So good.
>> Welcome back to coverage of Regional
Qualifier Atlanta. It is time, Shoma. We
have arrived at the best time really in
any big card game tournament. It is time
for the start of our top eight.
>> We started with 1,600-ish players before
the weekend. 64 of them, including these
eight, have qualified for the regional.
Congratulations to all those players who
have made it. Assuming the standings
have solidified themselves. Although, I
think there's maybe a little bit of
standings jelly to still iron out before
everything congeals. But, we have eight
players left and we have some very
exciting names in this top eight.
>> Yeah, we absolutely do. This is
a very good top eight, both in terms of
deck diversity, though I am relatively
certain that you were wrong about
>> Um but, we have some big names. We also
have some new players looking to make a
name for themselves and I am very
excited to talk about some of them like
>> Let's have a cheeky peeky at the
standings, shall we? And guys, let the
names unroll unfurl in front of your
eyes. Look at the eight players that'll
be probably more on this graphic, but it
is Coca Lopez, Prismatizm, Frosty,
Boulevard, Harakaze, Alanzq, Collin, and
Stahli. Our final Draven sneaking in in
the win and in in the Draven mirror we
just had on stream.
>> Yeah, this is a fantastic top eight.
When you're looking at names like
Collin, again, performed incredibly well
in the past, now on that set
representing the original legend that
they fell in love with. We have Alan, of
course, previous Regional Qualifier
winner, Ezreal specialist. We have
Harakaze, who we've seen on the
broadcast this weekend, great on Irelia.
Boulevard, Uh, I'm I'm just going to say
the quote. So, I was talking to
Boulevard during the break and Boulevard
said, "I really want to make top eight
>> Uh-huh.
>> because then all of the Legends of
Runeterra players will know that I
casted that game so that they could have
a chance."
>> We know that Boulevard is someone that
well, we both worked within Legends of
Runeterra for quite a while. Uh,
pleasure to be around, but not to play
against. Very, very good at card games.
Uh, has a hand in designing some as
well, which is pretty impressive. But, a
definitely a player that's uh fun
watching and has some spice despite
playing uh the most represented deck in
Draven. I have to point out Wait, no,
it's not six It can't be six unique
decks if there's three Dravens. It's
five Oh, including Draven.
>> Including
>> I believe that is one more than Leal as
far as deck diversity goes in the top
eight.
There you go.
It's at least similar.
>> Yeah.
>> It's similar.
>> There you go.
>> The The point is is that it's not
lopsided. It's not half Draven.
>> No. No, no. No, not like that. Not like
that. That's what happened. No, it's
not. And uh it's only three. Uh, one
less than the last time we were in North
America playing a regional qualifier.
And of course, that begs the question
apart from Prismatistism who I think at
this point is now become our de facto uh
player to win this event. I know you've
been uh
>> No, I I was going to say that's my de
facto. I actually think that there are
very reasonable takes otherwise. If you
had uh say argued for Alan, he's a
previous winner. Makes a lot of sense.
Uh, Colin is showing that he can win on
nearly any legend with this run on Set.
Uh, Boulevard, again, a lot of success
in other card games. Uh, is on Draven.
Uh, in fact, if you were about to ask me
if I had to pick somebody not named
Prismatistism, I actually might pick
Boulevard simply because while he is on
Draven, he has brought a very spicy
version of this list uh in terms of the
battlefields brought, but also some of
the cards included. Uh, there is, when
we hopefully get to it on the broadcast,
a purple Draven main deck. There is also
a red Rumble in there, he told me. I had
a wonderful discussion about why those
cards were included. I think that he had
a very good read on the room and it's
very clearly paying off for him.
>> Yeah, I mean for all of the talk of how
much Draven has represented across
Spirit Forge as kind of a season at the
original qualifier level, only has won
once. So, has a chance to do it again,
but it is not the Despite being the most
represented deck, it is not the most
dominant deck necessarily in the field.
Although, I guess maybe Vegas people
would feel a little bit differently.
Despite how excited I personally found
it really Draven mirrors.
Again, Prismatism I think the player I
guess we should talk about it cuz we're
going to talk about it at some point.
The player who we all have our eyes on
coming into this top eight has done just
about everything you can do in Riftbound
right now about from win a regional
qualifier.
>> Yeah, absolutely. Multiple top eights,
great performances in the third-party
tournaments as well. Continues to be
consistent and I think that's the real
measurement of skill. If you're new to
card games, you might not understand why
we're highlighting somebody like
Prismatism who doesn't have the big win
and the answer is simply it's hard to
win an event. You do need things to go
your way, but it is significantly harder
to be in the top cut, be in contention
time after time after time again. And
so, that is what is the standout when I
think about Prismatism. I will say as we
start to look at maybe the bracket as
that starts to coalesce, one of the
other things to keep an eye out for is
Frosty on that Kaisa because there is
three Dravens in the top eight and
Frosty looked very good earlier in the
weekend against a Draven on that Kaisa.
Looked very comfortable in that match up
and if things align for Frosty, could
just go on a run.
>> The funny thing about Frosty is actually
a player I met on Friday. I don't know
them. They just was like a fan of work
that I had done. Wanted to come over and
chat and they were practicing with their
buddy who actually was on stream playing
Musty yesterday.
And
I would like kept seeing this person on
stream. I was like, I feel like I know
this person. Did they top eight at a
different RQ? Like am I remembering it?
Oh, I met them on Friday. That's how.
And they said their goal coming into
this tournament was just to make top 64.
When I talked to them after they were I
think 10-0 after getting into the
feature match, they couldn't believe
what was happening. They were like, "I'm
sorry. I'm mentally readjusting to
what's happening right now. I have to
think about you know, I'm Oh, I'm I'm
not only probably going to win best of
Ka'isa, I'm going to be much better than
top 64. I'm almost assuredly in top
eight." Lo and behold, Frosty does make
it as uh expected. So, a player that is
uh
relatively new in some ways to success
at least at this level in Riftbound uh
looking to maybe break through and be a
new player we can keep our eyes on.
>> Yeah, and the interesting thing is uh
production was kind enough to let me
know that traditionally Ka'isa across
the field has a very bad match-up into
Draven. And a lot of times I think
that's on the back of Ka'isa potentially
struggling to deal with the Ferris
Forerunners, but Frosty's Yeah, Frosty's
version
uh dealt with it very well earlier.
Again, you had the right answers at the
right time and kind of I think
understanding that it was going to be a
battle of the Macs and using the Falling
Stars, the Singularities, uh even cards
like Smoke Skirmish to get those
favorable trades there. Uh I think
Frosty has maybe cracked how to pilot it
because I do think sometimes with these
lists, you look at it and you say,
"Well, uh every list is the same or
every pilot is the same." But there are
games that can be made if you kind of
adjust your play patterns, and Frosty
looked great.
>> Absolutely. Let's have a look at uh
Frosty's deck list. Uh this is at least
the main deck, and uh ooh, double time
warp. This is looking
like a very classic Ka'isa. This is the
kind of the first thing I said, and then
I realized there were two Forecasts in
the main deck.
>> Yes. Uh this is a card that it's been
included in a number of the Mind Domain
lists this weekend because it allows you
to get a lot of looks at your deck. Your
Macs have vision, and that triggers on
Forecaster when you play it because it's
a Mac, but also on your Forerunners. And
then also when your Forerunners are
cracked, when the Mac tokens enter play,
you get those triggers as well. So, this
is a way where you can ensure you have
that right card at the right time to
answer your opponents. And so, again,
might be a minor change on paper, but
has paid dividends for Frosty throughout
the event.
>> Yeah, but looking good. Again, this is
kind of a you know, the the best deck in
Arcanist certainly. Certainly the most
successful deck in that format. Kaiso
was the the most dominant force in that
meta game. You know what's kind of been
fun since Spirit Forge? Until today, no
Kaiso had ever made top eight at a
regional qualifier. Europe and NA did
not have any since Spirit Forge started
until right now.
>> Stay Frosty, my friend.
>> Stay Frosty. Well, I mean, we've talked
about kind of the heavy hitters. What
about the the wild cards? Cuz everybody
I think everyone's cheering for Set.
Collin is a a player that is easy to
cheer for. Very genuine, very lovely
guy, very good card game player.
And Set's just a fun deck. It's fun,
man. Who doesn't want Set to win? I want
Set to win. I don't even like Set that
much.
>> I am excited to see it in action once
again. Again, we saw earlier in the the
weekend, but it is a deck that I think
sometimes has struggled when piloting by
certain players because the resource
management is critical. It is a deck
that's very power hungry. You have to
essentially know your energy. You have
to know your power to pay for the heavy
body costs. You also have to know how to
manage your buffs, which I think is an
under thought about thing with that
list. Earlier, we were seeing
Darius lists that were using Rally the
Troops, for example, to get those buffs
for the monastery payoffs. Collin was
running the Arena Bar, for example, to
make sure that he always had that fresh
flow of the buffs. Again, understanding
that's a third resource I have to
manage, so let's make sure I have a
supply of it.
>> Yeah, I'm
Okay, so I have two Set stats that I've
just received that is kind of fun. So,
apparently, Set's win rate I assume this
is in Atlanta against Draven. You know,
the deck you expect to play against is
the most represented deck. 34% in Lil, a
cool 20%
here in Atlanta. Now, I don't think
that's very representative of Colin
during the break against Draven given
how good his record has been. But
against Annie, would you believe Set
looking pretty good. Do you want to give
any guesses about what Set Set's win
rate versus Annie might be?
>> Uh across the field, I would say Set's
probably
58% against Annie.
>> told, and I don't know if this data is
maybe skewed or there's something being
uh
misinformed, but that's it. That's the
win
rate versus Annie.
100%. It's literally unlosable.
>> I Well, that tells me a couple of
things. It tells me Prismaticism did not
play against the Set yet. Uh that also
tells me that
some of the Annies in the field just
might not have been prepared for units
that are both large and near unkillable
because the thing that separates Set
from some of the other just kind of spam
might decks is that Set legend ability
where you can spend the buff to get your
unit back to safety and then just get it
right back into the fray, right? Uh
Reavers' Row, as we know, was banned and
that had a very similar mechanic where
when opponents came in, you could kind
of save your unit, but Set's got that
baked in and I do think that there's a
situation where Annie lists might have
struggled against it, but I still think
100% is wild.
>> I I got to imagine the sample size is
particularly large for that one. So,
there may be something going on in the
back end and we'll take a little peek at
at some point. But uh thinking through
the rest of Top 8, Aurelia, I mean,
could get there.
>> Yeah.
>> I feel like we never have faith in
Aurelia, but maybe that's her time to
shine.
>> I had said, you know, again a couple of
times on the broadcast that I think
Aurelia was kind of due because we keep
seeing it get to the Top 8 and not get
the job done. Uh Harukaze did look great
on the broadcast earlier in the weekend.
Certainly a capable player. If they go
on to win it, I would not be surprised.
It is going to, I think, be a very tough
hill to climb just given the nature of
this top eight, however, because you're
going to have to be going up against
specialists, right? Caulin on the set
probably has a lot more games into
Aurelia than Harakazi does into set.
>> Yeah, oh, absolutely.
>> even if Harakazi has practiced against
Ezreal,
it's not the same as playing against
Allan on Ezreal. And so, that's the real
hill.
>> And I think that's the last thing we
need to talk about cuz that is the last
deck in our top eight. Ezreal, by the
way, didn't make it. Last year, by the
way, didn't make it. Not two things I
expected, actually. I thought you was
guaranteed to make it at least one of
them given that that deck, I think, had
pretty good representation and converted
quite well. We'll have a look at
Harakazi's deck list, though, cuz
Aurelia is a champion that you can build
in quite a few different ways. In fact,
if you cast your mind back to Vegas,
there was also only one Aurelia in the
top eight. It had Heart of Darkice. It
was a much slower, almost more
controlling build. This one, a little
bit of top end, but what's sticking out
to you here, Charmer, cuz again, there
are very many ways to let Aurelia dance
across the battlefield.
>> Yeah, the things that jump out to me are
the top end. We see that Mind Splitter
there. Yes, it's just a one-of, but
that's saying that Aurelia wants to
either have some hand disruption or just
have a naturally large might unit on the
back end. There is also that one-of Vex
that I'm a big fan of because when you
need to go in for maybe the game-winning
combat, being able to tax your opponent
at the right time also makes an awful
lot of sense. The other thing that jumps
out is earlier on the broadcast, we seen
a different version of Aurelia that was
brought by a team that did perform very
well. Unfortunately, none of those
members made top eight, but they were on
the sneaky deck hand, lower to the
ground version, and this one is very
clearly instead looking to play that
long game and then kind of come in when
things coalesce in their proper fashion.
>> Yeah, good. GA's are new things you can
play early two. Titan is in, of course,
there's three Desert Colossus kind of
filling out your early drop, two-drop
slot, as it were. Fizz, actually, one of
the also jumps out to me. You don't see
this that often in Aurelia, but I do
think even though it doesn't really work
with the you know things like not so
fast, hard bargain or defy, cards that
these decks are pretty notable for, does
work with a lot of other things that
rebuke being kind of an obvious one,
charm being a real winner there I feel
like as well, but fizz getting a decent
amount of mileage I kind of like that
one here and it's something I I'd
thought about in Aurelia, but I'd never
done it and it's now wild to see someone
in top eight with fizz in the main deck.
>> Yeah, there's a number of cards when I
was looking at that list where you might
have wanted to run another copy, but
it's hard to fit so many cards into a 40
card list. So, having that one fizz kind
of fills the role depending on the
situation. Need another ride the wind?
It's there, right? If you need another
defiant dance for like an offensive
setup, it's there. So, I like the one of
fizz.
>> I wonder how many boots does he put so
actually realize two, okay, that would
make sense. That's the number that's
usually pretty typical. We do have some
interviews though cuz Barrett has been
chatting with a few members of our top
eight, so let's go down to hear what
they had to say.
>> I'm joined here with one of your top
eight contenders, Colin Kaiser. I feel
like I've talked to you a lot this
weekend already because you have been
absolutely tearing it up here in this
tournament. How do you feel right now
locking in this top eight?
>> Honestly, it's incredible. This is going
to be my second top eight that I've had
now between Vegas and now and be to be
able to do it on my old passion deck is
honestly it feels incredible.
>> It's not even just the passion deck. I
mean, congratulations. You're obviously
already the best of set, so you've got
one trophy to put in the case now, but
how badly do you want to win it all?
>> I would love it, honestly. Just having
the ability to say that I'm the goat
unquestioned, unparalleled. I already
believe I'm the best, but to be able to
prove it to everybody playing a deck
that everybody wrote off would be
amazing.
>> Well, you're one of my favorites to win
it. I love set the boss myself, So, I
hope you bust some heads in top eight.
And who out of the other people that are
already locked as well, who do you maybe
want to avoid in the bracket?
>> Um at least until the finals, I'm in
with my teammate Coco. Uh so, if we
could get to be a finals of me versus
him, then what better could we ask for,
right? So, that's what I'm hoping for.
And uh outside of that, I'll take on
whoever decides to play me.
>> Well, I wish you luck as well as Coco
and Challenger TCG. So, good luck in top
eight.
>> Thank you.
>> I'm joined here with not only a top
eight contender, Coco, but actually your
Swiss champ after the end of two
rigorous days, 13 rounds. Coco, how does
it feel not only making this top cut,
but you're going to be going first?
>> It feels great. Being on the play with
Draven, I I can't feel any better, to be
honest. That's where I want to be at,
right?
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> So, now in that same mindset,
you are not going to be the only Draven
in top cuts. So, my question is, are you
really aiming for that best of, or are
you just like, it doesn't matter how
many Dravens are on the way, I'm just
aiming for that top prize?
>> I am looking for first place. And with
first place comes the best of as well.
So, we're looking for a win-win, baby.
That's That's all the way. That's what
I'm looking for.
>> So, I Are you maybe afraid because I
mean, there was a situation, I want to
say Bologna, where Draven was one of the
most played legends, it made top cuts,
and then boom, all of them lost in top
eight. Do you think that's going to
happen today? Obviously, you're going to
root for yourself, but if you're the
only one out, you'll auto lock in that
uh best of in the top four situation and
not have to worry about it.
>> That's true, but it then again,
I guess the best of doesn't matter to
me. Literally, first place is what I'm
aiming for. So, that's my goal.
>> Well, Coco, I wish you luck. Obviously,
I want you to give you some time, get
into the space, but congratulations.
>> Thank you.
>> I'm joined here with your top eight
contender, Irelia player Harukaze. First
of all,
how do you feel?
>> Honestly, it's surreal. I really didn't
expect myself to get this far. I've been
training a lot and it's been something
I've been like really proud about trying
to grind. Um, I'm very competitive
nature and then knowing that this is
something like, you know, so far up and
then getting it, I was like blown away.
>> Well, also congratulations. You're the
only Irelia in top cuts for such a high
represented deck, which means you're
already going home with a trophy, the
best of.
>> Uh, honestly, I was so nervous. I didn't
expect myself to actually get it cuz I
actually played against a mirror and
this was determining the best of and I
I'm so happy. It's incredible.
>> Well, okay, so obviously locking in a
little bit. You've got a little bit of
time to rest before we get into top
cuts, but is there a match up that
you're specifically trying to avoid?
>> So far,
Draven has always been the most
stressful. Um, fortunately I don't have
to worry about the mirror cuz that's
that's been difficult, but Draven has
been the one most stressful was um, I've
played I think like five or six Dravens
and I've won most of them, but
definitely something I still want to
avoid.
>> Well, it's good to know already on your
journey you are getting in comfortable
in that Draven match up. Don't have to
worry about the mirror like you said,
but congratulations once again, but uh,
if you have any shout-outs, you said you
worked really hard to get here. I mean,
so how about it?
>> Yeah. Uh, shout-out to all my friends
back in Connecticut. So we got Craig,
really big tester. We have Raffi, Alex,
um, Harry helped me a lot and then all,
you know, David's Good Game Cafe, you
know, one of my prime places that I go
to like play, so it's been fun.
>> Yeah. Well, you said Connecticut, so
I've got to I've got to go ahead and
peek the question. You're going to be at
Hartford?
>> I will. Yeah, definitely going to
Hartford with all my buddies there.
>> Well, I can't wait to see you there.
Good luck later today. Wish you luck.
>> Thank you very much.
>> I'm joined here with one of our top
eight finalists and man, Frosty, I've
got to say we've been watching you all
day today and I am so glad that you
finally get to represent Kaisa in a top
eight scenario in a regional qualifier
since Spirit Forge. How does it feel?
>> It doesn't seem real even after you say
it and it's apparently locked. Um
genuinely I was concerned about making
day two, let alone making it this far.
Um
so it's awesome, incredible.
>> It really is incredible and you're
incredible for doing such an incredible
performance. God, I think you're like
second seed across going into top eight.
So my question to you is you're probably
obviously going to you're easily going
to go first in this first little match
up and even your second one. But what
are you trying to avoid even if going
first is going to be an advantage to
you? What kind of decks do you not want
to run in or maybe even players?
>> To degree I think I have some level of
disadvantage against a lot of the top
eight opponents.
Um Draven I've had success today
but it's I don't think it's necessarily
a favored match up for me. Irelia is a
very difficult match up for my deck.
I think my variant has a better match up
into Irelia than a lot of other decks.
Um Alan Ziqu specifically if I'm second
and he slots into seventh being the the
win and in.
I played Alan five games I've won one of
them. Um and it was this match up um
with slightly different lists but I've
known I've known Alan for just a
month and a half or so and he's
definitely a an opponent I don't want to
sit across from in the first round.
>> I couldn't imagine sitting across from
him having seen him not only win a
regional qualifier but he's just such a
good, cool, and calculated player. So I
also hope you don't go against him cuz I
would like to see Kai'Sa have a little
bit more win. But speaking of you've
already locked in the best of Kai'Sa so
no matter what you're going to go home
with a trophy so that must feel great as
well.
>> Yeah, it's incredible. I'm playing with
a signed one
and it's an incredible upgrade.
Um
so
I don't it's it's hard to like that
isn't real to my brain yet.
>> Yeah.
>> Um
walking home with that is incredible. I
I was super super hoping to get top 64.
Like that was the dream. I heard I could
have an opportunity to go to Hartford.
Um So, I'm there.
Definitely going to be there for it.
Yeah. I'm going to take a semester off
of school,
play more, and then hopefully do well
there. So, hopefully we'll we'll see if
we can run it back.
>> I sure hope so, and I'm going to see you
there. Frosty, congratulations on your
top eight, and I wish you luck.
>> Well, Frosty doing a little bit better
than top 64, and you know what? It's one
top eight, that's enough. The first
semester, we're we're friend-pilled,
baby. You love to see it.
>> You know, it's not just that, but Frosty
said one win out of five games with
Alan, and they seemed kind of down about
it, but you and I were talking, and I
said that's a great win rate against
Alan. That would be enough for me to go
pro if I could beat him even once out of
five games.
>> My win rate versus Alan is
a flat zero, cuz I've never played him,
and I would like to keep it that way,
because I can tell for a fact I will not
do any winning against Alan, thank you.
>> You are somebody who can say you've
never lost to Alan. Yes, you got that
going for you.
>> I certainly have, and I think a very few
players can maybe maybe claim that, or
maybe there's a couple, you know.
I'm out there in side events today, but
I've also never played Alan, so have the
same distinction, perhaps. And that is
actually the player we didn't talk
about, but you know what? Let's have a
look at the bracket, cuz where these
match-ups fall is going to be so much
fun to see. So, where are we? We know
the seeds. Who's playing who? Oh, baby,
it's a dream come true. Up top, as Coko
Lopez plays Stardust. Boulevard is
playing the Aurelia player, Harukaze,
there. In our second match, Frosty is
playing Alan.
EMPHASISM IS playing Collin in the set
match-up.
>> Which is crazy, because we saw that stat
earlier where Sat has not lost to Alan
in all of the Atlanta regional
qualifier, so that is also a spicy one.
>> That is a spicy one there. And
unfortunately, after Prismata, it's I'm
actually looking. So, the Challenger TCG
players, they can play each other in the
finals based on this bracket. The uh the
friends of uh Prismata and Alan, their
teammates, they can only meet in the
semis.
>> Yeah, they could only meet in the semis,
but all of these players are uh again,
great. Uh I've seen the bracket now. I'm
still having a hard time picking who I
think would win it all because looking
at this, I think that bottom half looks
brutal. But then, on the top, Boulevard
has been very successful. Harikaze looks
good. Uh the the Draven slaughterfest up
top is going to be interesting as well.
I think Coco has the advantage. I'm
actually very happy that Coco mentioned
the seeding mattering. I think a lot of
times people are just aiming for that
top cut, and rightfully so. Top 8 is a
wonderful achievement. But Coco saying
in the interview, "I want to win. I'm
not just here for best ofs. I want to
win." And understanding that if I also
just keep winning out, that's going to
impact whether I go first or second in
the top 8, and I'm on Draven. I want to
go first.
>> I think in general, people in this meta
game have certainly gravitated to
wanting to go first. Oblisk kind of
undid some of the sting of going second,
but uh obviously that got banned with
for for good reason, I might add. And uh
going first has seemed quite good with
how uh
bo- uh battlefield centric or whatever
you call control centric a lot of decks
have been in this meta game. And I guess
with Draven and Aurelion running around,
that certainly makes sense. So, the
Dravens are going to slaughter each
other in the some capacity in the top
half, and then it is the wild west of
sweet decks in the bottom half.
>> Yeah. Now that you've seen the bracket,
do you change your prediction at all?
>> I don't think so. I feel like Prismata
is still the player we're going to be
watching on. I mean, look, if Collin
gets through, I think we're just we'll
follow him the whole way, and I hope he
makes it, but Alan is a player that
again, like it's funny looking at all
the match up data, right? Cuz it's
looking at a huge much significantly
bigger sample size than, you know,
individual players who will play cuz
they only played you know 13 rounds in
this however many games. And Alan, I
mean
Alan against those domains just doesn't
seem like he's going to lose very much.
So, if he gets there through kind of the
other decks that are a little
uh
that are not those, I kind of feel like
Alan might be running it back in a
different continent for once.
>> See, it's interesting because when we
see those stats for the overall spread
throughout the weekend, right? They tell
one story. But what jumps out to me is a
lot of the players that did make the top
eight have done so by finding success
against what should be an unfavored
matchup. Frosty said, "I don't think I
uh think Kaisa is favored into Draven
necessarily, but found a lot of success
today, right?" And then again, we've
seen probably small sample size, but
silly stat about Sett being
uh undefeated against Annie. And we've
got just silly uh Ezreal stats. That was
the other one that I was trying to come
back to. Uh a lot of the Ezreal stats
were saying that they were sub 50/50.
Some of them really unfavored, but
obviously
Alan's just built different. It does not
matter what he's up against. His win
rate is going to be drastically
different than the spread. So,
I think one of the things that you have
to look at is the player once you get to
the top eight because every one of them
has their own unique path, and that
includes beating their bad matchups. And
speaking of their own unique path,
>> All right. So, this is Collins run.
Again, this player was X O for quite a
while. 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 rounds undefeated
before finally picking up a loss.
Actually to a Draven player. So, he beat
Annie, beat Ezreal, Aurelia, Darius,
Draven, Riven plus took the L. Sam
Showman, actually that was the last
round of day one that we commentated
yesterday. And then lost
lost to open up day two, which never
feels good. And then win win win draw
into the top eight alongside Aurelia.
So, not a lot of Draven actually in this
run. A lot of different decks. more
elusive than maybe we'd expect. Another
deck that didn't make top eight that I
think we may have thought was going to
crack through potentially. But a pretty
fun run here and now thankfully for
calling, I guess, his run fairly diverse
and his top eight also relatively
diverse as well.
>> Yeah, looking at this run, another thing
that jumps out to me is
two wins against Victor.
So obviously being able to play into the
control decks very comfortably, not
worry about the removal, likely just
understanding how do I generate pressure
safely without over committing and that
could potentially give Collin yet
another edge should he move on to play
somebody like an Allen who's going to be
playing that control style.
>> very good against Aurelia in particular
which I believe Aurelia is on that side
of the No, maybe on the right other side
of the bracket. I'll come back to it.
No, let me check. Here's where
Prismaticism won a player that we've
been watching basically all weekend
long. Kicked off with the buy as always.
Aurelia Aurelia Azir Rexsai Sivir Victor
Draven. That is a very interesting
spread for those first eight rounds to
be eight and oh up to 10 and oh after
taking out the Azir and Draven and then
basically just continuing to run it
losing only to Frosty. So actually did
pick up the L against Kaisa but did not
have to play Set yet drawing in with
Coco Lopez in the last round after
taking out TuAli in our on stream match.
>> Yeah, I think that this run makes an
awful lot of sense to me when I'm
looking at it simply because the one
loss is to Kaisa. Sometimes Annie has
struggled against Kaisa especially the
versions that are off of sneaky decks
and off of maybe things like Rearguard.
So you have a little bit less accelerate
and that gives that Kaisa player more
time to find the removal, stop or slow
down that pressure.
But you can also see multiple wins
against Draven, multiple wins against
Irelia. Those are the decks you expect
to see as well as two wins against Azir
which yes, the representation didn't
uptick a ton from Leil.
But you still kind of expected it coming
in. So I think again, whatever testing
was done by Prismatism, having the
answers, making the right calls there,
did a wonderful job.
>> So, after looking at those, again, that
is us that is a top eight match that we
may well be watching. Certainly, that's
the one that's happening in this first
round of top eight, or one of the four
that's happening. Who do we think is
getting in there? How do we feel? Cuz as
you might noticed, Annie didn't play any
sets.
>> Right.
>> Colin set played one Annie and won. So,
doing the math a little bit, one player
is 100% against Annie in this tournament
who's playing in this match up, and the
other Annie player in on the other side
of that match up has 0% against Set.
There's nothing wrong with that stat at
all.
>> There's nothing wrong with it at all.
You know,
when I think about the match up, it's
going to be one that is hard to call
when I consider equal player skill. And
my reason is Set is very sticky. The
legend ability protecting your units
means that you're always going to be
able to get back into the battlefield
after combat. A lot of times Annie wants
to clear path, score points, and rinse
and repeat, but it's a little bit harder
to do when you do that clear path and
your opponent is still left with might
left over. This is a match up that could
very well be decided by who scores
first, could be decided by who's going
first or who gets that early tempo. So,
it's going to be close.
>> Yeah, I mean, again, Colin had to have
these decks on the mind when playing
building this Set deck. I Forerunner
seems like a tough card for Set
potentially crack, but we've also seen
Colin build like 20 plus might on a
battlefield including a tank unit. So,
Set certainly has the tools to grind
things out. I mean, body in general as a
domain can make a ton of might, but
I keep going back to something we heard
Turali say after losing actually to
Prismatism in jumping into the end of
that interview. Prismatism might have
the best deck in the room, and I think
if we're looking at Chaos and Fury as
the best domains, which
representation-wise would be true, I
feel like if Forerunner is the card to
beat, Prismatism is the best of playing
this card and you can see three
Forerunners hanging on out. We see the
Rengar, that's been the fun one. The Rex
are breached that sold out in the hole.
All the stuff we know and love or maybe
hate if you have to play against Over
Zael saying which is quite the card.
This deck, the fact that you can just
put a Forerunner on a battlefield and
then ready those runes. That simple
little change makes such a big
difference.
>> Yeah, if I was going to be looking for
an edge as Prismaticism, I would be
looking at the ways I can utilize my
tools without having to worry about
counter spells. So, cards like rebuke
get a lot of value, but also cards like
ride the wind can get you some
additional value as well because you can
hop on over when your opponent does jam
those big units back into you. Uh hard
bargain could maybe catch
Colin off guard. It's going to be an
interesting uh match up simply because
this is one of the few times we're going
to see these Annie players go against a
non-Cal opponent.
>> have a look at Colin's Setaka as well.
We've uh looked at it a few times. It is
Set Kingpin. The unusual one, not
Brawler. In the Chosen Champions zone,
something that's been very effective for
kind of Set's thing where sometimes he
does have to hold battlefields down in
order to get those points. Uh three
Fiora, three Lucian really leaning on
the power of those cards. Three
Sabotage, three Showstoppers, three Call
to Glory. Didn't notice that the first
time I looked at this deck list and then
a bunch of other pretty efficient units
that I can provide a buff for your team,
but really just a lot of straightforward
Set stuff, but it might look simple on
paper. It is very tricky in practice.
>> Yeah, I think the three Call to Glory is
100% worth it when you have three copies
of Arena Bar, you're always going to
have buffs available. And again, free is
so rare in this game. Being able to
fully commit, uh you know, I was talking
earlier about with Set, it's very
resource intensive and buffs are another
resource you have to manage, but this
gives you the ability to do so and then
utilize it to pay for cards like Call to
Glory. Uh I'm also glad you mentioned
Set Kingpin as well. Given that there
are so many Forerunners, all it takes is
Set plus one other buffed unit going in
and you can go over the top of a
forerunner and potentially not lose any
units because of the tank stat on set.
>> Yeah, set gets very big very quickly if
you're able to send in a few units and
buff and that one Kiku Mak might look a
little lonely but Fay Dragon also is a
pretty spicy one we did see Colin win
again with but enough about the yapping.
Let's have a look. You know what? Let's
let the players decide, shall we? That's
usually what we do here in top eight. It
is time to go down to the feature match
area where we have Colin taking on
Prismatism. Not the first time these two
have been in the same top eight but I'm
trying to remember. I don't think in
Vegas they played.
>> I don't remember them playing in Vegas
either.
>> No, actually.
>> Did they?
>> They did because
Wait, no no. Hang on.
So, I know that there was two Miracle
and two Midrange.
>> Yes.
>> And uh they were definitely both a
Miracle in that tournament. I tried to
remember if the Miracle players played
each other. I think they
No, they did. They would have made top
eight. So, no. They must not have played
each other.
>> I was going to say I thought Midrange I
thought it was Miracle versus Midrange
and Mid took both.
>> Yes.
>> That was the way that I remember.
>> That's what happened. And uh Sandy
Sherman, a Lucian player familiar today,
did not crack another top eight but you
know what? Still very impressive
showing. So, you are going to get ready
for game number one. Untimed rounds.
Open deck list. Both these players know
what's up. They're very very talented
and very found. This should be one hell
of a series.
>> All right and we're finally getting
ready to kick things off. Uh both
players opting to mulligan two cards.
Just wanting to make sure that their
hands are as good as they can be before
things get started.
And
>> And it's going to be Prismatism going
first. He's a pretty high seed in this
top eight so understandably wants to be
on going first whenever he can. It's
always funny to see some Perun's awaken.
>> Yes.
>> It looks like something went wrong but
no, that's just how Annie's legend
ability works.
>> It really does sometimes catch me off
guard. specifically when going second
and you just see one rune tapped but
like a red Rex Eye for example, cuz I'm
always just like, wait, that doesn't
cost one.
You're cheating, judge.
>> And the judge gets called, reminds you
of points taps Annie, taps the best of
Annie from LoR.
>> Oh.
>> And uh
>> So this uh this looks interesting. I
don't know if I see a unit in this hand
of Colin other than I was going to say
other than that first mate and obviously
you want to get some sort of presence on
the board but ideally that's something
that you want to take advantage of the
when played.
Little bit clunky, might explain why we
saw both players mulligan too.
>> Don't think it's ever arena by here. No,
it does have to be first mate. Doesn't
feel great but uh you do need something
on the board and Colin at least is going
to commit a unit on his first turn which
I think against Annie especially you do
have to do. Like Annie is the deck that
is trying to get uh get ahead early and
stay ahead for the rest of the game with
a bunch of little tricks she can use to
keep her units healthy and on
battlefields.
As Tide Turner going to be deployed to
base three ready again and Overzealous
Fan joins the Tide Turner that took the
point away from Monastery of Hirana.
>> Overzealous Fan is another one of those
cards that gets some additional value in
this match-up simply because
there's not a lot of targeted removal in
this list. You could do something like a
hidden blade but that's going to feel
really bad. You could have something
like a challenge but that's also at
least going to cost you a power so the
energy power spent is in favor of the
Overzealous Fan player a lot of the
times.
Uh Colin I think rightfully recognizes
I'm just going to go to the other
location, keep up on the point tempo and
then unless I missed it I think this is
just going to be on an arena bar cuz I
don't think it was another unit that was
picked up.
>> Yep, that is bar and uh kind of like uh
LoR that we were talking about at some
point earlier today uh Sett is a deck
that definitely gets most of its uh
removal done in combat. So when units
are on the battlefield they're pesky and
can push you away. Can be tough for
Set to crack through. He's going to have
to first mate to forward feels good with
that but again Set does want buffs to
spend. Very valuable kind of extra
resource that Set uh really only Set has
to manage with in this specific way. But
Prismatism still ahead on points going
to get a second one for holding and Tire
Turner maybe with a bit of help can
rumble over to the top but I pretty sure
I see a unit that has paid off every
single time he's been on stream. Ferris
Forerunner is back.
>> I was just about to say I have a feeling
we're going to see the Forerunner. I
think the question is just whether or
not you reinforce or you play this to
base to set up a future turn but the
goal of this Annie list every time we
have seen it has been play units on
curve
every turn but that third turn needs to
be Forerunner because it is a massive
amount of might. It's hard for your
opponents to deal with and it's also
again still going to leave you with the
runes up for some of your combat tricks
if necessary because of the Annie legend
ability. So, I think that's what gives
Annie an edge in these matchups.
I think a lot of the meta after this
granted we will be going into unleash
and that will change things but as
people analyze you know, what decks got
the advantage it will be based around
how could I play Forerunner and do
something else.
>> And uh one of the ways to do that is
simply to play Annie. So, Forerunner to
play runes at the ready flash available
almost always cuz again this is
definitely a deck that leans on the
power of flash.
Three copies in the main deck every
Prismatism and I can't imagine they come
out of the deck very often but coming
off of a bit of a slower start here
despite being able to hold in on the
battlefield does have some points.
But again Set not a deck that is as
let's say explosive at getting back on
battlefield. Every every deck has to
plan you know, what do I do when I get
behind and I have to retake control of
the battlefield? You can't just sit
there hoping to hold on that. Be the
only way you get ahead in a game of
Riftbound.
But uh there's certainly some trickery
here. Cards like Showstopper can help
with the mobility. Lots of different
things Set can do. Lots of lines to take
in. Usually Colin doesn't have this many
ruins that aren't recycled. So uh lots
of resources for Colin to play with as
well.
>> Yeah, I was just about to say there was
a Fiora that was picked up. So I think
the decision now is uh is that the play
with Arena Barge just to get that
online? Is this where you maybe develop
your chosen champion? Uh both would be
solid and yeah, it does look like
Kingpin is going to be the play
reinforcing over to that Seat of Power.
>> Seems like for now Colin's like, "You
know what? Uh that that Overzealous Fan
and that little Tide Turner, that's a
that's a later problem." And I think one
of the fun things about that is that
Prismatism has correctly taken control,
given the opportunity to take control of
a battlefield first, has decided to take
away Monastery of Hirana. Maybe
expecting that that we're going to be
split in this early game and saying, "I
do not want you to go. I cannot benefit
from this at all and it is incredible in
your deck." So you can have the Seat of
Power cuz if you can't take the other
one, you never drawing a card off of it
anyway.
>> Yeah, I was just about to say this is
actually a double denial cuz not only
are you stopping the draw from using
Monastery, but also you cannot activate
Seat of Power without presence at the
other spot. So you're putting yourself
in a position where you might get a
benefit from one of the battlefields,
but Colin cannot get any benefit until
they at least come get you off of the
Monastery.
>> All right. Well, Awaken Once More,
Ferris Forerunner, and now ready to
rumble.
As uh Set, as you can see, has uh one
extra might from the buff and then plus
two for each friendly buffed unit that's
at Set's location. But it counts
himself. That's why uh there's a plus
two for the die. So five, six, eight for
that Set plus four is 12 on the top
battlefield. There's a buffed Sea Monkey
that got played as well in the base.
Thanks to I think Arena Oh, Arena Sorry.
Arena Barge did of Kingpin. The Sea
Monkey can actually get a buff if you
pay one extra energy for it. It's one of
the nice things about the flexibility of
that as an early drop. And then still
only four might down in the bottom
battlefield, but uh underselling uh
Oversoul's fan a little bit there.
>> Yeah, underselling that. There's is also
a whopping seven runes available to
Prismatocism who just passed on that
last turn. But again, I think
Prismatocism has the time to be patient
here. Was able to score first as I
mentioned before. That could just end up
being the difference maker throughout
this series because that's going to
force Colin to have to do something to
unseat Prismatocism. And ultimately, it
looks like we're going to see a Kai'Sa
and a Rek'Sai come down. So just
reinforcing
uh the base a bit after moving that
Ferris Forerunner over to the monastery.
>> We talked to about something quite a bit
over the course of this weekend that I
want to highlight here. We've talked
about, you know, taking turns where
you're trying to maybe take action, you
know,
take out units, take points, uh you
know, jockey for position, you know,
maneuver yourself. And we've talked
about development turns, right? Things
where you just say, "You know what? I
can't really do much this turn. I need
to build up more resources. Maybe need
to put some units into my base so they
can ready on my following turn." And I
think the thing about Annie that kind of
breaks that parity is that you don't
have to really take off turns. You can
have development turns and also turns
where you still have interaction up. So
you kind of get the best of both worlds
in some way. I mean, this Forerunner is
now holding down the fort with an
Oversoul's fan. And Prismatocism has two
runes up and still played two units that
turn.
>> And not just two units, two incredible
units as well. So spent a lot of energy,
but did develop for a future state as
well as still holding up some
interaction.
The thing that I really like here is by
getting that Rek'Sai out and by moving
the Forerunner over, two things were
accomplished. First, you reinforce the
monastery knowing that you're about to
spend a lot of your energy. Yes, you'll
still have at least one reaction in
play. But if there's any tricks that is
maybe unforeseen from Colin, you have
the extra might there. There's also this
kind of future play where if Prismatism
has something like a Ride the Wind, for
example, uh you could Ride the Wind over
from your other spot, maybe
unexpectedly, trade with some of the
might on the Seat of Power with your
Forerunner, but then accelerate because
of the Rex Eye that you just developed,
and then resend in some max. So, there's
a lot of options available to Prismatism
just by taking a turn to kind of do this
setup. And now we're going to have a bit
of a
reaction check here as Colin moves in.
>> Yeah, checking out the uh
the battlefield. There's a lot of might
here, so the Sea Monkey isn't going to
get that much work done, but we have uh
passed on Fan, given that we're now
playing an action, which challenge is.
So, going to challenge the first
Forerunner, going to get two max, uh
going to get the option of Rex Eye, but
I don't think we're going to take it in
this instance. So, it was it is quite
funny. Uh let the Sea Monkey do battle
uh with the other two might units that
are there. And the Sea Monkey's only
going to be able to beat one of them. I
have to imagine the other one as Fan
isn't going to make it, but Prismatism
saying, "Yeah, I don't really want to
save my unit. I'm happy with the Here's
to Glory." gets played, takes the buff
off the other battlefield, something you
do get to do with this card, and buffs
up the Sea Monkey to try and win this
combat.
>> Yeah, that's right. The alternative cost
for Call to Glory is simply spend a
buff, not spend a buff on the target
unit. Prismatism is going to use that
two energy that was left up for this
flash, save the might that's again
likely why the pass occurred on the Fan,
knowing that the backup flash was there.
Uh we might see another interaction here
as well with Monastery of Hirana. Uh
that also says spend a buff to draw a
card. Does not have to be the buff on
the unit that is doing the conquering.
Uh I still expect that to be the case
cuz there's not really a reason to pull
it off to Kingpin on the other side, but
worth noting that uh like I was saying
before, your buffs are essentially a
third resource when you're piloting set.
>> Yeah, and Sea Monkey keeping the buff at
least coming into the combat was nice
cuz if
you know it did end up getting traded,
you could have potentially used set's
set's legend ability to save the Sea
Monkey at the cost of the buff. Instead,
Colin's doing a bunch of might math cuz
it might have looked like something's
happened there, you know, First Mate and
it did go down and two units went back
to base, but unfortunately, the might
that was at that bottom battlefield has
not changed. It's broke into some little
baby max.
>> That is correct. There was 10 might
there to start and despite all of that
from Colin, there is still going to be
10 might available to Prismatism, but
more importantly for Colin, he has taken
the points lead. As I said before,
Prismatism scored first, so the onus was
on Colin to kind of break that
stalemate, jump ahead on points, and now
it's going to force Prismatism to do
something to get that lead back.
Prismatism obviously has a lot of units
available, so options will be a plenty.
>> It does spend the Sea Monkey buff to
draw a card, and I think the other thing
to consider is, you know, you might want
to rebuff some of these units. I've been
reading about can rebuff the Sea Monkey,
but notably the unit does have to be
exhausted for Arena Bot to buff it. And
I'm mostly thinking up top there with
set Kingpin who does want to have buff
friends around him, which kind of makes
a lot of sense if you look at that guy.
But First Mate's going to be a tough
unit to exhaust, but you know what is
easier? If you just reinforce instead.
Sithria going to get played, and Fiora
also going to move in, and something's
going to get a buff. Sithria's going to
get a buff for seeing
another unit. It is yep, another unit
buff for me, and then Fiora's going to
get buff too by Arena Bot, which makes
her makes her mighty and turns on all
her other abilities, shield, gangking,
and deflect. So a lot of threat built
into this board, even if Colin is isn't
quite ready at the battlefield to do as
much fighting, let's say.
>> That's right. And First Mate is also
going to move back to the base, and I
like that move.
>> Pulling the First Mate back simply
because uh Colin did expend all of the
energy. That means cards are not
available outside of Call to Glory.
>> And that is opening things up for
Prismatism to again kind of
counterattack, right?
>> You have this math problem. You know the
might on the board. You can calculate
the maximum worst-case outcome of two
more Call
>> the Glories cuz you've seen one.
>> And you can navigate things uh in a
pretty standard way here. I think the
real question is uh how many units are
you going to lose in the process and or
how many cards you have to spend from
hand because the one thing I am noting
is because Prismatism has essentially
just played units after units after
units, the hand size is getting kind of
small. Both players only have two cards.
>> Yeah, and both the Cadre Battlefields
have basically been shut off up until
this point. The Kaiza a good way to draw
a card, so actually going to move in
here for the Conquer and does succeed
alongside of a mech friend. So, now
finally the cards are starting to flow,
but if you can get over to the Seat of
Power, it would be a similar story.
Actually, we get to draw two cards on
the turn, which would feel pretty good.
Colin already unlocked Monastery and
drew a card, so Prismatism answering in
kind with the Kaiza, but what do we do
with the rest of the units? We'll have a
quick might count first on Prizer's
side. 2 4 6 + 6 is 12.
And it is a two for the Sitria.
Uh
oh goodness. Uh six more
>> Yeah, there's 10
>> and then 10, yeah.
>> Yeah, there's 10 on the the Seat of
Power currently for Colin, and I really
liked that uh move into the Monastery
from Prismatism because again, talking
about what you need to play around,
moving exactly that seven might. Even if
there was a single Call to Glory, you
could have taken it. So, you're really
only worried about, as I said before,
the worst-case scenario that the last
two cards in hand are also the last two
Call to Glories in the deck, not likely.
And this also just kind of guaranteed
that you get that draw from Kaiza.
>> Yeah, now it's a matter of how much we
want to push here. And I think that I I
like here from Coven just by kind of
having those uh background units at the
ready as well is that leaving these
units on here, yeah, your your chosen
champion might die. And Set Kingpin's
pretty bulky. Can maybe sometimes feel
better, but uh you can always save
something with Set if there's a buff on
the unit and you have to if you get in
combat with Set, you must take him out
first because of that tank. So it is
very costly even if you do manage to
take out the Set cuz Coven just spends
the buff, recalls him back to base, and
basically threatens to do it all over
again.
>> Yeah, that is
>> It's like the meat grinder.
>> Yeah, I was going to say that is where
the Set deck has the potential to pull
ahead of Prismaticism just by
maintaining the might. They're both
trying to do the same thing but in
different ways. I think Prismaticism is
trying to accomplish that with Flash.
Flash has been like the marquee card in
these any matchups, whereas Coven gets
to do it for a buff and a power because
of the legend ability. I think right now
if those exchanges kind of continue down
that path, Coven becomes a little bit
favored just because the number of cards
available to Prismaticism has been
dwindling. Got a little bit better after
that Kaiza conquer, but uh you can't
just count on always having it.
>> The other thing about Kaiza conquer is
unless you flash her back to base, you
kind of have to reconquer for the draw.
So she's kind of an extra card draw
every other turn for the most
you have I don't know, Genking or
something, some other way to move her
around. I guess Ride the Wind does
exist, so it is possible, but for how
powerful Kaiza conquer is, uh
it's only, you know, it's not the best
uh four energy card draw engine, I would
say, present in this topic. I think that
title probably belongs to Stellar Corn
Herder when it's online. But uh still
getting kind of thin on resources for
both players here, and there's a lot of
decisions to consider.
In fact, Prismaticism might just be
saying, "You know what? Set Kingpin is
too scary. I don't want to go there. I'm
going to reinforce at least with one
mech on the bottom side.
And there's Annie coming in. Get the
flash back. That's another way to kind
of draw a card as it were from your
chosen champion zone.
And we go again with five more.
Time for traveling merchant and time for
Rexai Breacher.
>> So again, just developing my I think
that Prismatism
decided I don't have the interaction
that I want to go into the seat of power
yet. Uh yes, I had the might where I
could have just pushed in and forced
some trades. Could also still opt to do
so.
Just decides to develop first.
>> Yeah, not a lot of threat other than
Coda Glory on Colin's side. With all his
runes exhausted, so I don't think it's a
too risky.
And every And everything is being
considered here by Priz.
Oh, I do see a pretty spicy one. I see a
Ride the Wind alongside that flash.
>> Right. So earlier, I think the reason
that Prismatism was taking the time to
decide, do I want to develop, was there
was a play pattern if you really
disliked your hand, you could have sent
your units in that 10 might on 10 might
to just get a full clear without
conquering, and then you could have Ride
the Winded the Kaisa over, which would
have allowed for another draw. But I
think Prismatism just felt more
comfortable developing the might. Again,
planning for the future. Just staying
within striking distance of Colin to
close things out. I think that what
Prismatism is trying to do here is
mitigate the impact of Set's legend
ability. It's the sort of thing where
yes, it goes in Colin's favor if you can
play the attrition game, but you can
deny that by just avoiding combat, so
there are no units to save. You're kind
of invalidating the text on the Set
legend.
>> Yeah, I think that makes a lot of sense.
I think it's just a matter of how do you
find an extra point at some point in the
game? Cuz as you mentioned, Colin did
find a way back in front as as as the
points race goes. And uh different Fiora
is now going to be exhausted on the seat
of power, given a buff, and uh Colon is
really committed. Oh, really committed
to just holding down the fort in the
seat of power. A pretty aptly named
battlefield, but uh this is kind of one
of the things this set deck gets to do.
Uh maybe secretly one of the better hold
decks in Spirit Forge, cuz uh
unless you get a rebuke for that
Kingpin, it is really tough to crack
through, and I will know. Prismatism
does have a rebuke somewhere in the
deck, but right now it is just a uh
battle to hold as much might as possible
on one side of this rift.
>> When you talk about game design, and
specifically designing card games around
existing properties like League of
Legends, a lot of times you hear about
trying to live that character fantasy.
>> Mhm.
>> This is the set fantasy. You are
literally the Kingpin on your seat of
power, surrounded by a buff
horde of units.
Everybody on your team has abs at this
point. You're just saying, "Come fight
me, bro, or I will sit here and win the
game."
>> Yeah, and that is uh that's going to be
pretty close to 20 might also, if not
more. And this is something that Colon
has done on stream already in the
coverage we've had so far in Atlanta,
and probably something he's done most of
the weekend here. As Priz considering
their options.
Again, a lot of might at home, but I'm
not going to do the math. I just can't
imagine it's more than what Colon's got
sitting at that top battlefield, which
again begs the question. Once you get to
the point where it is the game is even
in reach, if we just played a hold for
the rest of this game, well, Colon's
going to win this game one, and I don't
think that's how it's going to go, but
what is the plan?
>> Well, there's another consideration
here, which is yes, right now the onus
is on Prismatism to break the stalemate,
but also the presence of these Fioras,
knowing that they both have ganking,
means that yes, it looks like Colon is
just sitting there passively, but
something like sending the Fioras over,
following it up with a showstopper,
Colon has just as much mobility
available as Prismaticism does with
those ride the wind plays. So, you can't
just feel comfortable on your side. You
kind of have to worry about what your
opponent is doing from the other end as
well. And it is going to, you know,
potentially be a situation where if you
let this go to seven, for example, then
Collin could just surprise you on your
side from the seat of power. Again, that
First Mate is what saves out to me
talking about the Showstopper plays cuz
it's just hanging out on base. It could
have been somewhere else. So, the fact
that it's there tells me that Collin
wants to have both something in reserve,
but something unbuffed in base to
potentially abuse Showstopper when the
time comes.
>> All right. Well, we're going in because
that Rebuke I mentioned has bounced set
Kingpin back to Collin's hand.
And now, this flash is going to bring
units back to base cuz they're going
somewhere else. This is the offensive
use of flash we do get to see every now
and then. Much like in League of
Legends, you can flash both defensively
and offensively. And again,
Pris Pris has counted it. I'm not
counting it yet, but I have to imagine
everyone is getting in the pool.
>> Yeah, absolutely. I mean, if you're just
looking at how much might he was
thinking about picking up there, that
was 16. There are four three might units
and then two two might units. Kang just
tells me that that is 16.
I went to his math school so that I
could learn how to count. And
I really like this. You know, he You
said it was an offensive use of flash,
and I think that's actually named
because this is kind of offending me. I
It is very offensive with how
beautifully navigated Prismaticism has
shifted over. And like I said, I think
that there might have been some fear of
these buffed Fiora's with their ganking
setting up their own move over. And I
think Prismaticism is just trying to get
a jump on Collin's game plan.
>> Yeah. Traveling Merchant stays at home,
but that is 18 after the assault from
the Rex Sai. So, five for each Fiora
means 10 and only two for little Sitria.
Means 12. Punch first is going to be
plus five, but 12 plus five is only 17.
So, Pri has done the math and realized
that at least a single punch first is
not enough in this spot.
>> And this punch first is
protected from hard bargain cuz there is
still four energy available.
So, Collin at least has that part. We
could also still see something like a
call to glory or some other
option here.
>> This is going to do a lot of damage.
Don't forget Oh, ride the wind. Who's
coming over? It's got to be Kaisa hoping
to get that draw Oh, or it could be
Annie.
If you want to save the Kaisa. Kaisa is
definitely going to get chosen as one of
the one of the units that does not get
to live if you move Kaisa over. So,
instead wants to win the combat here by
moving three extra might over and Annie
not usually an an offensive unit in this
deck does get the job done with ride the
wind. So, Ty Turner gets to live.
Everything else goes away except the
unit that Collin saves with his set
eligibility and that is going to be one
of his two Fioras.
>> And still a very solid unit to save
because the arena bar is there. You will
kind of have to finagle getting it on
there though cuz as you had pointed out
arena bar only buffs exhausted units.
That Fiora is going to ready during the
awaken phase of the next turn.
>> And actually another Overzelous fan is
now to reinforce alongside that Ty
Turner six points now for for Prismat.
Another fan alongside that Kaisa in the
bottom side. This is kind of position we
saw
Pri navigate to in a previous match we
had on stream where two fans on each
battlefield threatening to hold for the
win and Traveling Merchant even just
straight up draws a card because Pri ran
out of them to do all of that.
>> Yeah, incredibly efficient. Used every
card in hand to go ahead in the points
lead and then saved that Traveling
Merchant to send safely to a location.
Eventually, we got to that card draw
that I thought Kaiza might be trying to
get, but you are correct. Kaiza would
have died naturally.
>> Traveling merchant instead. I wonder
what state home. Very very efficient,
very clever use
of all of the might available.
And Kaiza actually going home anyway,
wants to hold on to a pretty valuable
unit, ready to ruins,
and passes it back on over. Colin now on
the spot where he is behind on points
once more. And worse than that, if he
can't figure this out somehow, uh
prismaticism is just going to win game
number one. Now, thankfully, there's
enough might already to at least do
something about the Overzelous fan, but
giving your opponent another point
doesn't feel great either, especially
when they can have they can conquer the
other battlefield and still win. It's It
is about scoring though. Sometimes you
hold them both, but sometimes you just
uh hold one and then score the other.
And there's already units back home to
try and do that with.
As Overzelous fan's going to kick out
the first mate that rumbled on in, and
Fiora also going to come going to come
through as well, because Colin also
wants to get to six on the other side.
Going to be hard to win, or at least
threaten to win, if you don't get the
points. But exposing a Fiora to the
battlefield doesn't feel great either.
>> Yeah, you
have to expose the Fiora to the
battlefield. I liked the use of the fan
there. It was going to die in combat
anyway, so unless you're saving it, you
might as well send the first mate back,
and then that forces Colin to commit yet
another action, yet another resource
just to retake the monastery. It also
means that, as you pointed out, Fiora is
stranded there.
We have a Kaiza in the base, and uh with
another card draw attempt, we could see
prismacism with something like a rebuke,
and then just a simple walk in.
>> I mean, whatever Colin plays from this
point is, unless Shurima's Legacy
involved, is uh not going to be on a
battlefield. It's going to be in base,
and that is not all that helpful. I
guess sorry, reinforcements could happen
as well, and that is exactly what's
going to happen. My brain corrects
itself. It is a long day, folks, but
it's been a fun one so far. And we're
only early. And the round of eight is
set. Kingpin comes back down from the
hand after being unceremoniously
rebuked.
And uh going to hang out with Fiora, but
no buffs on these units means that extra
little bit of text on Set is not nearly
as good. Fiora actually doesn't even
have her abilities right now. And the
Monastery for Iona didn't get utilized
to draw a card. So, it's all going wrong
for Set cuz uh the buff guy has got no
buffs.
Finally getting one there thanks to
Arena Battle.
>> After that big round of combat, all of
the units on Collin's side lost their
buffs. They have to go back to the gym,
hit leg day once again. Fiora is back
online after the Arena Battle does place
the buff on her. That's going to give
Set Kingpin that plus one passive.
So, there's still a healthy amount of
might there that Prismatism would have
to go through. Uh I think that this is a
safe bet from Collin simply because he
knows Prismatism had one card left and
that was just off the draw from the
merchant. So, it's not something that
was maybe tactically saved. Could get
lucky off the top deck, but
that plus another top deck is all
Prismatism is going to have to work
with. I think the real question is
Prismatism, once he goes to seven, is he
going to want to try to just hold seat
for the eighth point or is he going to
draw enough where he thinks that taking
the Monastery is possible?
>> Yeah, Akshan actually being played here.
This is the one copy that Collin has in
his main deck and there's no gear to
steal. Oh, no. Yeah, no gear to steal.
No equipment out there. There are a
couple longswords in Prizer's deck, but
not on the field for Akshan to thieve.
So, instead just uh deciding where is
Akshan going? Have to feel like you're
kind of committed to this battlefield
here. So,
he's looking to reinforce.
But maybe not.
>> Yeah, this is an interesting decision
simply because by playing the Akshan,
you are also signaling that you have one
card left in hand and the only thing it
can be that would be playable would be a
call to glory by spending Fiora's buff
because all of the energy is going to be
spent. Uh and I'm kind of with you. I
could see the auction going on the
battlefield knowing that if Prismaticism
takes it, that's it. But I think Colin
is banking on the fact that uh if
Prismaticism cannot get over the hump,
Colin goes to seven and needs to have a
way to take the other side. So, this is
a one of those situations where there is
playing to not lose and then there's
playing to win. And I think Colin has
assessed this and saying there's no way
that I can win. If he's got it, he's got
it. But if not, this is the proper play.
>> Have to agree as that looks like Feras
Forerunner going over to the other
battlefield.
Chris is going to make it as hard as
possible to get up top. Flashback. Oh.
Moves the traveling merchant, draws
another card. Actually just literally
committed for the card draw. That is two
energy draw a card. And that is good
enough right now.
Go against stack deck, gets another
look.
Ride the wind.
Is that enough?
Kaisa moves over. I don't
>> Well, Kaisa is going to move over the it
I was going to say if the card in hand
is something that Prismaticism doesn't
like, then the merchant could also go
back and do another filter. But I think
Prismaticism liked that and opted to
just leave the merchant and save it. But
again, that was all about cycling to
make sure that you felt comfortable with
your options.
Now it all comes down to what does Colin
have
to get over there? There is again a
Fiora with Ganking.
>> Yep.
>> We have the auction and the first mate
in base. The hand is it looked like a
challenge.
>> Mhm.
>> That set Kingpin is a six, so big enough
to challenge uh even the Forerunner
potentially and break that into some
max.
>> Easy to make a seven if you want. I'm
moving back home and using arena bar.
So, uh if you want cuz it's not
currently buffed, surprisingly.
Although, I guess there would have been
fewer would have been buffed, so it's
kind of all the same.
>> same. It's It's six either way.
And ultimately, again, because that set
does not have gang king, uh unless you
were trying to move it back and then
buff it with arena bar to set up
showstopper, that certainly could be an
option, but
it feels like if that challenge is used
on something like the forerunner, it's
just to get the might off of the
opposing battlefield.
>> Cuz I think uh yeah, you kind of have to
make the decision. Actually, I guess no
matter what you're locked in cuz
you have to break the other battlefield
or Prizza's going to win. And uh if you
don't
>> Yeah, this is
>> Uh and sorry, and if you do that and can
conquer, you're going to win cuz
>> You're going to Yeah, this is literally
the make or break turn. The game will be
decided here one way or another.
>> All right, so fingers are tapping the
table. Numbers are being added up. Eyes
are being rubbed again. It's been a long
day
>> Yeah.
>> for these players. Been a long day for
us. Half time.
Has been a long weekend.
It's first mate. Hello, I would like to
deal with the over zealous fan issue.
How do you feel about that?
Still thinking.
So curious with the last few cards. I
guess we know that challenge. I wonder
what the last one is.
Prizza's only with one
>> Uh it's a first mate.
>> Okay.
>> So, you could also have That's actually
very relevant cuz you could have a
situation where that set kingpin comes
back and then is readied by the first
mate. So, everything on the monastery is
mobile for the purposes of this turn and
that also explains exactly why Colin is
agonizing over it. Uh that tells me
we might have a situation where the I
was going to say the
Oh, okay. I thought we might have a
situation where the challenge was
not used uh on a unit that would kill
the set given the first mate, but this
works, too.
>> So, you know what I just realized?
If the last card is ride the wind
>> It is.
>> Then that form of dying actually makes
ride the wind three extra might on this
battlefield instead of one. Who's
traveling much of doing another card
doesn't do anything cuz prison doesn't
have any runes left.
All right, so units being picked off.
Fan does get sacrificed.
Yep, here comes the Fiora. Fiora ganking
across five.
>> This is This is so tough for Collin
because again that's one of those
situations where if you knew exactly
what you were up against, as weird as it
sounds, the correct play is probably to
have challenged the Kaisha with your
kingpin so that it survived and then
sent it back, played first mate, and
then also shipped it forward. But you
wanted to get rid of the most might on
the battlefield.
>> Oh, it's rebuke. It's not ride the wind.
That's so much better.
>> Well, that explains even more.
>> Yeah.
>> So
have to play the deflect if we're
targeting the Fiora, but that seems
fine.
Unless it's first mate. Yeah, there's
not enough there.
Oh, there it is. Hang on a second. What
happened there? Collin wins game one and
my brain is a little bit busted trying
to figure out like if rebuke just wasn't
enough.
Replayed again. First mate moved back
in. I think that might have been good
cuz Arena Battle still available.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. Okay.
A very complicated game number one
between two incredible players and
Collin is going to take game number one
on set. The boss.
>> Yeah, because it was rebuke and not ride
the wind.
That does mean that you get to replay
and then do the first mate. So that's
actually why he was okay with giving the
kingpin up. Knowing that it's likely to
be a rebuke, you have the first mate to
replay whatever goes back. I do think
that there's still a world where perhaps
the kingpin surviving
just killing off the Kaisha and then
going in gets it done but either way
Colin expertly navigated around the
things that could potentially harm him
gets game one and you got to feel pretty
good cuz that was also a game where
prismaticism was going first.
>> Mhm.
You get to go first in the last game now
as you do game of again number two
traveling merchant is going to be be the
two drop of choice arenas greatest gives
both players a point. No one's missed it
this time well done folks top eight.
They are sharp about these things do you
may notice the players a little bit
tired again it's been a long day I've
seen Colin yawn in his play cam seen
prismaticism kind of rub their eyes in
theirs and fun fact after that game
Chris got up did a couple push-ups after
getting up out of the chair to wake up a
little bit lock in for the rest of this
match.
>> I don't blame him.
>> I don't either again.
>> If if I got beat by set I would hit the
gym immediately because clearly that's
the difference between
>> wasn't buff enough.
>> what if anything that what set teaches
us is traveling merchant can hit the
sunken temple to two points we go it's a
bit of a shorter game this go around
by a single point.
Lucian the first play there for Colin on
the draw.
>> Yeah I will say I really like this
inclusion of Lucian in Colin's list even
if you're not very equipment heavy
because of the first time it conquers a
ready is allows you to still get in and
get out it's something that gives you a
little bit of additional mobility even
without equipment you can still throw a
buff on Lucian which makes him big
enough to trade with those all important
formite units.
Yeah it doesn't cost power.
>> Yeah plenty of pumps as well we've seen
plenty of pumps first quarter glory etc
in this list so kind of ways for Lucian
to be in some ways a removal spell in a
roundabout way throwing his body on the
line.
>> There is also
situation where with Akshan if you're
playing against opponents that have
equipment Akshan could still attach to
Akshan's self with weapon master and
then you could play Lucian to move it
over.
>> Does that Lucian also have weapon
master?
>> Yes.
>> Yes, so you could just steal it and then
play Lucian to move it over as well.
>> That's what I just said.
>> Oh, I thought you said the other way.
>> Well, no, cuz Akshan has to steal first.
>> Yes, yes, yes, yes, yes. That makes
sense.
>> All right. You know what? You got me.
I listened mostly, we can say, as uh
There's a shuffling away and uh Pit
Rookie is the next play here. He's going
to buff up that Lucian, you have to
imagine. And Lucian is going to travel
somewhere. It is six might right now at
the Sunken Temple.
Little bit spooky, so instead we're
going to go to the top, off to the arena
to pick up a point. Already got one from
the start of the game and wants to get a
second and does do so.
>> And the points are now even up.
And the even thresholds are still
important. No Aspirants climb. Yes, we
started with Arena's Greatest, which
gave everyone a free point, but that
standard stay on even path
feels
uh again the game plan for these
players.
>> Yeah, kind of one of those things where
just getting that first conquer, getting
you to the even point makes makes things
a little bit faster. I've actually seen
already today how some players are just
holding their units back until they can
start getting two points because you
want to maybe wait and see, set up a
little bit better of a position for
yourself. And that first point not as
important as the first two, as it turns
out. As Arena bar comes down, going to
buff up the Pit Rookie as well.
>> And again, there's
>> that mobility from the Lucian, got the
conquer ready, gets to go home. And in
many ways it makes this Lucian a
nightmare to deal with specifically with
Sett because on the off chance you ever
do get rid of it, you could still use
the Sett legend ability to save the
Lucian as well.
>> The tie is in a
going to move the merchant. Get another
discard and a draw filtering away and
overzealous fan. Prismatism digging for
something else. Did not have forerunner
on curve this time around.
>> Every time he's at six wins
they've just played the forerunner very
swiftly to a battlefield usually, so at
least Colin can be thankful that's not
happening and Z is putting up a pretty
decent board over there already, so not
just hopeful, very efficient format unit
that's often on the cheap.
>> And after the hold plus the conquer from
the merchant means that prismatism goes
from two to four. Again, trying to stay
on that even pointed
pace. I think there was a decision about
whether or not to send the hopeful back
to the base. I think that that would be
safe. There's an awful lot of might in
the base of Colin.
You have to assume that they would be
able to take both locations unless you
have tricks that you're confident in.
But instead we're just going to see
another hopeful.
>> The opposite is reinforce. You know
what's better than one hopeful at a
battlefield? Two hopefuls at a
battlefield. 10 might now.
On that bottom half of this play mat.
The sunken temple is a very crowded.
But a fun fact, no mighty units have
visited just yet. In fact, there's no
mighty units on this board as of right
now.
See if Colin can change that as he looks
to rumble in. Starting off with the easy
one, Alushin going to move up to the
top. Four might versus two is an easy
win and that's three points up for Colin
as Alushin will ready on conquer.
>> Yeah, I think I like this decision by
prismatism to try to hold here because
again, Colin was trying to keep pace on
these even numbers.
>> Right.
>> Prismat went two, four. Colin here has
to go through that 10 might if they also
want to keep pace and I think just
prismatism wants to play with the lead.
The moment that prismatism lost that
point lead, it came
it became very difficult for him to get
some of those retakes in and I think
that this is a situation where he
recognizes that. Also, probably wants to
hold it because if you do finally find
that forerunner that he finally did not
play on curve. You need a spot to play
it.
>> You certainly do. And you want to make
sure you're hanging out somewhere. What
better than the Sunken Temple? As
everything awakens, uh Lucian does
indeed go back after Fiora, reinforces
the arena's greatest, gets a buff thanks
to Arena Bot. There's actually nothing
but buff units on Colin's side of the
board, which is pretty much what you
want to see when you're playing Set the
Boss. And uh quite a lot of might in
reserve to
try something in this 10 might stack.
It's in that temple. But first, deep in
thought once again.
>> Yeah, I think that Prismaticism is going
to go into the tank a bit here simply
because
you see the hand. It's a lot of reactive
options. I think I saw a couple of
rebukes, a flash.
And this is exactly why we're going to
see the Annie for a stack deck because I
think Prismaticism knows there's not
enough might on the board to deal with
Colin's might.
So, you have to go find something to
continue to hold this. Also, if I'm
being honest, you just want to be
continuing to develop your own might.
You're going to at some point need to do
some sort of retake. And yeah, I think
that this is the right call. There's no
way that you're going to sit out there.
So, you run home, you develop the red
reksai, you get the Annie. This is again
one of those setup turns that we were
talking about. Now, the downside is uh
this is going to allow Colin to go from
four to six. Should go up to five from
the hold. Will be able to walk into the
Sunken Temple.
>> Yeah, might even
>> Might even draw if you decide to gank
over with the Fiora.
>> That would be nice. I think that is uh I
think that's where I'd start if I was
Colin.
Just have a visit, see what's there.
Hope I don't get rebuked. At least if I
do, I have deflect.
And uh Colin agrees with you and likes
drawing cards.
Which is again something I can really
get behind in a person in a card game.
>> Or not.
Maybe uh Colin doesn't agree with me.
Listen, I wouldn't agree with me either.
>> That's true. Uh they're thinking, you
know, it's uh
>> On time around here in top eight, you
are of course expected to play at a
reasonable pace, but there is a little
bit of extra cushion to really think
through your plays. And when it's a
single elimination at this point, and
there's a nice shiny trophy on the line.
And for both these players, a win would
be a big breakout for them. They've had
success, but they have not gone all the
way to first at this level. So, Fiora is
going to get Con over. Set Kingpin
reinforces first. That was the uh the
decision to be made first. So, I do like
that sequencing quite a bit.
Continuing to threaten to hold
Battlefields and lock things down with
Set, and then second tempo.
And he have Con a bit of card draw as we
noted the last time we saw Con on
stream. Uh Con just wants Battlefields
to draw cards. So, uh you'll see this a
lot in Con's games on Set, which makes a
ton of sense. And Sabotage is going to
get the news, what do you have?
And uh Rebuke Rebuke Flash Ferrous
Forerunner, notably a unit that cannot
be taken by Sabotage.
>> And that's also telling us exactly what
was finally found after all of those
draws by Prismasticism just trying to
find the Sticky Might to contest with
all of these large units on Con's side
of the board.
I think that this might be a pick of the
Flash knowing that there's two Rebukes.
>> That's true.
He's decided to pick that.
>> does decide the Rebuke. Okay.
>> very good against Con's deck.
>> It is very good, but having seen what we
saw in game one where that Flash was
actually used offensively, I think that
the versatility there makes an awful lot
of sense.
>> Arena Battle popped.
As Set has a little drink in the arena.
Gets himself a buff.
Makes himself a little bit bigger. Now
up to seven total. That's five plus one
for his text and plus one for the buff.
And uh still there with tanks. So,
again, very annoying trying to kick
through especially since Set's legend
ability means that Set Kingpin can be
saved at a moment's notice so long as
you want to spend that which feels like
a worthwhile trade for that and a bit of
power. Sif here though, you're going to
go ahead and reinforce makes that
Kingpin even bigger. And once again, the
Kingpin surrounding himself with a few
extra cronies.
As Colin is deciding where to put these
units, it looks like he's going to move
might to these battlefields again. Can't
really move some of them away, so might
as well reinforce them and try and make
the job even harder for Chrisman.
>> Well, and having gained the information
from Sabotage, this also lets Colin know
what kind of thresholds Prismatism is
capable of getting over minus whatever
he top decks. That's the, I think,
backbreaking part of Sabotage. Yes, you
get rid of the card, but you also know
exactly what you need to play around.
And so, I think Colin feels confident
that he can go and sit on some of these
battlefields and force Prismatism into
unfavorable trades because again,
Prismatism is going to be the one who
has to
break through this wall that Colin has
created because uh uh the point tempo
has unfortunately went in Colin's favor
once again.
>> And a very impressive that Colin's
managed to find a way despite losing the
lead early in both these games. Despite
again going first in this game as well.
Impressive to find a way back in and
then just kind of dig in. I think that's
the thing about this Set deck, it's been
impressive. Once it finds its way kind
of back to parity and with just a little
bit of a margin ahead, it just locks
down a site and then getting in is
impossible.
>> Right. And on the top we have 10 might,
on the bottom we have eight might, but
we also have three cards in Colin's hand
with three runes available. And while
three might not seem like a lot, it
turns out there's a lot of things you
can do in a set list with three runes.
Punch first is obviously a very powerful
card. Uh you could also worry about
cards like Challenge, etc. Uh instead,
Colin just decides to utilize the set
legend ability, spend a buff, and save
that Fiora.
>> All right, so Fiora going to get saved.
It does mean Kingpin is a little
vulnerable perhaps as Ferros Forerunner
joins the party at the Sunken Temple.
Unfortunately, is not conquering despite
being a mighty unit in that mech suit.
So, no card draw here for Prismate who's
kind of been a little light on resources
all game long.
More serious than I'll say actually
between our first, let's say one and a
half games we've seen so far. But, six
points to five
getting back in the lead for now, but
I don't know what to do about that top
half and I'm not sure if Prismate knows
exactly what to do either.
He's going to No, he's going to think.
Thought I saw a pass there, but
a lot to consider still.
And again, there's Lucian and Fiora
ready with the crack back.
So, a tough spot to navigate again. For
a for a deck that presents quite a lot
of might at battlefields with things
like Ferros Forerunner,
I feel like Set just has a lot more
might to go around.
>> Absolutely. Set is playing
as much raw might as what the Annie
player does, but with the arena bars
that Collin has had both games, that's
an extra essentially plus one might
every turn because you're going to turn
it sideways, activate it, stick that
extra might on the board. There is also
the issue as we've noted where when a
unit is saved by the Set legend ability,
Prismaticism is usually going down that
might due to the trade and Collin gets
to save it. So, this really does kind of
become a situation where it's attrition.
That's also probably why Collin opted
with that sabotage to get rid of the
rebuke because that's where Prismaticism
can spike back up at a key moment and
make up that gap of might lost through
the trades.
>> Interesting to think of what to do here
though knowing again that information
that you pointed out that is one of the
more powerful things that these similar
effects do give even though Sabotage
target cutaway. Knowing that the rebuke
is still there is important because I
was trying to think about the things
Collin can do to remove units that
aren't fight them which is obviously the
the primary way. And uh when you're
forcing your opponent into your
battlefield, well, that's really good
cuz you can hold up a bunch of different
pumps, like punch first. But, if you're
trying to be a bit more proactive about
it, well, challenge is really Collin's
best way to do that. And if you want to
challenge this Forerunner, let's say,
which I don't know if something he wants
to do, but something he might be
thinking about, uh you have to leave the
battlefield if you want to use uh let's
say your set Kingpin because if you
don't, you are getting rebuked.
>> Absolutely. That is a
>> no, you can't. It's an action.
>> Oh, correct. You're not starting a
showdown. So,
you can do it from one spot to another.
It's absolutely playable to
uh challenge that Forerunner from
across. I think the big concern would be
something along the lines of uh does
that open up prismaticism to then retake
with the max? And the the big thing here
is that going into this next turn cuz
Collin cannot win right now. So, going
into this next turn,
is there a situation where giving the
max into the base to allowing for more
versatility during a retake, you know,
more or less beneficial?
Uh Collin, it does seem wants to get on
the Sunken Temple, is sending in the
Lucian.
>> Four versus nine right now. But, uh plus
five would conveniently be exactly that
same number.
>> This might just be an emphasis on saying
I'm okay with potentially losing my
Lucian. You could also save it with the
set legend ability. But, in return, I
want to get rid of your red Rex because
what I'd be worried about on a retake
would be you sending in the Ferris
Forerunner somewhere,
having it die and then accelerate the
max to get even more might.
>> Yep. And again, though, something like
ride the wind, that would be a pretty
spicy way for Forerunner to trot on over
and try and see if uh
>> Well, you also know that there's the
flash in hand. So, again, we've already
seen the offensive flash play that
sabotage revealed it. And then again,
that's kind of why I thought see two
rebukes and one flash, sometimes you
just kind of want to remove your options
to your opponent, but as you had pointed
out, rebuke is also just incredibly
strong against Set. Kind of hard to go
wrong with any of those choices. Uh and
that is what happened. So, that Lucian
gets uh saved by the Set legend ability,
but does get rid of the red Rex Sai, and
I think that Colin was worried about
those accelerated Mechs.
>> Makes sense to me. So, we'll see. Does
Colin try and conquer the battlefield
and take away
Well, I guess don't take away the threat
of losing, but uh giving one point over
and just forcing him to conquer the
other battlefield is a way to try and uh
weasel out of this situation. But, like
you said, Colin got win. He can only get
to seven from this point. So, Set is
going to come back.
Sithriel all alone there
in that top out of the first mate.
Reinforcing the battlefield going to
ready the kingpin. So, we do want to
tussle with the forerunner.
>> And it's more about reducing options
here, making it a little bit harder for
Prez next turn.
>> Also, the specifically because this is
sending kingpin, this could be about the
draw as well. If you don't like your
hand and you want one more answer, going
under Sunken Temple with your mighty
unit is a way to do it. But, we have a
Rengar, a defensive Rengar. So, it's
only going to be worth three might
because it's not the attacker, so the
assault doesn't trigger. It's uh not the
Shen, if you will, but still is bonus
might and another unit on the Sunken
Temple. This is a big play.
>> And you also know that
if you commit more
if you punch first to try and win this
combat
you just don't know there's a rebuke in
hand.
>> You still know there's a rebuke in hand.
And on top of that, if somehow you do
still kill that forerunner, you're not
getting rid of the net might. So, there
still could be some sort of crack back
on the following turn. This is a rough
spot to be in. Uh these Rengars, when I
was walking the tables earlier through
the weekend, have been blowing out games
all weekend long.
>> Yeah, not that many reaction units that
are this size.
But, uh yeah, Rengar a pretty good one
here. And this is one of the innovations
that Prismat found for this Annie deck
three Renga. Cuz uh not only is it just
a pretty good unit in these domains, but
when Annie ready to ruin it, it's pretty
easy to find a way to leave open three.
And all of a sudden, two scary enough,
but three, you have to add Renga to the
mix as well as far as what you're
thinking about when you're doing
something like oh, I don't know, walking
into a battlefield with set Kingpin.
>> Yeah, if anything, plays like this are
why I'm so excited for Unleashed when
that comes out cuz there's so many units
that have Ambush that are going to be
coming in that set. I can't wait to see
additional plays like this, and we are
going to see the punch first committed.
>> It doesn't feel great, but at some point
you have to realize, well, I know they
have the Rebuking, they probably guess I
have a punch first. I'm going to make
you use it cuz at this point that's the
only way I'm getting it out of your
hand. I have to make an enticing enough
target to force this out.
>> So, the the situation that you're in now
if you're Prismatism is
am I forgetting anything? Is there any
way I'm punished by rebuking it? Is this
him just baiting it out cuz
we both know I have it, and he still
chose to play this punch first. Does he
know something I don't? Is he thinking
of something that I have forgotten? So,
this is one of those situations where
you don't just windmill slam your
rebuke. You want to think through what
the options are just to play it safe.
>> Yep. An Yielding Spirit, which is kind
of a spell that is a defensive body
spell, doesn't work in that situation
cuz it's not dealing any damage. So,
that one is Dismantle in Origins with
all the Kaisers running around, but not
so hot these days as a card you see
commonly in body list. And I believe
there's something coming in Unleashed
that might be helpful here, but
unfortunately, we're not there yet. This
is still Spirit for a draft at the end
of the original qualifier season for
this set. And what a meta game it has
been as both these players
still deep in thought, deep into this
second game here, and Prismat really
wants to take this one cuz if he
doesn't, he's out of the tournament, and
that is the one thing he's truly
searching for at this point in his Rift
Bound career is just a win.
>> And as I said before, yes, this seems
pretty straightforward, but you want to
make sure you're not forgetting
anything. There is also that flash
available.
So, this could be a situation where
instead of using the rebuke,
if you're worried about additional
attacks from the Fiora that is still in
the base,
right? Again, maybe there's a second
punch first, so you rebuke and then they
punch first and then still come in. This
I was going to say this could just be a
flash because not only does that save
your units, but it means that in the
next turn you'll get more value from the
Rengar. So, you set it up, make them
commit resources, and now it's going to
be plus five might on your turn when you
try to go for the double conquer retake.
So, I actually really like this. It's
safe and it gives prismaticism more
options.
>> It does give Kallen a draw that is that
does successfully conquer and go to
seven, but seven is not enough points to
win this game. You do need a despite
both players starting with the bonus
points thanks to the arena's greatest.
And I like this too cuz in some ways it
sidesteps the punch first, right? That
five might it's being granted by punch
first this turn. Well, that's not going
to be there next turn when you go back
in with the rest of your units.
>> And now Kallen only has three energy
left.
Has to decide where this Fiora is going
to go.
Knows that holding is essentially the
path to victory.
>> And uh firstmate Strand
over there in the uh in the top
battlefield Citria can go back
And it is uh
6 10 15. Yes, 17 might in base right
now. Uh accounting for Rengar's assault
two.
There So, you know, it does have assault
two, so that's quite a lot of offensive
power as you noted.
And uh the math I'm not looking to check
out right now, but we are going to make
it even better. Fiora is going to join
on in.
>> Well, this is an interesting puzzle for
Colin because again, it's known
information minus the top deck.
>> Yep. Colin knows there's a rebuke.
>> Knows what's on the board. The question
is, what is the top deck? How could I be
punished? How do I best position myself
to make it so that
>> So.
>> uh both are not there. Uh I like this.
Lucian is no longer stranded in the
base. Again, you know that you just have
to hold to win. This not only pushes
three might forward, but with the buff
as well is one additional. Going to go
down to two ready runes. So, those are
runes that could be used for something
like a challenge as we think about cards
prismaticism will need to play around on
his turn. Uh potentially a punch first
as well. And even if those runes are
spent as we know, there is also call to
glory that can be played by spending a
buff. So, uh two cards in the hand of
Colin and prismaticism
still has to play around quite a lot
despite the diminished resources.
>> All right. So, counting out the might
can see on the top cuz that's where
we're going to start, right? If Priz can
double conquer this turn, going to win
this game. If not,
Colin's probably going to find the hold
and find a win. So, do want to likely
break both here. I don't think you can
commit to simply going uh to the bottom
battlefield and just dealing with it. I
think you probably want to try and
conquer and score two points for the
win.
>> Well, uh Colin's at seven. So, you have
to deal with both.
>> You certainly, yes. Well, oh, that's
true. Yeah.
>> At a minimum, if you conquer one and
then just trade,
>> Yes.
>> then that is also an out, but either way
you have to deal with what's on the
battlefield for both.
>> And this is what I think uh this is what
I thought was going to happen cuz it was
five might. So, you want to bring at
least one more over. So, Ferris
forerunner going to move through and
have a feeling the Ferris forerunner may
be seen again on another battlefield.
So, that is seven points now for
Prizmat.
>> Yeah, perhaps it's a ride the wind that
could be
>> I think that's what I spotted.
>> And rebuke.
>> Well, we we I was going to say we know
about this rebuke.
>> Goodbye, say kingpin. Call to glory, my
Fiora, take my buff off my Lucian.
No, take it off my set.
>> I was I was going to say, yeah, yeah,
yeah.
He was just uh targeting the Lucian.
>> getting bigger. So, now the might is
pretty evenly distributed, but
everyone's moving on in.
Do you have enough? Those cards do not
help in giving it to Colin.
Is that enough on its own? 4 8 9 10 plus
3 13.
Five
>> Yeah, so the other card was an
accelerated Kaisa for the plus four
might, and we are going to game three.
>> Ooh. This battle of the titans, our
first game of the top eight, and it is
everything we hoped it would be.
>> An hour already. We still have one game
left to play. Two great players, but
unfortunately there can only be one left
here moving on to our top four.
And last battlefield,
uh I'm trying to remember now. I know it
draws cards on Colin's side. I know I've
seen them both, but it's been a long
day, so we'll wait until the graphic
fills in. We'll see where we will be
dueling for our final showdown between
between these two players.
It is sad to only see one of these
players for at least one more round
after this, but it has been an
incredible run for both of them. Already
locked for best ofs, now just playing
for the trophy.
>> I believe the last one was Grove for
him.
>> Yes, Grove of the God Below.
When I hold draw card, again, very on
theme.
You do love to see it. And it's Zone
Wards is the last one here.
Which one? Prismatism.
>> Uh Colin might be happy to see it. It
also explains, I think, why Prismatism
left that till the end. Uh Seed of Power
does also draw as well, but Prismatism
is typically the one that's trying to
double conquer more often. So, you lead
off with that. You want to hopefully
save the arena's greatest for when
you're going second. Unfortunately,
Prismatism dropped that first game, but
I think still wanted to run it out and
deny the Wards so that uh Colin couldn't
make use of the draw until the very end.
>> Yep, I think I like that. As uh players
are just looking through their decks,
thumbing through, doing any last-minute
changes cuz uh
>> And maybe taking a breather
>> Yeah. For one of these players, again,
untimed rounds, you do have a little bit
of breathing room and I think it is
important to take some at times like
these. TCG events are a long, they can
be stressful, and they are certainly a
slog.
If you make it to the end, you have
played a lot of Rift Bound over the
course of this weekend, and that is the
goal for every player at this point in
the tournament.
And
>> Oh, the rune has fallen. I saw a shuffle
from Collin, dropped a rune.
>> It's all right. The dexterity is still
there. Lock in, buddy.
Gotta make sure that those runes are
randomized.
Just a little chuckle on the other side.
Players uh do know each other somewhat
from uh their time in the top uh top
eights of regional qualifiers, as it
turns out. Again, we're both uh in the
top
four, if memory serves correctly, in
Vegas. Certainly, we're at least uh both
in top eight.
>> And I think as I was saying, I think
Collin is also maybe getting up to
stretch a little bit. Um might have to
run to the restroom or do some push-ups
of his own. Maybe he said, "Hey,
Prismatism just did some push-ups,
got a win.
>> That's true.
>> Maybe I'm going to step off camera for a
moment, drop and give him 20, and come
back and be the set I know I can be."
>> Exactly. I was going to say, that's the
set guy. Oh.
>> Okay.
>> And there it is. That was had to be
quick. That was probably push-ups.
>> If that was 20, that was impressive.
A big smile on Collin's face as he is
>> it was 20, and I'm told I know how to
count.
>> Yes, that is true. Uh your math has
never never failed us yet.
These two players just uh you know,
taking a breather, having a chat, bit of
a banter.
And uh shuffling up for what's going to
be our final game of this quarter this
quarterfinal match up, at least. Very
curious how the rest of our tournament
is doing, but I guess we'll find it
after this, cuz we need to lock in and
focus on the task at hand, which is
finishing the battle between two
heavyweights here,
Annie and Set. I would say, one of these
legends we expected to see in this top
eight, and one of them we certainly did
not. But it's a delight to have them
both here as decks are presented,
battlefields are revealed, and action
will begin in short order.
>> I think Callan might be the perfect
evangelist for this set list because I
have been impressed. I will be honest, I
have not really looked into building set
at all in set one or set two.
However, I like what I've seen. This
looks like it's a lot of fun. Uh the all
in three arena bar to keep things going
has been very effective. I like the
mobility of Show Stopper for sure, but
seeing some of these other plays with
First Mate has been fantastic. I uh
just did not give set the respect that
the Kingpin deserves.
>> Well, now we know.
It's always good to learn things, Tommy,
you know? Yeah. And not again, not the
set I expected to see in the Chosen
Champions though, but certainly I'd be a
convert at this point given Callan's
results.
Doesn't even have the option, by the
way. Does No Set Rollers anywhere in the
set deck, and that's the the flashy one,
we can say. Don't always need to be
flashy to get victories in Rift Bound,
as it turns out.
As players have presented their decks,
the customary fist bump is in the air,
granted, and
it is time to mulligan. Four cards
apiece, have a look and see if they're
all good. I see a single Over the Alps
Fan, at least a Four Runner.
Ooh, cards back again.
>> Yeah, I I I see a Rex Sai, and I think
the last one was a Hard Bargain.
>> Callan now looks like he's putting two
away.
Going to recycle those as as required.
Very diligent player is Callan, even
presented the two cards in the mulligan
to his master in game number one, which
I think is a
just a funny little bit and very sporty
Callan to do so.
>> When you are recycling more than one
card, you are supposed to randomize them
and offer a cut, so just following the
rules. Important to do when you're in
the top eight.
>> Very true, there are judges watching us.
Not many matches left to keep track of,
so the hoard of judging staff that has
been here making sure the event runs
smoothly all weekend long. Now all their
eyes are trained on
the four matches still in play.
And uh
>> I do believe some of them probably have
um
have maybe been, you know, said, "You
know what? You're done for the weekend.
You can be okay." I don't think there's
50 judges watching these four games.
That'd be quite funny.
>> So, a little bit interesting there. For
a moment, Prismatism was about to keep
the Forerunner and the Rex Eye. The Rex
Eye makes sense because going second,
that's going to be your turn one play,
getting rid of the fan, not necessary as
much. But, at the last moment, instead
shipped the Forerunner down and kept the
Hard Bargain.
>> Interesting.
There's the Rex Eye that you said.
Ruin's Getaway can Sitri out of the
tutor up on the other side there for
column. Not a bad one, especially if
there's a unit to follow up with.
And uh where are we going to go? Ruin's
Get Channel, card gets drawn.
Smiles are exchanged, but the
pleasantries are
not done, but uh you know,
wearing on as the series goes on here as
both
>> Just not the focus. They're locked in.
>> Yeah.
Well, Prismatism, I feel like he's
always locked in.
Permanently locked in. That's why he
makes so many top eights, don't you
know?
>> Yeah. Well, he's uh essentially achieved
flow state by adding the extra ism.
That's why it's Prismatism Prismatismism
with
>> I see.
>> the name.
>> All right. Well, off to the grove we go.
Sitri out.
Rumbling on over it and uh it's going to
say, "Okay, you can have the first
point. You are uh the player going
first."
So, usually that's the that's the case
that that player will take that first
point. I do like that Colly always takes
the point. As we talked about how some
players have been holding back and I
think that is correct in some
situations, but this deck really does
kind of get points in increments. Mhm.
So, uh given that you're holding it,
often I feel like when you're holding
you only hold for a single point. I do
like that Colly just tries to take the
points as they come. As a hidden card
goes under that battlefield, and if I
recall correctly, at least from what I
know of the main deck, that could only
be one of two things. That could be
Hidden Blade or a Face Breaker.
>> Uh yes, unless something came in from
the sideboard,
>> we don't know.
>> uh are the options, but uh this is why
that first point was taken because we
see
>> Oh,
Rengar is so bad.
>> a huge set Kingpin go down and Colin
recycled down to two runes to make this
happen, but Rengar on the attack.
>> Bargain? The Hot Bargain that was kept
is going to be so good here. Hot Bargain
and the hidden blade.
And that is a complete blowout on this
battlefield. It is four for the Reksai,
five for the Rengar, nine might total
crashing into five, six, seven, eight.
>> Absolute beautiful play from
Prismaticism. That gut check to say I
don't need the Forerunner, I just need
the aggression and protection is paying
off. Love to see this Rengar on offense.
Obviously helped Prismaticism win the
previous game by forcing resources out
of Colin's hand and then being the extra
might for the retake. Now shining here
in early game three.
>> Oh.
>> And this is a big blowout because the
Kingpin did not have a buff on it. Only
the Cithria did, so he cannot be saved
with the set legend. Now considering do
you want to recycle another unit? I was
just about to say if you want to keep
even just the Cithria, you have to go
down another rune and this is a big
setback.
>> The one might unit. Granted when you
play any other unit it goes to two, it
gets a buff, but that is so little might
for such a high cost.
>> And if you're Prismaticism, that might
signal a bit about what's in Colin's
hand because if you want to save even
this one might unit, that means you
might be light on units you can play
anytime soon. Maybe it's a bit top heavy
or it's just all of the reactive options
in Colin's hand.
>> So happy to take the draw here off his
own warrants.
Oh.
Forgot his trigger.
Interesting.
>> Yeah, just straight up forgot.
Cuz Kingpin's in there. There would be
another unit. Uh, another card that's
got it, disease so went to the warrants
and just forgot.
Cithria does get her buff back, thinks
Lucian going the game.
>> Sometimes
sometimes after you get Rengar, you
forget your triggers. It happens to even
the best players in the world.
>> Rengar is quite the jump scare as far as
units go both in the rift and in League
of Legends. So, we'll continue on as
Kaisa going to be reinforcing here
alongside Traveling Merchant ready to
runes and I'm in the pattern continues
here. If you're wondering, you know, a
little heuristic on how to play this any
deck, well, look at your hand and uh
look at if you have a unit on the
battlefield, consider reinforcing, spend
all of your runes on units, and then
awaken two and hold up something fun.
>> Yeah, I mean, that is a a great
beginner's take.
>> Yes, but also, let's just say this is
understanding the game state because you
just saw Collin go way down on
resources. You also should have the
point tempo. I know it says three over
there on Collin's side, but
you're still going to be able to catch
up. You also have this Grove of the
God-Willow locked off, so you're going
to continue to draw cards to continue to
extend that resource advantage.
>> Arena bar.
>> There's the arena bar.
>> Pretty key card here in this set deck.
Lucian going to join Sithria perhaps?
>> Yeah.
>> awkward cuz you you actually can't
easily exhaust this unit to buff it.
>> Right, you kind of have to move it there
to be able to buff it and then you can
move the Sithria back if you want to
save her and then if Prismaticism does
come in to deal with the Lucian, worst
case scenario, you can use your set
legend to still save it. So, it's not as
risky as it seems, but it is the only
way to get that buff on the Lucian.
>> conquering this case cuz of course it
was already held for a point. So, with
Sithria already occupying it, no need
for a Lucian to take anything. There's
nothing really to take. Uh the work has
already been done. So, Lucian can be
exhausted, which is a very funny thing
for Lucian. Usually doesn't stay uh
sideways for very long, but set deck and
flash in the hand and options being
considered now for Prisma.
>> I was just about to say this is kind of
a scary position if you're Collin
because you have Prismaticism with
uh a lot of runes, uh an abnormally
large number of runes, one might say,
because typically there's a lot of
recycling going on in these games, as
well as a lot of cards in hand thanks to
that Grove of the Godwillow.
What does prismaticism have up their
sleeves? And it turns out it's a mech.
>> Always has been. It's always Paris
Forerunner reinforcing that Grove of the
Godwillow, which as I believe you
mentioned is also drawing prismatism
cards. Not the plan Colon had when this
battlefield was put in the in the
lineup.
But uh certainly prismat will take it.
Going to retreat Rexai now.
Leave the Forerunner there. Maybe even
retreat the Kaisa as well.
Already some runes and it's just Kaisa
that's going back. So quite a bit of
might held on this battlefield. 12 total
now on the Grove.
>> I like this play. You do want to save a
lot of might on Grove to make it
difficult to overtake. You want to be
able to draw the cards. But if something
goes wrong, you want Rexai to be around
to potentially accelerate mech tokens or
to give you a little bit of umph on a
retake. Also, because you're sitting on
Grove and the Zone War dance has just
been held every time. Every time it's
held, you do not get the trigger. It's
only on conquer, and that first one was
missed by Colon. So again, you're just
trying to control the flow of the card
draw in this matchup. And Colon, I think
is just going to play this Fade Dragon
and look for as much additional might on
the board. Not a ton of value because
the other two units already had buffs,
but it is still eight on its own.
>> Yeah, just playing for the stats and I
mean body's got big bodies. It's one of
the
one of the draws to the domain. So it
makes a ton of sense. There is a
prismat going to awaken and get a point
now. Four a piece in this final game in
this quarterfinal matchup between two
incredibly good players, but prismatism
is going to go back ahead on points.
Take the War dance that he brought to
this final game. Get point number five
and discard and draw.
Kaisa.
>> Going to discard Kaisa. That is
something that I think I'm a fan of.
Just kind of looking probably for more
reactive tools.
We're also going to use the stack deck
to see if there's any more sauce that
can be found. But given that you have a
healthy number of units, you've now just
established the official point lead. We
kind of knew at some point Collin was
going to need to leave the zone warrens
open.
You just have to put yourself in a
position to be the person who scores
last. If you're Annie, you have to
assume that flash is on the table. So
Rexai isn't exactly in danger over
there.
There's also I believe a fan in his hand
which could be reinforced over there.
Actually it's going to go to the grove.
So again just all in on this grove
saying I am going to take away your best
tool to win this game.
>> It is hard to say no to a battlefield
that draws you a card every time you
hold it.
And it does feel like again both these
decks kind of just
whether by match up or by design just
saying you know what
really stacking a ton of minor one
battlefield is kind of the plan. And it
does make sense. Again we've seen the
the tank set kingpin from the chosen
champion doing. We've seen first
forerunner from Prisma. It does feel
like that is one of the primary ways
these decks do drive the game forward.
Oh takes back the fan.
Little rewind there. A little smoke from
both players but everything above board.
Did catch that in time. Stack deck first
get the information. Good see good
>> Oh okay.
A lot of good choices. This is not going
to be an easy choice on the stack deck.
Yeah he goes with the tank.
>> Ooh quicker than we might have expected.
>> Well so
you know looking at choices I saw a
flash. I saw a forerunner. I think the
forerunner is ultimately the choice and
it makes sense. That's a lot of again
sticky might but
I was not sure that was going to be an
easy decision. Does play the forerunner
to the other side. When the turn is
passed will ready those runes. But again
gaining the information important right?
Because Uh, had the other play stuck
there would not be enough energy left
over to have deployed that Forerunner.
>> So, what's better than one Forerunner on
a battlefield? Two. One each, I guess.
One on each battlefield. Feels pretty
good there. So, even again, if Collin
can trade some might in,
going to be some might out on the other
side there for Prismat as the baby
Mecklings do come pouring out of the
suits. And this is kind of Set's game
plan as challenge going to be issued
there to the Forerunner. Eight plays six
as far as the fight goes and that's an
easy one for Fay Dragon to win.
But,
>> we see a long
sword come down from the side of
Prismatism.
Again, a card that has performed well
for Prismatism. So well, in fact, that
the one Mind Splitter he was running in
Leo came out for an additional copy.
>> Certainly did. And that's going to be a
trade, I believe. Yep, does trade away
the dragon. Buff is available is going
to be used. Recycling a rune there to
save the Fay Dragon.
Yes, can get it back thanks to the Arena
Barber. Set Legend is now exhausted.
>> So, this is interesting just because
both players really kept most of the
overall might the same on the board. The
Fay Dragon just loses the buff, but that
can be added back by the Arena Barber.
On the other side, the long sword sticks
around and the Forerunner just becomes
two Mechs.
It does open the window for a conquer on
the Zong Warren's for Collin, though.
>> We'll see if Collin wants to take that
opportunity. Contend with the Rex side,
which again, on defense is only three
might.
So, not all that good
as far as the defensive side is
concerned. Another Forerunner
actually losing another fight to
the dragon, I believe. The second
challenge is issued.
One out and Mechs explode into the back
line. Lucian goes in, conquers the
Warrens.
Collin gets a point. Lucian's going to
ready. And should be a discard and draw
as well.
Does indeed discard an arena by that one
doesn't feel very good to use right now.
So it makes sense to put that one away.
Kind of only need one in a lot of cases.
>> And I was just saying I know that says
plus six but I'm pretty sure that's
supposed to represent six damage from
the challenge.
>> So what's next here? Five a piece as far
as points go.
First minute I can see in the hand
there.
And the forerunner has gone to much
easier to contend with the bottom
battlefield as well. Fair dragon getting
ready it's only six might fair dragons
are seven that's more than enough and
Colin's getting ever closer to closing
out this match.
>> Yeah, Colin did find a way to break the
stalemate back in his favor. Again was
behind on the point tempo. Prismatism
had a lot of might present. Colin found
a way to deal with multiple
Ferris forerunners which of course is
something you have to be prepared for.
It was the second most played card in
the room all weekend long.
Prismatism
unfortunately only at five points. This
is why we talk about those even points
being so important. If it was six there
might be a path where even with all of
this going in Colin's favor you could
retake because of the mech tokens
because of the longsword providing some
additional might left over. However,
Prismatism is only at five.
Will likely have to do something because
Colin is at six and that means Colin is
within striking distance of securing
this match.
>> love this threatening the hold and then
the conquer on the other side to
potentially win it from six to eight and
fair dragon just says I'm eight might
come and trade with me cuz I am just
going to get saved by my set once again
as the arena by rebuffs. So this is this
is the big round that set put you in a
rebuke. It has to be and yes it was.
He's going to try and fix the problem
but Prismatism still a critical point
behind from being able to win this turn.
>> Yeah, I was just about to say it's got
to be something like a rebuke here
simply because going into combat against
that Fay Dragon just results in a buff
going away and the set legend
activating. Prismatism has to do
something that pulls the might off a bit
more permanently. Obviously, could be
replayed by Colin, but that would eat up
his entire next turn because it would
be all of the seven energy. So, as far
as this game is concerned, that could
have just been as good as permanent
removal.
>> Yep, and that is nine might that Colin
is
here to play with as he does awaken. So,
again, Colin also threatening to win by
double conquering next turn if he can
find enough might enough units to get in
there. With the Fay Dragon being moved
back to hand, that is a big threat
removed. It is not able to be used in
combat you have to think cuz that's the
only thing Colin could replay. So, even
with something like a First Mate, Colin
played on top of it because it's already
the Fay Dragon cuz you just don't have
enough energy. That is the thing about
these decks, Set loves to recycle runes
to use all his very powerful cards, his
powerful legend ability. So, it's nine
might of worth of max to the Grove of
the God Willow Prismatism saying,
"I'm going to try and put myself in the
position to win and hope I can hold on."
>> And I would expect an additional unit to
be played. Here's the Annie, so you can
go back and get the rebuke that you just
played. And there's also likely going to
be an equip of the longsword for the
additional might. And actually, that's
very very sly of Prismatism. Instead of
going all in on the Grove, making the
uh mech on the other side a little bit
harder to go over the top of because
when you're looking at the units that
are on the side of Colin here, you have
the Sithri but that's only two might.
You have the First Mate, that's only
three might. So, neither can do it
alone. In fact, they can't even do it
together. So, it's
on board if you're just looking at that
information, uh got to be Elusian plus
another unit or force resources out of
Colin's hands. And if you overcommit,
Colin is also knowingly playing around
the rebuke that was just returned to the
hand of prism
by that Annie legend and it was a rebuke
so powerful that it sent pastry to the
shadow realm and I'm now joined on the
broadcast by Miss Chim Chim.
>> Yes, hello. Thank you for welcoming in.
I I've been watching from the sidelines
here. It feels like we're we're stacking
these big mighty boys all on these
battlefields here and seeing who can
hold the longest.
>> Yeah, this is really coming to a head.
We are in game three of our first set of
the top eight. Both of these players are
within striking distance. Colin has six
points could win with a double conquer.
And we are of course looking at prism
trying to hold just one of these
locations.
The game essentially comes down to this.
There is a weird scenario where Colin
could
just remove the units from both
battlefields and prevent the hold win,
but the rebuke is going to be enough to
push Colin off and that is a victory
going to the side of prism.
>> Wow, what a game. And you know,
honestly, I I I didn't know that it was
going to it was going to turn out this
way, but he was able to get that mech
just to be so big to make sure he could
hold for both battlefields here.
Amazing. And that's going to
What is What does that make him? He's
he's second right now, yeah?
>> He was the second seed in the top eight.
And so with this victory he's going to
advance to the top four
of the tournament.
>> Oh my gosh, we're going to see him in
freaking semi-finals.
>> We are and that is the hump that he
needs to get over because that is where
he finished in Leo, but still has to
feel good about getting that victory
over the set and representing the
Annie's throughout the event because set
was undefeated against Annie as a whole
up until the moment it mattered most.
Prismaticism sticking it in for the win
at the very end. And I want to highlight
the fact that we had
the text that Prismaticism has really
brought to the Annie list, showing how
powerful they are there. Rengar and
Longsword both showing exactly why
Prismaticism has included three copies
of Rengar and upped
the copies of Longsword after Leal
did beautiful work.
>> Makes a lot of sense, and if you little
switcheroo got custom to broadcast.
That's Prismaticism and all these
tricksy tricks, but Annie prevailing
with like honestly a very tough match up
there by the end. Colin navigating
expertly on set all weekend long, but
kind of the favorite still in that
position after that.
>> Yeah. You know, I'm very impressed by
your Miss Chim Chim vocal impersonation.
I swear you sounded just like her for a
moment.
>> Yeah, you know, I've been working on it.
You know, weekend had a little bit of
downtime every now and then to kind of
get it done, but like I said, Annie
still looking good. Both these players
locking in their best ofs, but
Prismaticism has to feel like the player
to beat, especially if he can navigate
the quote unquote weird match ups,
right? Set not a normal match up you
really do a lot of testing against you
have to think. So, if it is just going
to be the expected decks kind of going
through the top four, top two of this
tournament, well, Pris has a lot of
practice against those.
>> Yeah, I know that we keep joking about
the stat that we saw, right? That Set
was 100% against Annies. But, having
watched that particular match, I can
kind of see why. It's a lot of might and
the units stick around. It's just enough
to be a thorn in the Annie player's
side, and I can understand why the field
struggled, but it also highlights
exactly how player skill can overcome
adversity because again, Prismaticism
lost the first game when he was going
first, and that's his traditionally one
of the ones that you want to take early.
Still managed to run it back, won games
two and game three off of just very
tight pristine play.
>> And that's the that's the interesting
thing about this deck cuz you do have to
play very tight. The margins are really
thin if you're going to win, especially
high-level games at Riftbound, but it is
uh nice to see even early on in this
game's life cycle that skilled play is
rewarded. There is a reason players and
names we keep talking talking about over
and over again, no matter the
tournament, no matter the country the
tournament happens to be hosted in. Cuz
at the end of the day, Riftbound is
proving itself to be a very skillful
game indeed.
>> And speaking of skillful players, I do
want to take a moment to give the
flowers to Collin. Still locked in the
best-of set, showed that this is a
legend that can perform even against the
meta decks, and was really just moments
away from also moving on to the top
four. Again, that was an incredibly
close series. So, Collin, you can
certainly hang your head high.
>> Yeah, back-to-back uh regional qualified
top eights in North America. Uh I don't
believe traveled all the way to Europe
to try and compete, although I think he
would have done relatively well given
the skill we've seen on display, but
certainly uh home in the USA is looking
very good. And uh I'm so curious to see
what I mean, just in general, what
everyone picks up for Unleashed. But now
that we're getting towards the end,
we're still forward. Awesome to see a
kind of an old set main in Riftbound go
back to set for one final event and have
one last hurrah, but it is the players
we talk about seemingly every event
moving on for now, and I am so so
curious
who else is left cuz I have to suspect,
even though Azwel and Allan is in the
top eight, I'm think that was our last
quarterfinal.
That's my guess.
But I don't know.
>> Yeah, I don't know neither, but what I
do know is, you know, you talk about
looking forward to Unleashed,
the Rengar there looked outstanding.
>> Oh, yeah. That card is sick.
>> And Ambush is going to be one of the key
things that's coming in Unleashed. I
think if I'm a deck builder that wants
to competitively compete in Hartford, in
Vancouver, I would start looking at
lists that can mimic that play pattern.
Granted, Andy is going to allow you to
uh exploit that because you're always
going to have those runes ready because
of her legend ability, but even still,
those plays are incredibly powerful
where you are playing essentially a
combat buff, but it can stick around as
additional might for you to use for
retakes or additional holds. It was so
impactful even just to see that
defensive Rengar that forced the punch
first from Collin's hand and that
allowed him to not have it on defense
when Prismatism had to come back the
following turn.
>> Yeah, I think it's funny we've talked a
lot about Chaos at least off camera this
weekend and one of the things that
that's obvious is Chaos clearly is very
versatile, quite powerful, but a lot of
things Chaos does is temporary, which
means when you create windows of
opportunity for yourself, you must use
them very well. Like, if you're using a
flash to move some units, whether you're
doing it offensively or defensively, you
best believe you have to move the units
back to the right spot cuz if you don't
use the resources given to you, well,
you're going to run out of them pretty
quickly cuz it isn't a deck that can
grind forever and ever and ever.
>> Yeah, it's definitely not Set.
>> No, it is not Set. That's what we saw.
It can grind forever.
>> It really did feel like as the game went
on, there was just more and more units
in Collin's base or on the battlefield
because not only are they big, but
again, you can save them with the Set
legend ability.
>> to like 15 points, I think Set would be
a very, very good deck. Just chilling
out, make getting bigger and bigger.
>> Or maybe if you're playing to 11 cuz
you're playing 2v2.
>> All right, with that, we are going to go
to an interview. Down to the desk.
>> Thanks so much for that incredible cast
for that incredible marathon of a match
that you had. I mean, Prismatism, I've
got to say, you've now unlocked yourself
into another top four with Annie
back-to-back weekends. I mean,
I've just got to say it here, man. You
are really solidifying yourself as one
of these first
professional Riftbound players and you
were doing such incredible job and you
have since all of these. And I'm going
to bring it up.
Now you have to go against one of your
friends who I would also say is a very
professional Riftbound player. So,
already in the mindset, what do you
think of having to go against Alan's EQ
on the other side?
>> Well, he's my main testing partner.
We're both familiar with the match-up.
He's actually a bit scared going into
it. He thinks that I'm favored in it,
which
I'm not sure how true that is. I
maybe a little bit, a little bit
favored, but I I do have the die roll
advantage from seating. So, that that's
nice. I Colin put up a a huge fight.
That definitely took a lot to win that.
Every single game was down to the wire.
It was It was really cool.
And I mean now I'm warmed up.
Hopefully I can go get past top four.
>> Literally warmed up. For everyone that
wasn't aware, I'm going to I'm going to
put you on blast for a little bit, in a
good way.
You lost game one and you were like,
"Whoa, I went first."
He broke serve on you. You got up and
did push-ups to wake yourself up. Which
this is not the first time that you've
done this, as I've as I've been told.
You then win game two.
I've been told that Colin thought you
were taunting him because, you know, Set
is, you know, he's a big workout guy.
Um
so you win game two.
Colin goes and does push-ups.
>> Oh, I didn't even notice, actually.
>> Yes, he did.
>> I was just like thinking about the game.
He actually went and did them. I'm not
sure if he
>> He walked He walked off camera and I go,
"Where did he go?" And I go, "Oh, he
maybe went to the restroom or
something." No, he was doing push-ups
cuz you did them. For you both to lock
in for game three. So, I I just kind of
want to say, you know, how important is
that kind of thing? I Every time I talk
to you, your mindset, your your
professionalism in addressing this of
Riftbound, you you really are an icon of
the game and just
showing how much
not just talent, but discipline it takes
to do and play this game at such a high
level. So much so that sometimes you got
to wake yourself up.
>> Yeah, no, yeah. And it's a it's a tight
balance between the nerves, limiting
them, but also you need a little bit of
nerves. You need that energy. Cuz if you
get too relaxed, too calm, and like
you're falling asleep, you're not you're
not focused. And then so the push-ups
help with that. They also help with the
the tilt, just like getting the emotions
out, channeling that energy a bit, so
then get back at down to a good
baseline. And I got it from SCG Con
Vegas where in round five, if I can tell
the story.
>> Oh, yeah.
>> Yeah, in in round five, I was undefeated
going up to that point. I was playing
against the Kaiju. It was game three,
and I was ahead. I had a Mondo in my
hand that I was about to play as my next
turn. And then I accidentally drew an
extra card. And then I had the habit
shuffling my cards as soon as I draw
them. So then judge opponent judge calls
a judge correctly. Judge comes over,
says my opponent gets to see my hand and
take a card from it. He takes the Mondo,
and then I barely lose that game. And
that was like I was running so well in
that tournament. I still made top eight
actually, which was really cool cuz that
was my first first real
>> in paper
>> Yeah, in paper event. I played online a
lot before then, but took a lot of
getting used to in in paper. And then um
someone that I met the day before saw
what happened, came over to me, helped
helped calm me down a bit cuz I was very
angry afterwards at myself. And then uh
we went outside and he told me I should
do some push-ups. And then ever since
that's been my go-to whenever I have a a
really bad loss, something something
that really riles me up, I do the
push-ups, calm down a bit.
>> Well,
and you took that to heart for game one,
but you didn't lose the match. We have
our one of our top four finalists here
still on the Annie Prismatism. I mean,
there's really not much else I have to
ask about it. They're going to break
down a little bit of that game once we
walk away, but you play so you play so
well and with finesse that, you know,
I'm so excited to see this match up
between you and Alan ZQ because you both
play that way. And it's literally the
clash of the titans I think coming in
here. So, I know you've got a rough
match to pet uh to prepare for, and I
know you're really looking for that
crown. So,
>> Yeah.
>> I wish you luck, man. I do not wish to
be in your shoes, but I'm going to love
being a spectator. I wish you luck.
Fantastic match in top four, but we got
more action to cover.
>> Thank you.
>> We certainly do. That is just one of the
many matches on the docket for the rest
of the day. We again we made all the way
to the top eight. We threw most of the
quarter finals. I again very curious to
see the bracket cuz a little bit of a
spoiler Alan did also win his quarter
final match up which means he will be
playing teammate and testing partner
partner Prismalism in a semi-final that
I sure hope we're going to keep on
watching.
>> I learned two things from that
interview. First, we were correct in our
assumption Colin did go also do
push-ups. Happy to see it. But the
second thing is Prismalism said that
Alan said he thought he was favored. I
don't think I've ever heard Alan say
anyone else was favored in anything. So,
uh apparently you can strike fear into
the heart of Alan with enough practice.
>> Doesn't look like it with how stoic he
is at the table, but I guess it is
possible if you beat him enough times
with any in your testing games cuz I
can't imagine how many times they have
played that match up they're going to.
And it's fun it's funny that they're
going to play, you know, probably three
games of it in the semi-final cuz
they've maybe played hundreds if not
thousands of that match up alone at this
point.
>> Yeah. They're going to play it at least
one more time.
>> They are going to play it at least
>> And I'm really looking forward to it.
I'm also looking forward to seeing what
happened on that top end of the bracket.
We know two Dravens were playing against
each other.
>> Mhm.
>> So, one of them is moving on, but that
other match up was uh I believe Frosty
uh on the Kai'Sa versus Aurelia.
>> Oh, yes. It was Kai'Sa Aurelia.
>> And that one's very interesting because
Frosty has been playing uh outstanding
all day long, but Aurelia is usually a
match up that the Kai'Sa players are not
happy to see. And so, uh I'm excited to
see how that works.
>> played Alan.
>> So, Frosty lost to Alan. Let's have a
look at the bracket.
>> Yeah, actually you know what? Let's have
a look at the bracket. Let's just have a
look at it ourselves. Let the
professionals handle it and let the
graphic fly on over cuz we clearly can't
remember what happened 90 minutes ago.
So Alanzq is through, Prismatism is
through. They're going to be playing
each other in the semi-final. Harikaze
did beat Boulevard. Unfortunately, our
our hero, friend of the show Boulevard,
does perish on Draven. So there will
only be one other Draven in top four.
Who is of course there has to be.
They're playing a mirror. And by the
looks of things based on this bracket,
they're still playing.
>> Yeah, but the really cool thing is
four unique legends in the top four.
So no matter what, all of the best ofs
will be decided. These players are only
from here on out playing to win the
event for all of the glory to be the
regional qualifier champion here in
Atlanta.
>> I just want to point out um
what the meta they'll have in common.
Hey, you know what? Don't worry about
it. As we come back here, uh there's a
lot of exciting riff found to watch as
uh the Dravens will mostly be filled. I
did say uh before to be honest I thought
they would eat each other and there
would only be a couple that made it in.
Clearly a few made it in, but the
prediction did still stand
as Dravens did move on in. As we are
going to chat more about the upcoming
semi-final, Alan versus Prism. I think
just at a high level, Annie versus
Ezreal. I'm surprised that Alan thinks
he isn't favored cuz okay, I guess my
read with Ezreal is that Ezreal is the
kind of deck that feels like 45% against
the entire field. And Alan's skill is
just so high that he manages to wiggle
enough percent over that line to get it
done. But I guess cuz Annie is so good
at establishing early that Ezreal can
maybe just fall a little bit too far
behind despite having answers to just
about anything.
>> I think that the real difference maker
is the legend tax of Annie herself. I
think the reason that
he's able to kind of skill the rest of
the field is Alan knows how to punish
the opponent when they either take a
turn to develop or they take a turn to
push. And so having those answers,
right, with your Ezreal list because we
know that his list has a lot of answers.
He's just very good at playing the right
ones at the right time is a whole lot
easier when your opponent has to make
those sacrifices cuz they're only going
to have so much energy available.
Prismaticism and this Annie list because
you get to ready those two runes are
essentially always plus two runes net
across every turn. That makes the math
harder for Alan to make up that gap in
the place.
>> We've talked about fun stats, so here's
another fun one for you. Annie has a 60%
win rate here in Atlanta and Lulu is
100% What is happening with Annie's
stats?
>> Yeah.
Apparently Annie is all or nothing
usually across the field in at least one
match up, but yeah, 60% against Ezreal
and again that's across the field.
These are two great players. The skill
can absolutely make the difference. I
think this is probably as close to a
coin flip as we could get if
Prismaticism and Alan say that
Prismaticism is favored, I believe them,
but I'm going to say it's 52-48.
>> Yeah, I mean these are two incredibly
skilled players. Going to be such a fun
match of Rift Battle. Just trying to
think a little bit more about the match
up specifics. I do definitely get I did
definitely get the idea of like Annie's
just so good cuz she can present both
sides at the same time, right? I can
present pressure and leave up
interaction. Ezreal is basically all
about leaving up the interaction and
pretty much until you're forced to do
otherwise. Not really a lot of threats
in the deck so much. I mean Ravenbloom
Students pretty good, but Alan's not
like playing a two-drop and getting on
about it for that I think that man
probably scores points in the first four
turns of the game just in general with
how his Ezreal list works out. So
>> Yeah, he is capable of coming hot out of
the gate with the Ravenbloom Students,
but he is also looking for those late
game retakes with Watcher and some of
those other effects.
>> Yeah, Ballistic Breath, Endless
Smokescreens, all that kind of stuff,
but you know what? That match up's
coming up. Let's take a little bit of a
deeper look now at the gas game. We just
watched with Prismaticism and Colonn.
Thank you very much, Peace Treat. We're
here to break down one of those games
that got Reagan to help me out. And did
you get taller since the last time I saw
you?
>> I've always been 6'3".
>> Always been 6'3". All right. Well, that
confirms I'm also 6'3" then. I'll take
that. We're going to take a look at the
end of game number two between
Prismatism and Collin. Collin's up 1-0
at this point. Prismatism needs to win
two in order to take this, and the
game's looking pretty tough. Reagan, I
want you to count for me. How many units
are on the board right now? Because this
is something I've noticed this week, and
especially as we get to the higher
tables, we get to high unit counts on
the field. Yeah, let's count this up. 1
2 3 4 5 6 7
8 and 9 with a synth riff right there.
>> Oh, yeah.
Yeah.
>> That's a lot of units, and this isn't
even the gunkiest the board's got. And I
keep saying this term, "gunky boards,"
because the top players, they like to
play wide. They just establish these big
fields, and they play with the resources
as opposed to going for early trades and
trading one-for-ones often. I want to
now look at what happens here. Cuz with
set, this makes a lot of sense. You want
a lot of units buffed with the set
coming in. But right now, Collin decides
to go in as one unit to try and clear.
And we saw that Prismatism had two runes
up and decides to flashback. So, the
flash actually saves two units. What we
don't know is what that last card in
hand is, but we're going to find out
because there was a decision that
Prismatism could have done differently
there as opposed to the flash. But the
flash ends up actually saving him. He
had the correct order. Now, let's skip
ahead to the next point because
basically what happens in the interim is
that Collin just sends everything in,
and we reinforce this point. And now
Prismatism has to deal with like look at
this might. That's what?
>> Uh
>> three uh from the other units and the
buffs. So, this guy's like nine, five,
plus the shields of six, and then four.
Really hard to punch through all of that
when you also have to deal with the five
might defending up there. But the key
is, Reagan, what did he have in his
hand?
>> I think he's going to have a rebuke.
>> Rebuke. Let's play ahead because that's
the next card that comes down for
Prismatacism. That was what was saved in
hand. You had the choice as
Prismatacism. Do I either use the flash
to save two units or the rebuke on the
set to then hold that point, but that
gives more information to Callan.
Because Prismatacism did it this way
instead, went down this line, it allowed
Callan to say, "Okay, I'm going to try
and reinforce the set." Which
Prismatacism knows is the game plan for
the set. Send the forerunner in six on
five easy take there. And then the next
card we're going to play is doing the
math. going to rebuke away the set. Huge
swing right there. And the most
important part is top decking because
this alone I still don't believe is
enough. It's two plus the five plus the
three, that's 10. And that is 11 you're
tagging into, but we got the Kaia so we
can accelerate her. Prismatacism gets
the right top deck and pushes in. It
required a really strict use of those
spells and also getting a really good
top deck, but it gets the game two win.
And then that allowed the time to
actually get that game three win. So I
actually felt like game three it was a
little more standard, but game two had
these really exciting ends to the game
where it felt lost for Prismatacism.
Fights back, stays in the tournament, go
into top four. Reagan, do you think that
Prismatacism has what it takes? Can Andy
go to finals?
>> I think he can if he keeps doing those
push-ups.
>> True. He was doing push-ups between the
rounds. That was awesome. That's all
that we had over here. Back to the
casties.
>> Thank you so What is happening to my
character?
>> I was trying to
I was trying to get my mental right. I
learned a thing or two
>> You're welcome back in.
>> That's true. That was good advice.
>> It's great advice.
>> Keep your physical well being in balance
with your mental well being. Well, the
quarterfinals are almost done. Is our
last match done? Does someone know? Are
the Drevens still playing? Are they
Somebody knows. Are they spinning axes?
>> They just
>> that would make sense because we did see
one of those players win the series
based on a game one kind of axe juggling
and then a game three axe juggling. So
perhaps that's what's happening and that
takes a
>> something? A lot of practice.
>> I don't know if they know this yet, but
because the other Draven lost
Boulevard, our good friend, did perish
unfortunately in top eight.
This Draven match is not only who gets
to go to top four and who potentially
gets to go to finals. It's actually for
the best of Draven.
>> Yeah.
>> Can you imagine if that got dropped on
you in the middle of your very intense
quarterfinal match? He was like, "By the
way, the other Draven's out." I mean
you're looking around the room, they're
probably playing somewhat near you.
Like, you know, there's only so many
people left in the venue at this point.
Outside of answer winding down slash
done. People are mostly just watching.
It's only again, there's only four match
to keep track of and they're both both
basically in the same area. So you look
over, you know there's a Draven player,
you just see them losing.
It's a lot of pressure. It puts a bit of
extra pressure on you. You know what
they should do?
Couple push-ups.
>> They should do some push-ups. That's
right. The thing about the push-ups is
it makes you strong enough to hold those
axes for the juggling.
>> Makes them feel good. Ooh, I have some
fun ideas. So do you like the best of
stuff here at the regional qualifier? I
love the best of stuff.
>> Yes, I adore it.
>> Well, we've talked about best of winners
already cuz you know there's a few.
Let's have a look at some others that
have won. Rian, as we know, did win Jinx
Loose Cannon
almost. That's what I'm trying to say.
Almost made top eight. Mom Sky, very
funny name. Yasuo Unforgiven at nine and
four, not too shabby of a record making
day two and battling it out to get on
top there. Snowfalls, Alune, winner five
two and one, barely missing day two. A
draw at the end. A dagger in the heart
of Alune players everywhere who's never
made day two in North America, Monka.
And Riftbound Plus, the winner of the
Victor Harold of the Arcane best of one
that is a surprisingly popular. Either
the deck is popular or people really
want to win the best of. I guess Arcane
did a number on people and what best of
and what legends they want to play cuz
there was always Victor player Victor
players running around, even though none
in this
>> Not everybody is a Victor hater like we
are. There are a lot of people who go to
the church of glorious evolution, and
they believe in a machine-oriented
future. And rightfully so, because 10
and 3 is a heck of a record at the end
of the day.
>> Well, you know what? I do like talking
about the best of winners, but I'd
actually like to hear from them
themselves. We're going to throw over to
some interviews we've done with these
best of champions.
>> I'm joined here with the best of Jinx
player, and it's so exciting to have you
here, Rian, because we got to see you on
stream. And you Yes, of course, the
result was not in your favor, but Alan's
EQ is one of the best players so far in
Riftbound, but you're taking home the
best of Jinx, and how does that feel?
>> It feels amazing. I'm really happy. This
took a lot of preparation. I was back
and forth iterating on this constantly
for a while now, and so, you know,
getting to prove myself and getting to
prove my specific deck list really meant
a lot to me. Yeah.
>> That That's such a big message, too,
because I think there's a ton of people
out there that really enjoy a legend
like link like Jinx. She even has like a
champion deck that you can get started
on in the game with, and you showed up,
and not only did you show up, but you
showed up basically going almost
undefeated on her, obviously losing out
towards the end there, but we got to put
you on stream. We got to see you play
out of your mind. And so, my question
is, are you going to stick with Jinx in
the future? Now that people see you
playing it, you're going to inspire some
others. Or, are you maybe going to try
out something new in Unleashed?
>> I'm absolutely a brewer at heart. So, I
really I feel like I've done a lot of
work with Jinx. I'm really looking
forward to getting to do something new.
Uh I have a friend who really loves
playing League of Legends. He keeps me
in the game, and he is a one-trick
Lillia. So, I might just be playing
Lillia in the future.
>> I mean, it'd be really cool if you took
home a best of Lillia to share also with
your best friend. That's such an amazing
idea. I'm so happy for you. Great job,
once again, and I hope to see you at a
later regional.
I'm joined here with the best of Yasuo
winner, Mom Sky. He's got it right here
in his pocket. First of all, I think a
lot of people were excited to see Yasuo
in this tournament thinking he was going
to be the Irelia killer, but you're the
one taking home that prize for Yasuo.
How does it feel?
>> Oh, it's pretty good. Uh my last round I
had to knock someone out for their best
of chance. Uh it's it's weird cuz like
it's really nice for me, but you have to
be like
got to be chill, yeah, give them a fist
bump, so.
>> Hey, but you're going to take home that
incredible prize here and I got to ask
you, are you maybe continuing going to
play Yasuo going forward or Unleash on
the Horizon, is there maybe a new legend
you want to maybe bring that trophy home
for?
>> This card's really pretty. So, maybe
maybe I go for the repeat, um but
they're all really pretty, so it's it's
tough. I have to I have to figure that
one out.
>> All right, well, TBD, but I'm hopefully
still going to see Momsky at a future
regional qualifier and I can't wait to
see what you cook up. Congratulations.
>> Appreciate it.
>> I'm joined here with the best of Leona
winner, Snowfalls, and I've got to pick
your brain real quick.
You kind of already knew that you won
this starting off today. So, obviously,
congratulations, but did you have a
great time in the tournament cuz you're
playing a legend that I think a lot of
people like and you're the one taking
home the prize.
>> I think for most of Leona, right, it's
super hard to play in this meta with all
the reboots in the hand. So, it's kind
of really hard to do that. So, what for
my play style, right, I was more of of a
go into fight fight might to might style
cuz I have Leona legend
stun, so I was going to be plus one
always. That's why though.
>> No, it makes sense and it's and it's a
smart way to go about it cuz a lot more
people are going into combat now and I
got to say like the stun mechanic can be
pretty good against the Dravens of the
meta. So, I'm glad you had success. I
have to ask you one more question. If do
you like Leona so much that you're going
to play her maybe at a future regional
qualifier, take home another one or do
you think you're going to play a new
legend that's coming out?
>> Most likely a new legend. I've been
looking at Ivern maybe or
Lillia also though. Cuz two those two
are my favorite jungle champions. That's
why I don't know.
>> Well, I can't wait to see what you cook
up. Of course, Ivern, same color, same
domain, so you could play a lot of the
same cards. But congratulations on your
win, taking home a great trophy.
I'm joined here with the best of Victor
winner, Rift Bound plus, and we even got
to see you on stream. Now, of course,
maybe not the result that you wanted,
but in the end, you still took home that
best of. How does it feel?
>> Ooh, it feels amazing. Oh my gosh, this
result is amazing. Uh just such great
matches all weekend. The whole weekend
was great. Today was great. Um couldn't
be happier.
>> Absolutely. And now you're third top 64
right across uh all these uh regional
qualifiers that you've gone to so far.
But my last question that I want to ask
is this. Are you going to continue to
show us that you are a great Victor
player, or are you maybe going to pivot
to something new in Unleashed?
>> You know, there's a new
uh Order Chaos legend on the horizon,
LeBlanc, the deceiver, one of my
favorite characters from League of
Legends. I'm a mid lane main, which is
why I brought the Victor control. Maybe
I'll bring in the assassin uh coming in.
I think she's going to be hot in
Unleashed, and I'm thinking about trying
her.
>> She is, and she's going to be highly
contested just like Victor was this
weekend. So I believe that you can
definitely do it, and I'm excited to see
that LeBlanc list. Rift Bound plus,
thank you so much, and congratulations.
>> for having me play some Rift Bound.
>> That's right.
I'm here joined with the best of
Misfortune here, Snake. All I really
want to ask real quick, I know you got a
you're really busy person. You got a lot
to celebrate for. How do you feel in
this moment, having worked incredibly
hard for this coveted prize?
>> It feels fantastic. I tried it Houston,
I got top 64 and lost in 64, and now I
have it now, so it's great.
>> Absolutely, Snake. Now, are you going to
keep playing Misfortune, or are you
going to mix it up with the next one?
>> I'm a Diana main in League, so when
Diana comes out, I have to get the best
of Diana.
>> Well, I hope to see you with that best
of Diana at the next one. Great job,
man.
>> Kangus, we have made it to semi-finals.
It is now time to cast the top four.
>> There are two more matches left of the
stream. Two semi-finals happening
concurrently and then one finals and
then we will have a new regional
champion here in Atlanta. And we have
four unique decks in the top four, Ms.
Chim Chim. It is incredible the
diversity that we're seeing in the meta
right now.
>> Yes, I am super excited and I'm super
excited especially for, like you said,
the unique decks that we're about to
see.
>> Yeah, we got Draven Aurelia and then we
have Ezreal and Annie. I hate to say
Kaisa did not make it. It was I was
watching it on the secondary feature
match, the Kaisa versus Ezreal match up.
Um, that was Alan Z Q versus Frosty. It
was close. It was a banger. I'm telling
you, you missed out not us not being
able to get that on the broadcast, but
um, if you know any of them, check out
their socials. They're probably going to
be talking about it. Really, really
tight match between the two of them.
Alan Z Q, he's just so good
>> He's just so good. Oh, it's crazy.
>> I also want to point out like we had a
lot of two ones here in the
quarter-finals. So, a lot of it was
really close. Even the Prismaticism's
ism and Colleen going head-to-head
there. It came down to the wire and
there were a lot of uh, turnarounds and
like uh, this like crazy moments.
>> down the end of game two. That was
almost a two-oh, but Prismaticism had to
come back like a crazy end to game two
to to even the series and then close out
the series. Also, uh, bless the seeding
uh,
because all the Dravens got put on the
top half of the bracket. So, they kind
of like hit each other a bunch yeah, on
the way out. It was Draven versus Draven
and then uh, Harukaze actually on
Aurelia was able to beat Boulevard on
Draven. So, that means
we almost had like a Draven Draven
semi-finals mirror, which would have
guaranteed Draven in the finals, but now
with four different uh, legends, it's
anybody's game. All four of these,
especially when you look at the pilots,
could be capable of taking it.
Especially when you look at the
matchups, too. Like Draven Irelia, the
two most represented decks of the
tournament against each other. Ezreal
Annie, two of the more kind of niche
picks just with expert pilots,
teammates. Alanzq went through a past
teammate and friend in Frosty, now might
have to go through another friend and
teammate in Prismatism to make it to the
finals.
>> Yeah, no. Very exciting here, but I'm
just glad to see this diversity. We've
got the Ezreal and the Annie and the
Draven and the Irelia. So, I'm glad to
see
we going we going to see somebody new.
>> Also, potential for two teams to be
against each other. CTG versus CTCG.
I think I got that right. Either way,
they're different teams, different
acronyms. We could actually have
different teams represented in a
regional finals. That'd be really fun.
At least on the name. It's It's probably
happened before in spirit, but this is
official. They They changed the Riot tag
to include it.
>> Absolutely. But, let's kind of talk
about that Irelia versus Draven uh
matchup here. I believe I heard that
Irelia's normally winning
>> 56%. I like Irelia into Draven. I feel
like it's one of the strong matchups
because not only can you just get around
the battlefield and then get away from
the Draven. Cuz a lot of times Draven
wants you to stay on the battlefield so
that they can come in and contest, fight
you, win the combat, draw card. Irelia's
one of the decks that can kind of just
play around that. You got your Right the
Winds. You got a lot of ways to just
kind of move around the the battlefields
and and not give them that opportunity.
We also have a lot of buff spells, so
it's kind of hard for the Draven to do
the math cuz if you have four runes up
to like
a you know,
it's can be so many things. On guard, it
can be disciplined, it can be even like
if some people are like a one-off
Switcheroo, they're hiding. That That's
me. No one else is on that.
I I think it's good.
All kinds of stuff that the Irelia can
do to really mess with the Draven
player. So, I I think it's a really fun
matchup, and it's one that while people
often are just like, "Ah, the rogue
decks are more fun than like the top two
most represented." When you watch two
really good players playing Draven
versus Aurelia, it is very entertaining.
So, I think that's going to be a great
show, too.
>> Absolutely. And then we have What was
the other match-up? Was it the
>> Ezreal Annie. Yeah, Prismatist on the
Annie has been looking
killer.
>> He has.
>> That's going to be a battle of who's the
main character cuz both of those Both of
those players in their feature matches
have just been drawing like the perfect
card for the situation they're in. Uh
game two for Prismatist getting that
Kaisa and Alan Z Q against the Jinx that
we highlighted with the triple stupify,
like insane. Yeah.
>> Absolutely. And I mean Coco's Swiss run
was absolutely insane.
>> Yeah, let's take a look at some of the
runs here because uh we can see this is
the Draven pilot from CTCG. There we go,
I was right. Um
had no opponent, yeah, so the bye
because they they were able to win one
of the
regional qualifiers.
Um
Sleeping Skittle, great name. Uh
Skirmisher, sorry. Sleeping Skittle,
Slack Eye, Masta, Nicknac. But let's
look at the match-ups. A lot of Dravens.
More Draven mirrors, actually.
>> Yeah, but he came out on top every time,
it looks like.
>> True against Alan Z Q on the way here.
That's actually really interesting.
>> Yeah, I think I think that's both of
their one
tie there.
>> Yeah, must be. And what what a player to
tie against. I mean, at that point that
could set up for a big grand finals cuz
they're on opposite sides of the
bracket. So, we could get a rematch
>> Ooh.
>> in the grand finals. You're not going to
go to time in that one. We will get a
definitive winner.
>> Yeah, we'll get a full play of that one.
And we see he also is the reason that we
did unfortunately have to say goodbye to
that Frosty, but you know,
is what it is.
>> Uh I believe that was around 12 of
Frosty. So, that was Frosty's first
loss. But uh it was actually um Alan Z Q
that beat Frosty in the
uh
eighth place match or the the top eight
match. Either way, let's take a look at
the next one here. Harukaze the opponent
in Aurelia.
Let's look at this. Also a couple of
mirror matches. Wow.
>> Yeah, a couple of mirror matches but
also we've got a bunch of Dravens here.
Uh I also see the two Kaisers so had to
go through a little bit as well. Love to
see the Rex Eye and um we also see the
set there towards the bottom.
>> And there's a few, I'm sorry. Got the
win against Fiora. You're
gorgeous.
>> His depression, my depression after
seeing that.
>> Yeah, and a Rex Eye. Actually a Rex Eye
pretty late in the event too so maybe
the best performing Rex Eye. Not many
were making day two to begin with so
um that's the path that they both took
to get here. I would argue that uh the
Draven path was a little harder. A lot
of mirror match-ups and also a lot of
really notable names. Not that, you
know, um
uh the Aurelia pilot wasn't playing
against good players but just when you
look at the the name value of the
opponents that you're up against uh I
think Draven had a tough road to get
here.
>> Absolutely and I mean I'm pretty sure
the mirror match-ups can't be easy at
all because, you know, your your deck
lists are going to be kind of similar
and you just get the luck of the draw
whatever is in hand.
>> Some I mean we did hear from previous
Draven players on stream like, "Oh, I
teched my deck to win the counter
match-up or the the mirror match just
because, you know, that that's going to
be one of the most popular decks." And
it it was in fact the most popular deck
here in Atlanta. So, maybe some of these
Dravens have those type of answers but
then if there's no more Dravens there in
the rest of the top four and you teched
out your Draven deck to beat Dravens,
you know, that's not going to be the
field anymore. It's not going to be like
it was uh back in Vegas. So, yeah, we'll
we'll see what happens going forward.
Who do you think is favored from this
point on with just these four decks? I
have an opinion but I'm curious uh who
you're rooting for whether a a duelist
or a deck.
>> Who I'm rooting for and who I think is
going to win are two different answers,
unfortunately.
>> All right, let's hear it.
>> Um I do feel like Ezreal Allen might
take the win from what I've seen today.
>> Okay.
>> He's been really dominant in a lot of
his and he's very confident. And uh he's
also shown like he will take that safest
route to get the victory, like really
just making sure all of his ducks are in
a row before taking any action, okay?
So, I'll say that.
I would cheer for
the Irelia.
>> I was going to say the same. Irelia
hasn't won a regional yet. I think it's
time.
>> It's time.
>> It's time. The last year of the
regional.
>> Yeah, we've seen the other winners.
We've seen the Draven, we've seen the
Annie, we've seen the um the Ezreal wins
already. And uh I think I'd just like to
see the Irelia, but why don't we look at
what Irelia is running right now?
>> Let's do it. Up first, a deck list here.
This is Harukaze's Irelia. Let's see if
there's any outliers or if it's pretty
standard. I will say some of the
outliers I'm noticing, Mind Splitter in
the main deck. I don't see every Irelia
pilot this. It's a big unit. Sometimes
you don't have the amount of runes
necessary to really pull this play off.
You have to play very patient in the
early game in order to set this up. And
in the main deck, again, like sometimes
maybe side deck it in if you know that
you can play patient into certain
matchups, but main deck means that I
imagine that Harukaze actually plays a
slightly slower uh game tempo of Irelia
than than we've seen others play that,
which kind of deramps themselves
earlier.
>> Absolutely. Now, before I got on my
uh Fiora uh
journey, I did play Irelia. So, uh this
does look pretty pretty standard to me
besides the Mind Splitter. I don't
remember running any Desert's Call. I
think that's also one that stands out to
me, but everything else looks pretty
freaking standard that hard bargain,
that not so fast because you got to make
sure that you're able to protect Irelia
if there's any spells that come out,
even the Defy there, but you can even
get a little aggressive if your uh
Irelia is out of battlefield and use
those charms to bring someone in while
your Irelia is high and mighty and go
ahead and take down some of those uh
opponent units, but you can also use the
charm Never Forget to move a unit away
from the battlefield. So, you can move
them back to base. It's a very versatile
uh spell.
>> Sometimes late game, you just need to
take the point, you don't have the
might, you can just do that. But let's
take a look at the opponent here cuz I
want to see what the Draven list is
running. And again, looking for outliers
if there are any. And immediately, I'm
seeing some fun ones. The Beast Below,
this is a tech that uh is can been kind
of a more recent adaptation I've seen
within like the last uh 2 weeks, maybe
month of play. Beast Below has been
sneaking into Ezreal list, sneaking into
Draven list. It's a very big unit that
can also remove enemy units. When you
play me, return another friendly unit
and an enemy unit to their owners'
hands. If it's the only unit you have,
you can't return another one. So, you
just return your opponent's. But you can
also just bounce back like an Elixir of
Iron, uh a Tide Turner, a Gem Jammer,
things that you'll still get use out of
again later. Uh also one Blood Rush.
Important to note, we're on the one
Blood Rush, one Cleave. A lot of folks
are just on two Cleaves, but Blood Rush
is a little more versatile and like
sometimes you need that extra one might
um and you have the runes for it. So,
getting Assault and Forge can make the
math a little easier in some
circumstances.
>> Wow, that's a lot, but also want to
notate that Switcheroo. I think it can
always come in pretty handy, man.
>> Oh, I love the one of Switcheroo. I You
know what? I was saying I play it in my
Irelia. I think it's really funny in
Draven. Just the one of. Cuz you you
like play enough Tide Turners, you hide
those, you bait your opponent into
getting comfortable like, "Oh, it's Tide
Turner. Oh, it's Tide Turner." And then
the one switcheroo, they just don't
expect it.
>> Yeah.
>> And especially against Aurelia, you pay
the deflect cost, but if that Aurelia
gets gigantic and attacks into like a
Ferrous Forerunner, even that's still
worth switcherooing. So, that might be
very impactful in this game.
>> I I truly expect it to be uh hidden
somewhere and then reacted with later at
some point. Look at that trophy, y'all.
Let's make some no Oh.
>> Got a floating rift right there. Look at
that. That's beautiful.
>> Oh. Oh, you're you're being silly. My
bad. I was like, "Is it? Is it
floating?" I had to lean in a little
bit. Now, let's get ready for our first
semi-finals game. LET'S GO.
>> YEAH.
>> HYPE IT UP. HYPE IT UP. WE'RE GETTING
into game here. Oh my gosh. Let's go
ahead and see this Aurelia versus
Draven. And we're getting the mirror
match-up in terms of battlefields.
>> Dawn Warrants versus Dawn Warrants. I
love hearing players give their insight
as to why they play certain battlefields
at certain times. We've heard some
saying, "Oh, I play it second or or
third because it helps me see my
sideboard faster. I can just cycle
through my deck more." Some say, "No,
it's the one that you go first because
then you can go like Asper's Climb or
Arena's Greatest depending on if you're
going first or second." And Dawn
Warrants is just kind of the catch-all
to to get the cards you need for the
match-up that you want. Either way,
we're going to see a lot of discarding
and drawing cards in game one of our
semi-finals.
>> Let's get it.
I want to scream so bad, but I can't do
that into the microphone.
>> Yeah. I mean, maybe away from the
microphone.
>> Yeah. Y'all might hear me scream in the
background through uh King Ghetsis' mic
>> Yeah.
>> at the end of this.
>> I'll face this way for a brief moment.
Just give me a tap on the shoulder if
you if you feel like doing it. What are
these sleeves going on here? Oh, is that
Super Saiyan?
>> It's yeah, it's Dragon Ball Z, I do
believe. I don't know what the rune
sleeve is precisely, but But on theme.
We're going to head and go ahead and
bring out that Jim Jammer for Coco
Lopez.
>> Also, I believe the first time we're
seeing them on feature match or at least
my first time catching casting them.
Well, I'll say they snuck their way onto
one of Pacer and Charmer's. But okay,
let's talk about the starts here and
what ideal starts are versus non-ideal.
It's a decent start for Draven. You
would rather something
Actually, now I'm trying to think like
what other two mites that we saw on the
list. I guess Ty Turn is also one that
you don't really want early as much.
You're not getting any out of the Jim
Jammer, but it's still a unit that's
going to score. Meanwhile, Aurelia's is
going for the Zonyas. Typically, you
would rather have like a GA here cuz now
your own smaller units are going to eat
up that Zonyas unless it's something
like like a Stellar Corn. Like Stellar
Corn would be ideal here and there there
it is.
Okay, nice.
>> There's the Stella coming out on that
second turn there. And we're going to
pass over to Coco and we're going to
ready that Jim Jammer. Let's see what we
got here from Coco. We're going to move
that Jim Jammer back actually. Don't
want to start any problems this early.
>> And Lopez is discarding the Falling Star
cuz into the Aurelia match-up there's
Not So Fast you have to worry about.
Hard Bargain can also be really
annoying. But in instances like this, it
would get through the Zonyas, but it
also just D Ramp see so much and it
would delay the Forerunner turn which we
are already going for.
Looks like there's some thinking on
Harukaze during the Conquer window here.
>> Yeah, not sure if we actually wanted to
play that for a second, but
we are going to keep that Kaisa there.
>> Oh, so we had to trigger the Zone Wars
still. So so we just rewound briefly to
trigger the Zone Wars and we still play
the Furious Forerunner. I like this type
of play from Draven establish control at
a board especially once the Stellar Corn
gets onto the field cuz the worst case
scenario is like they move to one, ride
the wind over to the other and then move
back. So denying them the ability to
move twice and conquer two points at the
same time Uh that Harukaze's draw engine
potential is slightly diminished. Also
only going to be able to score one
point.
>> All right. And uh when I move, draw one,
and still a has moved, we've gone ahead
and gotten our first point on the board
there. So, we're kind of drawing and
seeing what we want here.
>> I like discarding the Desert's Call. It
doesn't get a lot of value in this match
up cuz it's only four might represented
from four energy cost. You usually have
better things to spend that energy on.
It's good in other match ups, but uh I
could imagine it even coming out of the
um the deck for sideboard going into
game two here. But, let's see what
Harukaze has in hand. I see a flash. I
don't see anything else. I see a flash.
I see a bargain, maybe?
>> a
um I think I saw a ride the wind there.
>> We're just going to play the Irelia
first.
>> the Irelia out. Now, she is kind of
safe. Okay, we've got that Zhonya's on
the board already. So, she's not in
complete danger as of yet. But, just
remember uh whenever you choose this
Irelia, you get to give it plus one
might.
>> Yeah, anytime it's readied as well. So,
like a ride the wind could come in here.
If if uh a snipe spell comes through
from Lopez, then that means you can
uh just go for like a discipline to try
and buff it up. Again, not so fast is
available. There's a lot that Irelia has
with two energy visible. Like, so many
of the spells are are low cost. So,
Cocoa Lopez should expect something to
be coming in here. The flash is the big
one to just save the Sellikorn. But, if
you move in and then they flash back,
you at least win the combat. Still is
the Draven, so you get to draw as well.
Um and that's I think what Harukaze is
just accepting basically. It's like it's
an unprotected Sellikorn outside of the
Zhonya's, but good chance that you're
giving the Draven an additional resource
here on top of being ahead in points.
>> Yes, and it looks like we're going to
Oh,
get the Oh, get the second gem jammer.
>> He's thinking.
>> We're thinking. You know, it's very
important that we think these through.
Like, we are semi We're not playing in
little games no more.
>> No.
>> We playing a We playing a big boy game.
>> And he he he gets in there.
>> you know what? We're bringing out that
Jim Jammer, so we're going to go ahead
and put that into base here.
>> He'll give ganking to one of the units
at the battlefield. It looks like he
tapped the Ferris Forerunner, so I'm
assuming it's that. That makes sense to
me. You won't get the draw from the
conquer, but it's just more safe to send
the Forerunner into the Stellar Corn
than it is the Kai'Sa.
>> Absolutely.
>> There's so many things that can get a
three might above a four might in the
Aurelia deck, so throwing to six, even
if it's like a defiant dance, you die.
Like you get two mech tokens. So Coco
Lopez is playing for the efficient move
here, or more of the defensive efficient
move as opposed to the offensive
efficient move.
>> And there we are. We're going to move
that Ferris Forerunner over, and boom,
there's the rebuke. The rebuke is coming
out for the two
runes and two recycled.
And we're rebuking that back to Coco's
hand.
>> All chaos runes spent on Harukaze's
side. We got to keep in mind if he's
able to flip over two more, or if he
only flips one. Because if it's only
one, Coco Lopez plays the next turn
knowing that rebuke is not possible if
Aurelia's on like two or three of them.
Um but let's see what the next decision
here is, because uh you can just try and
play like your your Draven. You're
already at four points, so it's like
pretty big. It's a seven. Honestly, I
don't even hate that.
Or you play the Darius. That's pretty
good, too.
>> the Darius. So Darius is going to come
out and immediately go to the other Zuan
Wrens and take care of that Stella.
>> Yeah, and then I imagine move the Kai'Sa
back. Actually, ooh.
Okay, yep, triggered his Zuan Wrens
discard draw, and discards a Ferris
Forerunner.
Huh.
>> Oh, wow. That's a big boy to let go of,
now.
>> Yeah, I mean, maybe it signals that
there's more in Coco's
>> Something better?
>> hand. Well, we don't Maybe just more
Ferris Forerunners, I'm thinking. Cuz
like otherwise, that is such an
efficient unit, even in this match-up. I
feel like it's pretty good. Especially
when one rebuke's already gone, but the
Zonyas did save the solid one. So,
Harakaze has the ability to move that
around still and get some draws.
But with Coco winning the combat, he got
an additional draw. That's always the
danger of playing into Draven.
He just gets advantage for playing the
game.
>> Absolutely. And I mean, if we take a
look at the board state oh, we're
hiding. I mean
The
Oh.
>> We don't know.
>> It was hidden.
>> It was It was
>> It was a switcheroo.
>> I'm really sad.
Don't want anyone to hear.
>> Yes, we don't want anyone to know.
>> This could be big. It's a five-might
unit. Hiding switcheroo with a
five-might unit is very uncommon, but
into Irelia specifically, if you're
trying to hit in on that Draven or that
Darius, you're probably going to go a
little bigger.
You're at least going to read like,
"Okay, so I have to be over seven, cuz
if it's tight turn, then I want to be an
eight." And then you go in with eight,
and then it's like, "Okay. Thanks for
the stats."
>> Exactly.
>> Especially if it's defiant dance, cuz
then it like lowers the Darius and it
buffs the Irelia. And yeah.
>> All right, so that still is actually
going to move in for a point. So, we're
two to five here in favor of Coco.
And Irelia at this point will basically
always be that five-might, because she's
going to be ready at the beginning of
every turn from here on out.
>> Unless she doesn't move.
>> That has happened. Sometimes you ride
the winter in and or like ride the
winter away, and then the start of your
turn, she's not ready. You're like,
"Oh."
>> Oopsy.
>> Whoops.
Not like I'm speaking from experience
>> Oh. Well, the Zonyas did go away, but
the GA is coming to play. Going to
choose her, move her in.
>> counted up. Six plus one is seven. So,
that's seven attacking in on the five.
Multiple wounds showing, but switcheroo
would have to pay the flight cost, but
it will at least force something else
out of Harakaze.
>> And are we going to react with that? We
are. So, we're going to switcheroo these
mights real quick. And that seven might
is going over to Dariana.
>> I always wonder if like Coco could have
also sent the gem jammer in just to bait
out even more and it didn't matter. Hard
bargain will just stop that play in its
tracks. Very efficient. There are no
additional energy up for Coco.
>> Unfortunate. Just no runes to be able to
pay that hard bargain.
>> Yeah, yeah. You can always exhaust two
to counter it, but you have two to
exhaust.
>> to have to.
>> Now we're in an interesting position. I
don't often see Aurelia this far ahead
on runes. You're full two ahead of the
Draven right now because of the high
cost, the deflect cost,
the the Darius cost. And if we play the
Draven on top of it all, like that's
going to deramp even more. So Coco
typically like I think of the Draven as
something that can, you know, match or
even further ramp through the Aurelia,
but we're seeing Harukaze also had the
Mind splitter has been playing a much
more slow game. Has only, I believe,
recycled one time for that Guardian
Angel equip.
And that allows you to play a longer
game with things like Mind splitter. So
Harukaze was just giving up early
points, accepting, "Yep, you're going to
be ahead early. Now I'm going to keep
two units out there with three runes
up." Again,
kind of scary proposition against the
Draven decks.
>> Absolutely because we've got those three
rune deck or three runes up, so you're
not sure what can be responded with, but
it does look like we're going to take
some type of action here to start some
type of showdown. We can't just let
Harukaze just start racking up these
points. I do agree.
>> Coco Coco's playing the game right.
Coco's ready to go and you're already
ahead in points, so you really only need
to take one of these battlefields. I
would go for the Stellar horn. The
Aurelia's got the Guardian Angel and the
Stellar horn's just going to get more
card advantage. Now the problem is like
something like Flash could be available.
Hopefully Coco has his own Hard Bargain
to play through that and we are going to
go for the solid one.
>> All right, so we're moving in both the
Kaisa and the Jim Jammer over to the
Sizzon where Stella is occupying and
we're passing that priority over to
Haru.
>> So what's in the idea? We saw the flash
already. That's I think the best thing
that Harukaze could play. You're giving
up points, you're going to give them a
draw but you get a draw and you protect
the Stellar Corn to get you more
advantage later. Like if you have
Stellar Corn, it doesn't really matter
if you're giving the the Draven draws on
combat because you're going to get more
off the Stellar Corn yourself.
I guess Kaisa will also get one. So
that's basically two draws you're
giving.
Yeah, well well I I don't I think
>> I see two Ride the Winds. Am I tripping?
And I do see the flash.
>> the Wind would be very interesting. If
you send that Irelia over there to try
and clear the Kaisa and the Jim Jammer,
you win the combat. I think the only way
Draven could win that at that point.
Yeah, here we go.
>> Here's the two and the one recycled for
the Ride the Wind. Let's go ahead.
>> But now do we do we move the Irelia or
the Stellar Corn? Cuz we could just save
the Stellar Corn.
>> Right.
>> At that point I think you should flash
though.
>> Oh.
>> We're going to move her back to base and
draw off of the move.
>> I don't
see the reason to do that over the flash
cuz we just recycled a power
and flash would have accomplished the
exact same thing.
And if they had a hard bargain
then you
then you didn't, you know, recycle.
Interesting decision. I feel like Ride
the Wind's a little more versatile
especially in the mid game when you have
the Irelia already set up. You can get
around the battlefield more
and also
if you use a flash instead then you're
not, you know, losing that power cost.
But again, Harukaze, I would I would
take a guess as a better Irelia player.
Um so I'll I usually still defer to the
expertise of the players on stage.
>> I even wonder like maybe we're just
saving that flash in case we have two
units that are in trouble maybe cuz you
can use it for two rather than just the
one.
>> about Aurelia is once you have the draw
engine and you get enough draws on Cell
Core and you have the Aurelia, you kind
of just play with the Aurelia. Like you
don't really need to have two units for
the rest of the game. Like even if Cell
Core dies at that point, you kind of
have what you need to play with Aurelia
and five cards in hand. Um but the
Dravens is going to keep establishing
the board
uh and tie turner to save the Kaisa and
not even playing the Overzealous Fan at
the battlefield, just keeping it at
base. So, not going to try any attempts
to hold at that other Zuan Warrens. Coco
Lopez uh understands that they are ahead
on points and even if Harukaze holds and
then conquers this other one, Coco Lopez
is still in a position to win on the
next turn with a big push.
>> Absolutely. Also, played that Noxus uh
helpful into base. So, we've kind of got
a lot of might over here on this side
for Coco. But we're about to see how do
we want to tackle the situation at hand.
The Irelia comes in readied, we get the
additional
and we've got all of our runes ready.
Arthur is
on guard
flash. I can't tell.
>> we know that there's the flash. That's
what looks to be at the the front of the
hand there. Yeah. I really haven't
gotten many good looks at Harukaze's
hand. There there is an on guard. I
think there's a discipline.
>> I do see the discipline as well.
>> another ride the wind. I think you're
right that there are two ride the winds
in the hand. So, I guess maybe that's
another reason why Harukaze would use
that as opposed to the flash just cuz
then you have options in the future. You
can choose between the two. But now we
have one less rune to work with this
turn. Let's see what they do. There's
seven available.
And uh Cell Core is going to move into
the safe battlefield just to get a draw.
So, they're just using this basically as
a draw one. Now we will see the ride the
wind. And important to note, no rebuke
on Coco's turn because there's only one
available chaos rune for Harukaze right
now.
>> Wow. That's a lot of drawing that we
just did off of that Stella. And then
we're going to immediately on guard to
make sure we clear that Zuan Warrens.
>> Okay, nice. Good good use of stellar
corn. Should be readied right now. Or
did they move him back to base?
>> moved moved it back to base and then
went into the zone.
>> Interesting that they did that as
opposed to moving to the zone and then
back to base. Cuz now I guess it's
holding it's going to force something
from Coco to go up there.
>> Yep.
>> And with like an on guard and discipline
in hand, maybe you're trying to fight
through all of that. But I imagine
Coco's in a really good spot. Harikaze
needs two turns to win. Coco can win
this turn and has so much gas as the
Draven. I'm vastly favoring Coco in this
current board state.
>> Yes, it looks like it, but there are a
couple of runes up on the side of Haro,
so I won't count him out for now.
>> attacking into an Irelia. Like there's
so many
>> She can get big.
>> It is a ridiculous how many things
Irelia can have access to, but one
that you're not going to expect is like
a ride the wind defensively for Irelia
to jump over. You've already seen two of
those. Also, Irelia wouldn't even ready
if that happens. So, you're you're
reading on guards, you're reading
disciplines, you're reading the worst
could be the defiant dance, cuz that's
going to not only increase their might
but lower yours. So, you really are
basically assuming like again, in
situations like this, if you're going
for the win, you almost always have to
assume worst case scenario. It's like,
okay,
if they have three defiant dances and an
on guard, can I beat that? If the answer
is yes, then
absolutely 100% do the line, cuz like
that's worst case scenario. It can't be
reviewed cuz there's not enough chaos
runes.
And then if if you don't have enough to
get the worst case scenario, you kind of
like dial it back. Like, okay, 80% worst
case. Can I beat that? Is that a math
worth it to go for a push or do I play
patient because Harikaze needs two turns
to win? Do I just try and like take one
battlefield and hold it? These are the
types of decision trees that I love
seeing the top players go through. We're
going to send 10 might into the stellar
corn. A single defiant dance would not
be enough. You'd have to commit multiple
tools here to keep the stellar corn
alive.
>> And I'm not going to lie to you. I don't
think I see a single defiant dance in
that man's hand. And that's going to be
the best resource at sometimes because
not only do you get the plus two, but
you get the minus.
>> Oh, he's letting it go. I was about to
say it might be a flash angle. Just save
the stellar corn get another draw. But I
guess we're saving the flash for the
rally because we have no way to
currently get back over there for
Harakaze. But Coco is going for the
option B that I presented which is
just go and conquer one battlefield and
then try and like reinforce that. I
imagine that Oh, wait, we discarded
another forerunner. So maybe it's not
the reinforce. That's like one of the
best cards to reinforce a battlefield.
Unless you just have enough spells in
hand. Maybe a Darius if you want to push
into the Aurelia.
>> I saw we just sectioned the runes into
four and four and now we've got the two
and the
Okay, like we keep pressing them to the
side. I'm not sure if those runes mean
anything specifically.
>> One of the best ways for Draven to hold
points is either Ferris Forerunner cuz
it's just a big stat stick or multiple
Overzealous Fans. So we already have one
in base you can just move that up. Maybe
another Overzealous Fan.
You know what I just remembered? Oh no,
we already saw this Switcheroo, right?
>> Yes.
>> Okay, I was going to say what if it's
Switcheroo.
No, it's going to be Overzealous Fan
going into the battlefield. And even if
the Draven just passes without playing
anything else there like all of these
runes up is scary cuz they have rebukes.
They have spinning axes.
They have a lot of things that can you
know try and reinforce this. Some are
even on rank I don't think that Coco
Lopez was. So I'm imagining at least
something coming down here.
>> Yes, and it looks like we're going to go
ahead and exhaust three and play a
Rexai.
>> Oh, we can
play our
Draven Showboat from the Chosen Champion
zone.
>> We've got five exhausted
>> right now.
>> And yes
>> It's still going to be just an 11 might
unit. Or sorry, 10 or
uh 10 might unit as it's three base
might.
>> Oh, we've decided to go another route.
Instead, we're going to exhaust and
bring in another Jim Jammer here.
>> And maybe Noxus hopeful. It's it's two.
Okay, I didn't quite catch the art.
You're right, Jim Jammer. Um so so this
to me signals a Coco saying, "Yeah, it
it doesn't necessarily matter to win
this next turn. I just need to force
Horikaze to use resources to get me off
the point." Because you always have the
Rexsai with the uh Draven Showboat
aggressive play. The danger of this type
of line is that one charm can kind of
you know, kneecap that game plan. Cuz if
Aurelia can clear the point uh and then
also charm the Rexsai in, that means you
can't accelerate the Draven Showboat
afterwards. So, there's always a a cost
to be paid for any decision tree you go
down. Coco has made his decision and the
turn has passed. If Coco holds, that's
game one.
>> And honestly, I can try and deduce this.
I'm not sure if this is totally
uh true, but we did see Coco fidget with
both the Draven Legend, the Jim Jammer,
and finally the Tide Turner, and then
hid a card at that battlefield, which
makes me assume it's that Tide Turner.
>> Which I believe we know it is because
the only hidden cards were
three Tide Turners in the deck. If if I
remember the deck list correctly, maybe
it's something that surprises us, but
I'm reading that that's going to be a
Tide Turner, so it'll be two extra
might, which would make this a total of
12 defending. Overzelous Fan has the
option now to move back the Aurelia. So,
we flash, we saved that. We didn't save
the Seller Coin. Instead, we're going to
flash back the Aurelia, send her in. She
did not ready for turn, so it's only one
might from the targeting of flash. That
is currently a six might Aurelia. And it
looks like Horikaze actually passed
priority to Coco Lopez. This is
something that Aurelias can do. You just
uh chew through the GA and then can even
just play another one, equip it, use
your Irelia Blade Dancer uh legend to
then re-ready the Irelia go in again.
So, it's just kind of like a way to hit
multiple times. You're going to give the
Draven some draws, but it's a way to
chew through that uh that hold.
>> Absolutely.
Uh it looks like we're trying to decide
how to deal with this at the moment. Cuz
I don't think we
want to do any Tide turn in quite
>> see what Coco has in hand? I I haven't
really spotted anything.
>> No, it's been really close to chest so
far.
>> Number one thing you could do is uh
throw out a rebuke and just kind of hope
they don't have a hard bargain or a not
so fast. That's a little scary. Like an
equipment is a safer move if you have a
spinning axe cuz there's really no way
for the Irelia to interact with it. Um
but it looks like we're actually just uh
I I actually, you know what? That wasn't
priority. I think that was the
Overwhelm's Fan trigger cuz you have to
trigger any defend uh abilities before
an action window opens. So, we're past
the Overwhelm's Fan window. Coco did not
use Overwhelm's Fan on the Irelia and
now the uh
>> Defiant dance.
>> down.
>> It's coming down. We are minus two in in
plus two in the Irelia. It looks like
the minus two is on the Kai'Sa, I do
believe. Yes, thank you so much judge
for that clarification there. And we're
going to see the flash come out from
Coco.
>> So, this is a total of eight defending
might against the nine attacking. So,
flash will save those resources and just
give up the point. Yeah, Harakaze knows
that hard bargain would blank the flash
and it can clear everything on there and
that is a big swing for Harakaze.
>> All right. So, those are totally off the
map all together. And now Haru has taken
full control of not only this
battlefield, but
I'm a good game.
>> So, so we haven't dealt with the Rexite.
If a charm comes out here, I think
that's just GG. I don't think Coco,
unless you have like a Darius,
uh
or maybe like an accelerated Kaisa or
some way to like just get more might on
the field that can go in, which I I to
be fair, Draven does have a lot of
access to those types of things, but
you're at least getting rid of the known
threat. No charm, that means that the
Draven Showboat from the Champion Zone
can come in accelerated cuz this Rexsai
allows any unit not played from hands to
enter with accelerate. That's going to
be a 10 might Draven that I imagine will
hit the board at some point on this
turn.
>> We do have three
Uh we do have three uh
runes still up, so
>> Yep. Harakaze has tools. He can try and
do stuff.
>> to to deal with this.
>> But the Defiant Dance was used and uh
that means that at worst case scenario,
there's two. So So again, anytime you
get information like this, you can start
to chip away at the worst case scenario
situations when you're doing your math.
Now worst case scenario would be two
Defiant Dances and one On Guard. So
that's uh what, 10 might Delta? So as
long as you get above even that, okay.
>> So Fast for the Rebbuke trying to get
that back into the hand, but we're just
>> Hard Bargain! Oh, he can counter the
counter and that's going to be game.
Yep, Harakaze immediately scoops up the
Hard Bargain to stop the Not So Fast is
enough. Coco had another unit. We did
not even need to see the Draven
Showboat. It just came down to the
spells.
>> Got the counter for the counter.
>> Yeah.
>> And I think we're going to go ahead and
move on to the next game, Raven Bloom
Conservatory for game two on the side of
Haru and Aspirant's Climb. So we're
climbing. We're climbing this one.
>> Whenever you're going second or assume
you're going second, you know, your
opponent still gets to choose, but most
players will always pick going first. So
when you assume you're going second,
Aspirant's Climb will just delay the
game. Your opponent can get set up
first, but then the game goes a little
longer. I will say as uh an Aurelia, I
don't think you really mind the game
going later cuz it also buys you time to
set up your field, and you don't have to
feel as pressured to get in there super
fast. So, um and also going first,
you're often on an odd number of points
anyway. So, it's like yeah, you know, if
you conquer and then like get on the
other field, you usually be like to
three if you conquer hold conquer. Uh
but now you're at four. Um so, it's uh
it's interesting to see how that math
kind of changes things, but the the
bigger thing is that Draven can get
bigger now on the side of
Coco Lopez. Draven Showboat gains might
for every point you have, and Aspirant's
Climb means that they can get to even
larger numbers than normal.
>> All righty. Well, let's get into this
game number two. We're getting started
here. Two runes coming out for Aurelia,
and we're immediately starting with that
Tide Turner.
All right. Stack deck on the side of
Coco. Going ahead Going ahead and
looking through what cards we might want
to add.
>> Tide Turner start for Aurelia. Uh again,
when we're looking at ideal starts, it's
like eh.
>> Yeah.
>> It can get you a point, but it doesn't
really do anything on its own, and
Draven kind of just chews it up. So,
there's the stack deck, and let's see
what the first unit is. Overzelous Fan.
>> Overzelous Fan. So, uh we could go ahead
and go in and get a point, and maybe uh
Coco might move to the other
battlefield, but instead we're going to
bring in that Stellacorn. So, we're
going to start drawing.
>> Eventually. Now, do we send the Tide
Turner in?
>> I see.
>> Now now we're tapped out. Okay, we're
going to go for the Rainbloom
Conservatory. This will get us a point.
Uh and again, being on odd points isn't
bad into the Aspirant's Climb. Um I
realized I kind of tripped over my words
at the beginning. What I What I meant to
say is uh it's similar to like the um
Arena's Greatest, where being on an odd
number of points scored in early turns
isn't a big deal because you can still
score if you're at like one point now,
it's still now four turns of double
scores for the rest of the game. So, if
you're able to kind of like score two on
a turn, which is a max you can typically
get, uh you're still able to end on the
same clock uh as opposed to being on an
odd number uh when it's like a normal uh
battlefield state. But, uh all that's to
say that I think Harukaze uh is going to
opt to just look for a spell dig so that
hopefully even if you lose combat to the
Draven, you can get a plus one as well
with the Ravenbloom Conservatory
uh while having a good uh kind of score
ramp right now.
>> And boom, why don't we just go ahead and
accelerate a Rek'Sai into this
battlefield? Go ahead and deal with the
Tide Turner. Make sure that no hold
points are collected, and we still have
another unit that can go and collect
that second point. Do we want to do
that, Coco?
>> It's kind of tough cuz like if you go in
there uh and then the Stellar Corn jumps
at you, you either lose your unit or you
have to bounce the Stellar Corn back,
which gives another draw. So, I actually
don't know if Coco is supposed to send
this in.
>> But, he does it anyway. We're going to
try and get that point here, and it's
going to go through. So, we've got two
to the one, and now it's time for the
response from Haru. Do we want to go
over there and take care of that
overzealous fan?
>> Also, I didn't see what spell was added
to hand, but Harukaze did get a spell
off the Ravenbloom. I was looking over
at uh Coco's field uh when it happened.
Happened so fast, but he got something
off of it. So, uh there's the Stellar
Corn Haru going in getting a free clear.
Coco says, "Yep, you can just kill my
unit. I'm not going to give you the free
draw." So, Coco's opting for sacrificing
units in order to get points. We don't
see that a lot of that at the top
tables.
>> All right. So, we're actually going to
go ahead and equip a Boots of Swiftness,
which will give that Stella ganking. And
I think we're about to tap our legend to
ready her, and you know what happens?
Bye-bye Rexy.
>> Oh, switcheroo.
Oh, wait.
>> Oh, no. We're just going to There's no
There's nothing to switcheroo.
>> Was it not hitting at the Ravenbloom?
Did I miss something there?
>> No, he drew that.
>> Ah, oh. Ravenbloom Conservatory. Oh,
that makes way more sense. So, that's a
future switcheroo.
>> That's a future switcheroo. So, we know
it's in hand. So, yeah, Stella is going
to go ahead and clear that battlefield,
get the uh point, and then we're going
to get a Sand Soldier played off of
Desert's Call.
>> Also, uh this is a fun little mini-game
where you either count how many times
the Sellsword Herder gets to move this
game.
>> Okay.
>> I have a running theory.
>> If Sellsword uh Herder moves five times,
you cannot possibly
beat Turalia. That is too many
resources.
>> Okay.
>> I think it's at two right now.
>> Yes, we are at two. We have the base
going to the Spire's Climb and then over
to the Haru. So, I'll give you your two.
I'm going to also leave it to you to
keep that tally right there.
>> Okay. I'm going to I'm going to keep
trying, and I don't know why I put this
on myself because I already forget
things all the time. That happened like
two turns ago.
>> All right, we're bringing in the Fairest
Forerunner over on the side of Coco
Lopez. I do think I spotted another Rexy
in hand. I don't know if he's running
two for sure, but I do think I saw that.
>> And so, what what happened basically
here is that we got to see a reason now
that's three moves.
We got to see a reason why a lot of
players choose to not go into combat as
early to score points. Coco lost both
units, had to reestablish a board, and
went basically, I guess, even cuz you
scored a point on the
conqueror winning combat, and then lost
a unit, got a
spell off a Ravenbloom Conservatory
where he lost a unit. So, essentially,
you're like lost two, but gained two. Um
but still, like, the Sellsword is
getting so many more. Look at this hand
size.
>> Yeah, I think he's got just so much to
deal with everything.
Um
Goodness gracious. Desert's call is
going to come out. I do think that uh
the Stella is just getting so much value
here. You're not only getting the
points, you've not only got the five
might, but you're also drawing every
time you're scoring. It's just so much
value. And then we're going to ride the
wind.
>> Move it to the other battlefield. We
already scored there, so we're not going
to score, but it's just a draw ready and
then back to base to draw again. So it's
just an efficiency for uh draw engine
here, and that is now five.
>> Yep.
>> Five moves from Selicorne Herder, and
that again, I think it's critical now.
Like you reach a point where you just
have too many cards. Like Raven will not
have enough answers into this hand of
Harugaze. He's He's doing a little
wiggle.
>> We don't have to guess what Haru has in
hand. We can just assume it's the whole
entire deck at this point.
>> Remember when I was like you have to
kind of assume worst case scenario? This
is worst case scenario.
>> Yeah, it's starting to get a little
scary. That's why you have to deal with
that Stella corn early before she starts
giving just a little too much value. So
we're moving in. The six might is on the
board with the uh I'm going to start
calling it the Ferrari uh runner. I
don't know. Yeah, I kind of like that.
Aw, man.
>> I don't know. I don't know. Are we
allowed to
>> Rexide does come in.
>> Damien, can we say Ferrari?
>> We'll check that. Uh the second Rexide
is coming in to play for Coco. So I was
correct in seeing that in hand, and
we've got three sand soldiers on the
side of Haru in base.
>> Okay.
More draws, six moves on the um
uh Selicorne Herder. I believe eight is
the record that I counted cuz I I did a
whole like a analyst breakdown of one.
They got up to eight moves on one
Selicorne. I think that's the record to
beat for Harugaze, and given that hand,
I think that you're going to beat it. Um
Um
you only need two more moves and this is
why I think it's just like such a good
card.
>> Aw, and the Duke making the Ferrari
forerunner possibly go back to hand. I
do think there is a not so fast on the
side of Coco though. I'm not going to
lie to you. I want to see if it's going
to come out. Oh.
>> Oh, okay. We're just going to game two
or game three rather. Yeah.
>> We're going to game three.
>> Coco had just fallen so far behind.
>> Yeah, it was tough.
>> At that point like you really don't have
a clean avenue back into the game. Save
time. I I guess we're not even saving
time cuz there's no time limit here in
the semi-finals but save your mental
power.
>> Mental wins games, y'all.
>> It's still a resource, your mental
energy and cuz if you win this you got
to go into a finals as well. So you the
worst thing you can do is just tire
yourself out in the
doomed day game state. Also, I have a I
have a nice fix.
>> Okay.
>> If you can't say the card name that
you've been saying, you can say Forari.
Nah, it doesn't have the same ring to it
cuz I was saying Forerunner and Ferrari.
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. Now you know what? As I said it, I
knew it wasn't.
>> Sometimes you got to test it. Sometimes
you got to test drive it like a Ferrari.
>> in front of everybody listening.
>> Yep.
>> Yeah, they they knew too. The moment it
came out they I think there was a
collective cringe. Uh Targon Speaker
versus Hunga Temple is going to be the
game three Battlefield match ups as Coco
Lopez should get the decision to go
first and I'm fully imagining that The
Draven will take advantage of that
taking that first turn.
>> And yeah, Coco is really going through
making sure this deck is shuffled
because we really we really want to make
sure we're pulling the cards that we
need to pull. We don't want the same
cards back to back to back by an
insufficient shuffle. We're we're
playing
for the win right now. Okay, this is
game three of semi-finals. We're going
to finals if we win.
Lock the freak in. So we need that deck
properly shuffled here.
>> And you need to
hope for the right draws. I honestly
don't think we've seen like the ideal
turn one from either deck yet. In my
opinion, the ideal turn one for Aurelia
is Guardian Angel. I mean, Zone Zone is
fine, but like GA is the better ideal
start because it doesn't get wasted on
something like a Tide Turner.
And if you're going to send out the
Celericorne, you kind of want the GA on
anyway cuz then you can ready it, move
it around. Draven, the ideal start would
be
probably the
Overlord's Fanatic. He's like that turn
one big play cuz you get to play it
down, move in, and then kind of deny
your opponent from conquering a point
afterwards. You hold a little bit
better. Let's see game number three.
>> This is it, guys. We are going to know
our finalists for Rift Bound Regionals
in Atlanta after this game right here.
We're going to Targon's Peak. We're
going to Sunken Temple.
Let it begin.
>> Both of these decks like both of these
battlefields. Both of these decks can
take great use of both of these
battlefields. So, I'm imagining both
these battlefields will be greatly
contested in this game three. Let's see
what Coco's got in store for us.
>> All right. We're getting the official
the official fist bump, and we're
starting nice and strong with a gem
jammer coming out from Coco.
>> Again, not the 100% ideal start, but
it's a unit. And as long as Draven gets
a two drop, they can play the board.
>> Absolutely. And the Tide Turner is going
to be the response on the side of Haru.
We're passing turn straight back to
Draven. Yes.
>> We can go to turn three. It's actually
very nice.
>> Stack deck. Okay. Uh-huh. Yep.
>> I think it's almost always the Spinning
Axe here. I love Spinning Axe into
Aurelia specifically cuz they can't
use things like Defy. They can't use
things like Hard Bargain. It's an
equipment, not a spell. And I I don't
know if that's actually what was picked.
That camera angle, I loved it, but it
was not as helpful as it
>> It was a little dark. It was a little
dark. I'm not going to lie to you, but I
still love the angle and I
I'd love I'd low-key love it every time.
>> All right, there's uh two runes up.
We're going to send the gem jammer into
Targon's Peak, so we'll at least have
two runes to play with and I think that
was Noxus' hopeful added off the second
Nox deck.
>> Because of the lesser cost, we can go
ahead and play that out to make sure
that we've got some
units on the board.
>> Yep. Give Give us a turn for the next or
a play for the next turn.
>> Yep. Boots of Swiftness already coming
out. The three are going to be exhausted
and one recycled. We're going to go
ahead and equip that to the Tide Turner,
send that in. What can the gem jammer do
about this for my unit?
>> Harukaze's basically saying bet.
>> Yeah, like do something about it.
>> A spinning axe I actually goes really
hard here for Koko, not going to opt for
it. Maybe he didn't take it. I feel like
you
you could well when there's one showing
I guess on guard and discipline are both
on the table and then you lose the
spinning axe for future plays.
But now that Targon's Peak is it was
uncontested, you're guaranteed going to
be playing into even more runes, so
yeah, that's tough.
>> That's tough, but another Tide Turner
does come out to play on the side of
Haru. So, we've got we've got more
>> want to swap them. He didn't want to
swap the Tide Turner.
>> He didn't want to swap them. That would
have been really
>> have high-fived on the way
>> Yeah, exactly.
>> places. That's I that's in my head kind
of that's what I was thinking.
>> high-fiving right now.
>> He's high-fiving a wave blast of energy.
>> Yeah, that's crazy.
Turning the tides, truly.
>> Oh, I get cuz he he turns places with
another person.
>> Mhm. Uh-huh.
I'm I'm proud of you.
I'm proud of you.
>> Noxus' Hovels going to go into the
uh the temple and we're just going to
play the forerunner, so Koko's going to
opt to try and go for a more of a hold
strategy here. The weakness of this is
always going to be rebuke. Harukaze had
it last game. Does he have another one
right now?
>> I can't quite see what's in hand for
Haru at the moment, so I can't speculate
what's going
>> cam to go behind Haru and just kind of
like play it over, yeah.
>> It's back and forth.
>> should do, we should get like a glass
part of the table that they have to put
their hands down when they're not
looking at it and then we
>> Oh, we have a camera up. I like it.
>> that a lot too where they put their hand
down.
>> Yeah.
>> See, I'm saying
>> Oh, Stella is coming out and we saw last
game that was a real problem. So, I feel
like we might have to shut this down. Uh
I also could see us using that Ty Turner
as a sac- sacrifice just to get the
boots of swiftness off of the Ty Turner
and onto the Stella.
Really interested to see if that's going
to be a play in the future.
>> Danger, I mean maybe against other
decks. I mean Draven, you're just giving
them a free draw if you ever run in
there. I mean you would trade with the
Noxus Hopeful, so at least you like get
one unit off, but generally you don't
want to give the free draws to Draven as
now the
Gem Jammer will give Ganking to Ferris
Forerunner.
>> Oof, and that is going to move over,
collect another point, and it looks like
we've got more in store. There's going
to be five exhausted and we're bringing
in the Draven.
>> Okay, this is going to be a pivotal
play, pivotal turn for Harukaze. Koko
has committed all Oh wait, no, there
there's actually two turns left cuz we
conquer Targon's Peak. So, Targon's Peak
is always going to make this a really
interesting board state cuz you can
never truly tap out as long as you're
conquering.
>> All right, so Stella's going in. We're
drawing and we're getting an additional
point here. Keeping it kind of close,
but Koko still has the lead.
What can we do?
>> Two Ty Turners in the back. We did not
get a draw off the Sunken Temple because
we didn't buff up the Cithria Herder to
be a big enough might.
Uh I was thinking maybe there's plays
where you go like on guard or
um
you know, like disciplined to to buff
up, get the draw, and then charm
something in, but I maybe not expecting
that anymore. Instead, just the draw off
the cellar corn. But, all runes up,
still a lot of options for Harakaze. We
can establish the Aurelia. We can try
and um you know, deal with that Ferris
Foreerunner if we really want. Uh, we
can try and slow things down cuz at
least uh this next turn cuz Coco's going
to hold at the Targon's peak. Now, we're
going to go in. Okay. So, the fine dance
plus the tie turner. This is a gambit
because now even if we take this, this
gives Coco the opportunity to take it
back and then ready to runes as opposed
to holding and then not having the
opportunity to conquer for two two runes
at the end of the next turn.
Um might have been able to delay some of
Coco's options, but uh Harakaze says,
"I'm ready to get aggressive. I'm I'm
here to fight. I got a lot of resources
in hand. They're burning a hole in my
pocket.
>> All righty. Let's see what kind of
response we're going to get. There was a
not so fast in hand for Coco or not not
so fast. Hard bargain, I do believe.
>> If you do that, I think that Harakaze
just pays it easily. Coco, that's not
enough to deal with it. And even if you
lose this Ferris Foreerunner, you get
two mech tokens. That one I'm definitely
not going to sing cuz we will get
copyright struck.
Um
but um this is another one of those
things where as the uh Draven player,
you probably you know, okay, now you get
it?
>> Yeah.
>> Can't hold it back anymore. Aurelia's
coming out. As uh you at least dealt
with one defiant dance. So, that's
information. Worst case scenario often
times is defiant dance can be chained
multiple times. Now, there's only two
available in Harakaze's deck to be
played for the rest of the game.
>> All right. So, we're going to go ahead
and bring out the Aurelia for Haro. So,
the real fun is about to start, but we
don't really have anything to protect
her on the board. Not to say that we
don't have anything to protect her in
hand.
Um
>> There's not a lot that Draven can do to
hit in the back row. It'd really just be
falling star
and that can be not so fast and you can
also like discipline and then that
targets Aurelia. She goes up to seven so
then the falling star is not enough to
kill. Plus you have to pay double
deflect cost. So like it's almost in
this specific match up it's actually
very safe to play Aurelia into the back.
There's not much that Draven's going to
be able to do to interact with that and
that's just kind of like something
Draven has to accept in the match up is
like yep. Aurelia's just going to be
there.
>> Just a just a small threat.
>> Yeah, pretty pretty big threat.
But
one that you can't really deal with
until it's out of battlefield.
>> Right.
Well,
I think we're going through the motions
here trying to see how to set up the
board in a way that we can deal with it
and we're going to go ahead and move
that Noxus hopeful into the Stella but
Haru is going to respond with an on
guard.
>> First on guard.
And there's
>> Oh, and there's the spinning axe from
Draven.
>> That's going to give seven might
attacking in on five. Does Harukaze have
anything else?
How important is the stellar corn? We
didn't hit critical mass Reagan.
>> Oh, another another defiant dance. So
we're not only going to plus two our
Stella but we're going to minus two that
Noxus hopeful.
>> If this goes through it's seven
defending on five attacking. Hard
bargain is in the hand of Coco. If you
double hard bargain Harukaze cannot stop
it. You deal with the stellar corn. I
don't hate that from Coco. You have a
lot of units still available to play
with. You're going to be ahead on the
clock. You can go into the tight turn
with the rest or even just the Draven.
Chew through more resources. Going to
let it go.
>> Let it go.
So that spinning axe will head back to
base and Stella is going to be
victorious here.
>> Yeah, I mean I The other argument the
counter argument to my point is that now
you can just equip the Spinning Axe to
something else. It's Death Knell. It
only dies at the start of your beginning
phase. So, if it dies during your turn
when you're already playing, like you
can keep using it. You can keep
equipping it to stuff and going in. So,
Coco's instead opting to kind of take
back that resource. It's still a seven
might Stellarborn defending, but the
Draven plus the Spinning Axe might be
able to deal with that.
Uh let's see what Coco does. He actually
has a lot of lines left available.
>> He does. There's so much readied on his
side of the table right now.
Uh it looks like we might move this Jim
Jammer somewhere.
But we've also got a lot of might just
on that Stella now because of the
previous combat.
>> Yeah, he's deciding where to put the
Spinning Axe. It's actually going to go
on the mech token attacking six on Ty
Turner. That's four defending.
Uh the mask here it's like an on guard
or disciplined crashes. At this point
there's two Defiant Dances that have
been used. So, you're kind of
mathematically assuming that you won't
have to deal with that for the rest of
the game. It can still be part of that
worst-case scenario calculations that
I've talked about before, but in general
uh with two gone like that would be a
statistical improbability. If there's a
third in the hand of Harukaze, and now
we're sending in eight might Draven. We
conquered a point putting it above the
Stellarborn, and there is
>> on guard from Haru. Now, he did just Oh,
and then the Hard Bargain from Coco to
make sure that that doesn't go through.
It deals with the Stella, and I was just
about to say Haru probably isn't too mad
about that Ty Turner cuz now he can
equip the boots on either to the Irelia
or more likely the Stella, but now the
Stella's gone.
>> It was worth waiting.
>> It
>> It Coco was absolutely correct to wait
on that Hard Bargain. Hitting it there
when Harukaze cannot respond with more
uh exhausted runes, and then you only
have to Hard Bargain once. You still
keep up four runes. We readied two from
the Targon's Peak and had two available
as well. Coco is at five points up on
the timer and holding too strong.
The danger is that Harukaze still has
the Aurelia, but like what was that? Two
defiant dances, two on guards.
>> Yeah.
>> That is four of the available buffs and
especially the cheaper buffs. And the
Stellarhorn's gone, too. So like the
draw engine's offline. Harukaze,
unless you can get like another
Stellarhorn to keep drawing or just draw
into all of your other buffs, like your
counter spells aren't going to be as
useful. You got to get big enough to
deal with this Draven. That's a 10 might
Draven.
A five might Aurelia without enough
buffs is just not going to do it.
>> Am I tripping or is that nine might?
>> It's a six and then Oh, you're right, a
10. Or sorry, nine.
>> Nine. It's okay. Oh my gosh, and that is
the handshake. Coco Lopez the glorious
executioner is going TO FINALS.
>> NO WAY TO STOP IT. Coco can hold for
two. Harukaze says, "I didn't have the
gas in my hand."
The hold attempt was too expensive with
all of the on guards, all the defiant
dances. Victory. CTCG Coco Lopez,
congratulations
and a well-played game three.
>> I freaking love to see it. And you could
tell each individual calculation there,
the discipline. Not the discipline from
Haru that he actually played, but the
discipline from Coco that he displayed
during that game was absolutely
immaculate.
>> Yeah.
>> Oh my gosh, talk about not having
patience, man. I I I don't know if I
would be able to do that. I don't know.
>> Yeah, he saw a much better line than I
did. That's showing the experience of a
Draven player saying, "Okay, it doesn't
matter if I lose this Noxus hopeful
going in with the spinning axe. I can
still equip the spinning axe, get a
really efficient take on the other side
and then send That gets the Draven big
enough to crash over cuz then he's an
eight might attacking the seven might
cellar corn and you still have the hard
bargain. There's not enough energy up on
on the other side to pay the hard
bargain cost so you can get really cheap
hard bargain still have a lot of runes
up have massive hold and again when
Aurelia spends four of the one cost
spells to try and hold and is barely
able to do it doesn't even hold at the
end of the turn it's like oh
>> Yeah it feels bad it and that's the
whole thing about Aurelia like you you
do have these spells to get big you do
have the spells to counter things but
when you're recycling so much you look
at your board and you're like oh no I'm
kind of out of resources here.
>> And you know what's really funny?
Old Draven wouldn't have been able to do
that that's just a four might unit.
Now the game probably would have gone a
little different if if that one was
still available but it shows the Draven
showboat still has great uses it's like
it gets so massive you get this giant
stat stick that can just go in and start
you know taking over battlefields and
Draven didn't always have access to that
type of type of stuff before and now it
does and it it shows what it's able to
push through it's really cool.
>> Absolutely I mean making that Draven get
up to nine might like just those little
turns from conquering and it helped him
so much in the end there to secure that
victory.
>> Yeah and and again I just love the
sequencing of it cuz I was looking at
the might of the Draven like it's not
big enough on its own to really contest
the seven might but yeah just go for the
other one instead.
>> Boom.
>> And at first I was like oh you're
putting the the spinning axe not on the
Draven cuz that's how it would get in
and then you start the gears I could
feel them you know rotating in my own
head of like
oh I'm getting it this is a really cool
line that Kuku was able to find there
and again it just shows skill expression
I love top skill expression in card
games it's so exciting when you see
these people that that's an earned
finals right there I don't think there
was any shenanigans going on like that
Aurelia had a pretty good setup really
good defensive tools strength keep the
cellar corn alive and the just sequenced
it in a really optimal way to push
through and take that win. I love it
when that's how decks get the win cuz
it's not like a oh, they just like drew
the one of out or something like that.
It's like no, no, they just sequenced
incredibly effectively.
>> Absolutely. And the time was taken
through each of those sequences. I know
we were waiting just a little bit, but
it showed that it proved necessary to
really pull through that win. Um I also
want to say that I I think that maybe
that Stella in the second game really
helped that Irelia to get the five.
>> That's the crib last. He got it there.
Five times.
>> We didn't see much of that movement from
Stella in the game
in the final game, the game three.
Didn't have the boots of swiftness on
her, which might have been
one of the reasons.
>> Didn't get quite get enough tools to
move the Cell Core around early enough.
But still, I mean, you got to work with
what you got as Irelia. You can't always
get the Cell Core dream of moving it
every single game, especially two in a
row, but I got to say Reagan, man,
that's we we both I went I pivoted from
Kaisa, you pivoted from Fiora. We both
pivoted to Aurelion. Aurelion's out.
It's going to be Draven in the finals.
Let's hear from the pilot themselves
about their semi-finals match.
>> Great cast for our first semi-finals
match. I'm joined with your first
finalist that we are knowing, Coco
Lopez. Congratulations on making finals,
proving to everybody that we might still
be in the League of Draven. How are you
feeling right now?
>> Oh, I'm feeling pretty good. I'm
obviously tired. It's been a super long
day, right? Everybody's ready to get out
of here, but uh
I'm feeling good about the game. I'm
playing well. Decks doing good. I think
the list is good, so I'm excited.
>> Yeah, absolutely. The forerunners,
right? You know they're coming to you.
You know, we're going to always be able
to play these incredibly important card,
and you're definitely going to need it
in the finals cuz I'm sure you're aware
of who's on the other side of that
bracket. We don't know the winner yet,
as we have Alanzq against Prismatist on
the other side. But I mean, if you had
to pick one of those opponents for you
to go against, what are you feeling
right now in the moment?
>> I think if I had if I got to choose who
I play against, I'd probably pick Briz
as the actual match-up is is obviously
is winnable, but it's not ideal. I don't
have a lot of tools to beat Driven in my
opinion. I played him in the Swiss. It
was my one draw.
And it was it was rough. All three games
were hard and grindy and I haven't
played for
for his Briz yet, so I'd like to see how
that goes, but usually I think I think
I'm good at Annie, so I I'd much rather
play into that than the Ezreal.
>> Absolutely. And I think the biggest
thing I want to ask too as you know, you
know, on the team of course,
representing very well. Your team doing
incredibly job here.
My biggest question to you is for the
people at home making it to the finals,
how much time did you have to put in
perfecting this deck, making it as good
as can be and obviously you're playing
out of your mind. How many hours do you
think it took for you to be at this sort
of level potentially taking home the
crown?
>> Man, infinite hours. I mean, you just
have to put in hours every day.
Thankfully, luckily, just like you said,
I have a team who puts in infinite
hours, so even if I'm not putting in all
the hours, I get so much help from them.
The deck is obviously wasn't just mine.
Danny has been working on it. Calm has
been working on it. Everybody's been
putting their own piece on it, so
obviously everyone puts in a ton of
effort, a ton of time and
hey, it rewards you, so it's good.
>> With great teamwork rises great stars
and our first star to shine on our final
stage is going to be you, Coco.
Congratulations and looking forward to
that match, but now take a well-deserved
break.
>> Thank you. Thank you. Thank you.
>> Good luck. Sending it back.
>> Yep. Later.
>> Awesome to hear.
>> Yeah.
>> No. I I I I can totally see the hours
that were put in. Infinite.
>> Yes.
>> I don't think that's real. I'm going to
I'm going to press exit out on that one.
I think he might be exaggerating.
>> Maybe just a little bit.
>> Might be.
>> I'm not too sure, but uh we also heard
that his teammates
>> Yeah.
>> weighed in on there. So, it's it's
really valuable to not only have your
own understanding about like what you
want your play style, but to also have
your teammates who are playing these
other decks weighing in on, "Well, maybe
I do this and then you can do this." I
think it's so valuable to have that team
atmosphere cuz you can really grow.
>> Yeah, Challenger TCG a great team and
it's they have a representative in the
finals and it on the other side we could
have again a team versus team match-up
with believe it's CTG, if I got it
right. CTG versus CTCG. They're very
similar. It's it's fascinating. Um but
if Allen's able to win either way, we're
going to have that match-up in the
finals. And Allen I they even mentioned
they'd match-up in the Swiss and it was
a tie. So, we we could get that
definitive match. Um now I I hear that
we we have a good chance that we can
actually catch them in game three cuz
that's where uh what's happening between
Allen and Prism Matacism. But before
that we're going to have
a recap from that last match when that
one's ready to go. So, just a little
teaser. Stick around everybody cuz the
semi-finals we'll actually get to see
what's happening on the other side of
that. Both went to three games. That's
kind of hype.
>> Yes, absolutely.
And this is our bracket. Look at this
Draven finally making it grand
>> in the entirety of the bracket stage
so far. It's only Harukaze versus
Boulevard.
>> Yeah. Yeah, and then Harukaze dropping
out there. But now we have the Ezreal
versus the Annie going up against each
other and it looks like it's one one.
And so, they're playing their game three
for the game deciding match of who is
going to face that Draven.
>> And uh those two had actually never seen
each other in a bracket before at a
regionals. They kind of dodge each other
on other sides of brackets or just one
would win, one would lose early, and
then they just never face each other.
So, also two friends going up against
each other for the first time. Very,
very exciting. Um Um regardless of who
wins that one, I think that's kind of a
historic match here in uh in the
history of Rift Bound competitive play.
But then, Coco Lopez going to be waiting
in the finals. I'm sure that he's going
to be watching. Uh may- maybe actually
chilling. I don't know. But but if he's
tuned in, then he can kind of scout out
uh what his opponents are up to.
>> what they're doing, what they're
playing, kind of how he wants to move.
Is are they aggressive? Are they
defensive?
>> Well, I I think that uh watching them
play uh
I I saw very different play styles cuz I
got to watch both quarterfinals uh kind
of concurrently at the same time. One
was on the feature match, and one I was
watching on the secondary monitor. And
I'd say Alanzq actually plays um
this is going to sound really conceited.
He plays Rift Bound like I do. You know,
he approaches the game in a similar
mindset of like use your your I know
again, he's so much better than I am.
I'm I'm not saying that as in like,
"Hey, you know?" But like, I think that
the mentality is a little more similar.
And like, when I look at card games, I
think of I want to simplify games. I
want to I want to make sure I'm using my
interactions and trying to like answer
one for one with my opponent as much as
I can while increasing my advantage. If
I can get a one for two, a one for three
even, uh or just find ways to like keep
drawing while I'm trading one for one
over and over again. That's a really
efficient way to approach it. Ezreal's
kind of the king of that. Like, you're
just able to uh
stupify uh Wages of Pain and clear
something, and then you get a draw. And
like, technically, that's an advantage
for you, right? And uh Alanzq kind of
plays Ezreal in that way. Where you
watch the board states, and rarely does
he have like a bunch of stuff to do.
Part of that's Ezreal's play style, but
I think also part of how Alan approaches
the game. But then, Prismatism, you look
at how he was playing in the
quarterfinals, and you get what I was
calling the gunky board states. Where
it's like six units in the back, and one
of them's a Ferris Forerunner. So, when
he dies, that's going to be two more
units. And it's kind of build up the
army and like wait wait wait. Strike at
the right time. Send the army in when it
when it's ready. Um and it's more of
this kind of patient play style as
opposed to this like get in and score
early points and pressure your opponent
and go for one-for-one trades instead
like you know, I'm going to slow the
game down and make it more complex as
opposed to simpler. So, that's going to
be really fun to see if that's actually
what's happening in the game cuz that's
my prediction is like it's it's kind of
two different philosophies between the
two players in that other semi-finals
match.
>> I'm super excited to catch up on that
when we're able to see it, but I want to
go ahead and analyze this post game.
>> Hello and welcome back. We're here at
the uh the day I guess we lost our
table. We were the we were the desk at
one point, but the the whole is clearing
out as we're not getting closer and
closer to the end of the day. In fact, I
might have to quiet my voice a little
bit because one semi-final is done,
we'll have a look at what happened kind
of at the end of that game in a second
trauma, but uh there's another one going
on right over there just past you. Two
players are still playing to determine
who's going to be in our finals, but
Aurelia versus Draven kind of the two
most represented decks and
unfortunately, the most represented one
did win at the end of it.
>> Yeah, that's right. Draven did finally
knock off the Aurelia that I was kind of
selfishly hoping would make it to the
finals because I was saying it would
either be an Aurelia or a Prismaticism
who is also still playing. Maybe I'll
get that end right, but this was a
fantastic series. Did all the way go to
game three and we're going to watch how
that wrapped up here in just a moment.
>> game two kind of the story of that one
is like Stellacorn is doing the
Stellacorn stuff and so I can see why
Harakaze wants to protect it. He has a
starts with Ungod as his spinning axe uh
knocks and hopeful moves on him and all
of a sudden it feels like the fight is
uh maybe going to get turned, but
there's a big exchange here to kind of,
you know, figure out who's going to own
the control of this in Defiant Dance,
the great equalizer or unequalizer I
suppose from Aurelia going to make this
a very unfair fight.
>> Yeah, absolutely. This is a situation
where I think Harakaze was hoping that
this would be enough might to survive on
its own. Uh we're going to see there was
also a backup play available, but one
thing you have to worry about when
you're playing against Chaos is still
counter spells, which is a little bit
weird being the calm player and then
potentially losing to the counter spell
in the end. But, I'm glad you brought it
up. This really was a series that I
think was dictated by a Stellarcorn
Herder.
Game one was not really online to the
degree it needed to be. Game two started
running rampant, was played on curve,
had those boots of swiftness, and Coco
really just didn't have a way to answer
it. But, here in game three, when
Harikaze they tried to get it going and
wanted to protect it here. Again,
they're playing through it, but you're
going to see the exchange was not able
to keep it alive. And not only did that
turn off the engine, but then also
really slowed down the point tempo of
the game.
>> think you know, pumps are interesting
cuz they are they lost it for the turn,
which can be good in this situation even
when your opponent has a big back line
of units. But, there is just so much
might left over here. Like, Stellarcon,
even with the plus force to honor, it's
just not going to be big enough, I feel
like. And I have to think with Aurelia
at home, I mean, it's rough because the
the point totals are even and you do
want to try and score here cuz you can
maybe threaten to win. Cuz if of course
if Coco Lopez conquers both here,
manages to kick you off the battlefield,
then they're going to be threatening to
win from six on their turn. But,
Aurelia's basically losing all the value
that she could have been getting from
the pumps you're committing. And
Stellarcon at this point is only going
to draw you so many more cards.
>> Yeah, and so this was a situation where
Coco had shifted to ensure that he
conquered the other battlefield. Again,
we kind of talked about it all week and
long. These even point values in
Riftbound are just not the same as the
odd ones. Not all points are created
equal. You want to go from two to four
to six and then to eight. And so, Coco
secures that fifth point and then sends
this massive Draven, which is one might
bigger again because you conquered and
scored that point on the other side.
Every point matters, and then this is
the moment where the hard bargain gets
the victory essentially for Coco.
>> not not over right at this moment, but
effectively over from this point because
there's just nothing left for her to
have cuz like all the resources got
used. The Silicon Draw injury shut her
down from there Draven is able to
navigate to a victory. So a very tight
game, a very close series, but uh a very
fun one as we are preparing now for our
final series in Atlanta.
>> Preparing for our final moments we are
as we're gearing up to possibly watch
the other semi-final match.
>> Yeah, they're in game three right now.
So we're going to be hopping into there
to see who's actually going up against
Coko in the finals against the Draven
cuz Draven was on everyone's hit list.
It was the most represented deck. A lot
of folks were like, "North America is
the league of Draven. That's what's
going to win in Atlanta." And now we get
to see what the challenger is going to
be between Alanzq and Prismatist. It is
Ezreal versus Annie game three.
>> All right, and we're seeing that the
final game is going to be on Zuan
Warrents and Sigil of the Storm.
>> I did not notice that Alanzq was on
Sigil of the Storm this entire time. So
um I'm assuming that that would mean
Prismatist is going first. Usually uh
you don't want to give your opponent
something easy to conquer there, but
we'll see what happens here as
it is uh Annie set up. Oh, he's he's got
the he's got the Annie uh best of I
think with it. Look at that.
>> Oh, wow. That is crazy.
>> That's a flex.
>> ahead and let the world know. No, yeah.
Got to go ahead and let the world know
that.
>> two metal Annies on the field.
>> the metal Annie right here.
>> That's crazy. That that's like you're
just mogging Alanzq right now. Geez.
>> I freaking love it. Well, we're going to
go ahead and y'all he's playing with the
Chinese version of the cards. So do bear
with me, but we're we're going in with
the overzealous fan. I I I can read uh
Mandarin. I I can read it. Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. That says overzealous fan.
>> I go by picture. I just I'm like that
that guy looks a little too excited.
And um
What's another word for fan?
>> Uh and very
>> I want to know the other definition of
fan.
>> Okay.
>> Yeah.
>> Oh.
>> Switch it up on you. All right, the
overzealous fan can now go into a
battlefield. We can go for the Zaun
Warrants, get a discard and a draw, and
also defend it. But against Ezreal, it's
kind of scary. He's just going to have
stuff to bounce it back, specifically
things like Wages of Pain.
Um so, Prismatism is going to opt to
again, this is This is what I notice
from him. Instead of going in and
accepting, all right, I'm going to trade
one for one resource, you're saying,
"No, I'm not going to give you the
opportunity to hit my thing. You're just
going to have wasted runes." Cuz I think
Alanzq against most opponents would say,
"Oh, I'm going to Wages of Pain here. to
get a Gold Gear, spend my three runes,
deal with the threat." But now instead,
he has a card in hand, but he didn't
develop a board, he didn't get to spend
the runes, he doesn't have the Gold
Gear. So, in that specific instance, I
think Prismatism's feeling pretty good.
But Alanzq can just play a Ravenbloom
Student and still have the card. Because
if you don't chew through it, you don't
chew through it. It's still in the hand
of Alanzq.
>> Yes. So, we've got that uh Kai'Sa ready
and the overzealous uh fan ready, and
looking to make some moves here. Both
battlefields are open.
>> I'm imagining with the Kai'Sa,
now we will conquer. First off, a Wages
of Pain alone will not deal with it.
There's only three runes up, so it's not
like a Stupefy Wages is in your future.
Maybe a Stupefy Gust is in your future.
But again, you get through two of the
resources then.
Um so, all that to say, Kai'Sa should go
into the here. Yep, and it does go into
the Zaun Warrants.
>> Yep. So, we're going to go ahead and
score our first point of this game.
>> That'll get a draw for the Kai'Sa.
>> Yep.
>> And trigger the Zaun Warrants. Uh so,
we'll have to discard and draw another
card. And then we can send the
overzealous fan in to defend the Kai'Sa,
and Alanzq will not get a action window
to react to that. I I'd say react to do
act to that, I suppose, as it would be
an action spell.
And that would force Alan Z Q and said
to like use the Wages of Pain on their
turn, which feels much better cuz then
they can't use those three runes as well
to do other stuff.
>> And it looks like the Rex size going to
get discarded here before the draw
instead of
playing that. We're just going to go
ahead and put that in our trash bin.
>> Six runes up, a lot of options to
develop right now.
The one thing I am expecting to still
Overzealous Fan to go to the battlefield
cuz the reason I just gave, even if it's
hit at that point, I think it feels
better cuz you it's still three
essentially wasted runes from Alan Z Q
on this current turn. And then if Alan Z
Q uses Wages of Pain, that would be
three runes spent on his turn that he
can't use on other things.
But again, Prismatism very often does
things that I'm not expecting. Very
often he goes for a hyper hyper safe
play.
So, there is still a world where he just
doesn't move it up there and instead
develop something else. I I I'm kind of
imagining it's not a Ferris Forerunner
cuz I feel like if it is, that's such an
obvious move that you would just drop it
right now.
Um
but I haven't got a good look at his
hand.
>> Do you think he's going to tap both
legends when he taps his legend?
>> Do you think if you get two Metal Annies
that you're able to
tap both and get and get four untapped
at the end of your turn? Like is that
just like you get a cheat code?
>> I can't wait to see when we get off of
this turn. We are going to move that
Overzealous Fan and we are going to go
ahead and exhaust six and we're bringing
in two more Rex sizes. That's why we
discarded the Rex size, babes. We got
all three.
>> All right, I want to point out two
things. First off, that's a lot of
aggression on Prismatism's next turn.
Second of all, I think for the first
time today I've successfully predicted a
move that Prismatism might do. So,
just I to say
I'm learning.
>> Did we tap the legend?
>> Getting into his mind. I'm I'm I'm you
know I don't have the hair he has that
he keeps playing with.
>> Yeah.
>> But I'm pretending to do.
I'm shadow hair tugging, you know.
>> I'm I'm just really sad cuz I wanted to
see both Annie's simultaneously tapped
here.
>> Yeah, well they don't actually have to
exhaust in order to ready the the runes.
They just kind of do it.
Yeah.
>> um
>> I just for the just for the vibes, you
know.
>> Yeah, he could build like a tower of
Annie's. Right now he's got like a
>> Yeah, he's got the bottom.
>> What's the what's the the
battle formation of of the Trojans? The
phalanx. He's got a phalanx of Annie's.
Although that would require one behind
as well. But that's the spear.
All right, we need a third metal Annie
for prismatism in order for my joke to
work. So let's work on that.
>> the blade of the ruined king promo card
since he's got top eight.
>> Fortunately not the correct domain, but
I like where your head's at. Let's see
what Alan does on his turn here as he's
got the ring bloom student.
It can be buffed if you play spells and
again that wages pain has kind of been
read from the beginning from prismatism.
And I've already kind of given the
thought process here. So Alan Z Q will
go through it, but this feels so much
better than getting hit on your turn
because Alan Z Q just had two turns in a
row where he had three runes up that he
didn't get to use. Now he has to spend
them on his turn and will only have four
more to play with.
>> We're looking for the respond and it
looks like that's going to go through.
We pass.
And we pass back.
What is he waiting?
>> that Alan Z Q has passed and and now um
prismatism is thinking.
The only thing that you would really
have is like a flash, maybe a hard
bargain. Uh but it will go through. So
wages pain has dealt with the over
zealous fan
and has created a exhausted gold gear
and now comes the card shark.
>> And now comes the card shark. So we are
actually going to get two gold gears
here uh on this turn.
We've got one more rune left.
Do we have anything that we can do?
>> I mean, one rune isn't much. You could
stupefy Kaisus and the Ravenbloom in.
Maybe that's one of the angles. You
could even Hextech or no, sorry, not
Hextech. Wait, this isn't Kaisus. Man,
I'm so Kaisus filled still.
Shout out Frosty. Uh yeah, it really
just be like the the stupefy and then
crash. Actually, it wouldn't even be
crash at that point because we played
the Wages of Pain already, so.
Uh
Alan's EQ is
still thinking, still processing. Three
cards in hand. We've targeted one thing.
I I think you would probably stupefy
either way cuz you get to draw stupefy
and then you get to use the Ezreal
Prodigal Explorer legend to draw a
second card cuz you've targeted two
things, but you got to pick a hand and
it looks like we're passing. Okay.
>> Yeah, he was asking Prismatismism if he
wanted gold from the card chart. He was
like, "Are you sure you don't want this?
Are you sure you don't want this? Are
you sure you don't want this? I kind of
want one more." But
uh of course, it's always bait, so we
went ahead and said no and we passed our
turn.
>> Trying to spot what's in Alan's hand. It
looks like a gust, a singularity,
and a
arcane shift. I think that's the three
cards.
>> That's correct. I agree with you fully.
>> Oh, there's a Fizz, too. So, that's
four.
>> yep.
Um but
we're looking here and it looks like the
stack deck again can read Mandarin
is going to come out here.
>> I'm going to press exit out on that one,
too.
I feel I feel like you're messing with
me.
>> No. Look, I read it before they pulled
up the card.
>> I'm going to I'm going to Google
Translate something for you real quick.
Keep talking about what's happening on
on screen.
>> Will do. Well, honestly, not much going
on right now. We're kind of just
thinking through the motions right here.
Trying to figure out how we want to take
action.
We're looking at the stack deck cards.
What do we actually want to proceed
forward with?
>> All right. Can you read that one for me?
>> Uh yes.
Uh hi, how can I change the language to
Chinese
>> It's actually League of Legends.
>> Legends in Chinese.
>> All right, Rex took one battlefield.
Let's catch up on what else is
happening. Alan Sell has not scored a
point here. Prismatism is controlling
the field very efficiently.
>> We're still on stack deck here,
wondering what card
>> what. No matter what. No matter what.
You know, you know what I think it was?
I started being able to interpret
Prismatism's play style once I saw him
doing push-ups between games.
>> Mhm.
>> It was like a spiritual connection
happened.
>> Do you think push-ups were done during
this uh
>> Well, I would hope.
>> Uh
>> I would hope.
>> All right.
>> Otherwise, why was I doing them?
>> I'm trying to see what we just pulled,
but I cannot. Is that a what?
I really can't tell, but we're going to
move that Rex Sai in over to the sigil
of the storm.
And uh
I I I I think you uh
broadcaster, they're showing me down
here in the bottom right-hand corner.
Um and the uh traveling merchant is
going to go ahead and come out. Thank
you cuz I was I my uh my Mandarin was
messing up there. I wasn't quite sure
what I was going to say. Traveling
merchant
>> has hit the field. Uh it's a pretty
efficient unit early on. Now, we're just
establishing a board. This is what
Prismatism has done many many times in
his feature matches, and I imagine on
the table matches as well. You go wide.
You make a lot of units out there, um
and still has all of his runes
available. So, you just exhausted two
for the merchant and then ready them at
the end of the turn.
>> Yep.
So, you got a lot to play with, but so
does Alan here. We've got Got of cards
in hand, and we have something to deal
damage with.
>> Yes, Singularity's big, but the problem
is like a double hard bargain really
shuts it down, and
Prismatism isn't that every rune
available. That is seven total.
>> That's interesting. Where do you go in?
>> Maybe you would go for like the arcane
shift on the card sharp. It can get you
another gold gear. You can instead go
for the you know, your Ezreal Prodigy,
get the draws, then arcane shift, get
the draws again. We're going to send the
card sharp in.
>> All right, we have pass priority over to
Prismatism, and that is going to go
through. We're going to take out only
one of the Rex size, but it's the start
of the battle here.
>> Yeah, and now arcane shift can deal with
the other one. So, like you can send
Ravenbloom I'm just talking known
information from from specifically
what's already on the field. We can
already we can always establish more
units, but like you can send Ravenbloom
into the Z on Warren's, and then arcane
shift back to base, sniping the Rex
side.
Um you could
Okay, cuz then you're not really giving
like the the avenue for the Kai'Sa to
attack in on the Ravenbloom soon on the
on the crackback.
Um
I I feel like Ezreal Prodigy might be a
good call here just because it can get
you more draws. Fizz on the hard bargain
is also enticing cuz it can hit the Rex
side and even if they like
at reaction speed use the long sword to
quick draw on the Rex side, you can then
still send the Ravenbloom in and crash
anyway.
>> I see.
>> And then you still establish another
unit. So, there's a lot of lines for
Alan Z Q. Like these are the types of
moments where I'm so happy I'm here and
not there. Cuz if you're in the
game-deciding
may maybe even game-deciding moment.
Like you're down three points. Like this
is the pivotal turn for Alan Z Q. You
need to take back some semblance of
control, and you have so many different
lines to go down. Really tough decision
uh tree to kind of navigate here.
>> Yeah, it looks like we've kind of maybe
started to devise a plan. I noticed
we're divvying up the runes to kind of
see maybe we could put down this Fizz
and we'll bring back a spell
uh from the trash bin for that.
>> I think this one feels the best.
>> to ignore the cost. Well, I mean, it's
the only spell in the recycle bin at the
moment was the Wages of Pain.
>> And the reason I think this one feels
the best is because we save an action
speed spell in the arcane shaft for
later.
Um we get to establish another body on
the field and it forces an interaction
out of Prismaticism. It's the flash.
It's not the longsword, but still like
now that flash is gone. Yeah, this is
how Alan likes to play the Azrels. You
just chew through the resources. Flash
is no longer available. Uh and if you
can target one more thing uh cuz the
target still happened. Um
you can also get draws off of your
Azreal Prodigal Explorer, but there's
nothing on the battlefield. So, I think
Singularity's actually the only thing
that they have they can target target
that back square.
>> yeah.
Now, there are still what? Two, four,
five runes up on the side of Pra-
Prismaticism.
>> Not ideal cuz that is double hard
bargainable. Actually, you won't even
need double hard bargain on Singularity.
One would be enough.
>> No, you just need one. Yeah, it's not
repeatable.
>> Giving purple a counter spell made all
of these Chaos X so strong.
>> Crazy.
But there's I mean, I see why it's
needed. It's something to like you got
to be able to deal with it in some way
or fashion.
>> I uh I still have this dream of making
like an Aurelia deck with three hard
bargain, three to five, three not so
fast, three windwall.
And then you just kind of hope you never
match against a Lucian.
>> Yeah.
>> All right, Ezreal's hit the board. Uh
Prodigal is going to get discard two and
draw two.
This signals to me that Alan might be
going for a slower turn and instead opt
for more resources, more choices for
future turns.
Uh here you're still falling behind in
points. Like if we don't get a point
here, that means theoretically
Prismaticism will be at five to zero
>> Oof.
>> going into Alan's next turn.
>> Yeah, and that's that I mean that can't
be optimal in any in any uh fashion.
>> I've seen decks come back from worse,
but usually not in the semi-finals
against one of the best players in the
world, so.
>> Yeah.
>> Usually it happens against me at locals.
>> We just got to take some time here and
really
>> analyze what direction we can move
forward. We've got three more runes to
play with and we do have one readied
unit. We
we could get on the board.
>> Opting out of passing.
>> Yeah. If we get on the board, you're
just sacrificing the Ravenbloom student.
I don't think that Alan Zilean's hand
was able to protect it other than Arcane
Shift. Um
but I guess I want to save Arcane Shift
for future turns cuz you can get back
the Fizz to, you know, get the Gusts.
You can get back the Ezreal to get more
draws.
Uh it's a little more flexible if you
use it on the other two and not the
Ravenbloom.
>> Yeah, it looks like we're starting to
get a little bit stressed as that Kai'Sa
goes in and scores the fourth point. Now
we're going to discard the card and uh
draw from Kai'Sa real quick.
>> it.
Looks like it.
>> I kind of want to see
what we have in hand here, but we're
holding them close to chest here. We're
going to go ahead and exhaust one and
stack deck.
>> What's that one say?
>> Stack deck.
>> Nice.
>> Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
>> Okay, maybe you do need to read. Yeah.
I can read I'm fluent actually let's see
what the choice is
but the looking at the hands now looking
back at the cards. I think there was a
merchant there. That's the only one that
I was able to quickly spot. I imagine
that's not the choice as there's
probably more efficient options and it's
cleave that is taking a hand and I think
there was another one that I got to
two cleaves representing six additional
assault strength when you're attacking
in and send the Rexall in and not the
merchant.
>> We're going to go ahead and secure that
fifth point here five to zero. It's
starting to really get down to the wire.
>> Yep,
and we're actually playing Annie
stubborn to get back the flash.
>> Oh, wow. Okay, so flash is known to go
back in hand. That is known information
for Allen.
>> And to me the signal is that
prismaticism is very happy with his hand
cuz otherwise you'd go the merchant and
discard something that you don't think
is that useful to get a different draw
and then you can flash to move them back
but instead they said no, I'm going to
keep the exact hands and the Rexall in
use the flash to be able to save that
and that means that Allen's probably
sweating even more cuz you're like okay,
he's not even digging for anything.
>> Yeah.
>> He just has what he wants right now.
>> Or has what he wants in hand.
>> I like has what he has though. That's a
that's a good thing too. I mean that
he's got what he's got.
>> You could kind of hear him say like I
bet you're feeling excited while they're
chit-chatting at the table here
but we're going to go ahead and stupefy
real quick.
>> The Rexall in.
>> Get that draw.
>> Okay.
That's going to make it harder to take
out the kaisa on the other side but
Rexall is now at two might and Fizz will
go in.
>> Now we do have the flash in hand but I
don't think we really need to. What do
you think? Oh,
we don't cuz the long sword that's that
says long sword.
>> says long sword.
>> Uh the longsword is coming out.
>> And uh that's going to be four defending
on three attacking. AlanZQ will need
something else. Another Stupefy
potentially. A Gust is not enough. No,
it's four might. Wages of Pain would
crash. Like there's things in the Ezreal
deck to do this. And again, we do also
know that there's the Arcane Shift,
which uh banishes a friendly unit then
replaces it and deals three damage to a
unit out of battlefield. So, you can
also do that to kind of blink the Fizz
out and then hit the Rex Eye. Uh
actually, you don't have to blink the
Ezreal out. Stupefy, I think is the
cleanest one. He had another one. AlanZQ
loves chaining these Stupefies together.
>> All right. So, we're going to Stupefy
that Rex Eye one more time. Tap our
legend.
And we're buffing the Ravenborn.
Yeah, let's go ahead and make sure we
know that that is equipped to the Rex
Eye here.
>> Mhm. So, minus two, plus two, back to
three might defending on the Fizz. This
would be a crash.
AlanZQ still at this point can now look
to use things like Gust or Wages of Pain
to just uh remove the Rex Eye from the
board.
I haven't gotten a good peek at AlanZQ's
hand in a while. Again, we we know it's
Singularity and Arcane Shift and Gust.
Those are the three that I remember from
before, but he's drawn multiple cards
since then. Two draws off the Stupefies,
a draw off of the Prodigal Explorer
legend ability.
>> Yeah.
We're going
>> And this is a contested game state. One
thing that I heard um Barrett, the uh
show floor host, um
uh
he actually had a a really good point uh
that he made earlier, which was when you
get to the top tables, like these big
match-ups,
one combat can be the decider of the
entire series. They're at least the
entire game. Um and in this case, the
entire series, cuz it is game three. So,
I think that this is one of those
combats where it's like depending on how
this one goes,
uh how many resources Alan has to spend
here to get the first point. There's
hard bargain.
>> There's hard bargain for that flash.
Don't really want to let them run away
from this battle here. We need to try
and get some uh
some battlefield open and some units off
the board on the side of Prismatism.
>> And oh and with the plus three might,
that's five attacking four.
>> Hey, we've cleared the battlefields
which is half the battle. We're on the
board. We've got our one point for Alan.
>> Also we got to utilize Azrael Prodigy's
second ability which doesn't come up as
often with Cultist band, but your repeat
costs are one less. Uh so that double
hard bargain was only three runes. I
believe that that's what happened there
with three town three exhausted and then
the two from the stupifies earlier.
Um and Azrael can still go in. We still
have the arcane shift. So Alan like in
terms of current board state and
resource state is feeling pretty good.
In terms of point pressure, Prismatism
is within uh two turns of winning.
That's putting pressure on Alan who is
still
>> That's a scary thing.
>> score here, but then you're three turns
away from winning if you do.
>> My own
>> Or if you don't. Like I feel like you
kind of have to score here if you're
Alan.
>> kind of have to lock in here and start
getting these points on the board
because you're starting to trail behind
and it's starting to hurt.
>> Oh, he's passing. So Alan's actually
playing a really patient play. You heard
Charmer talking earlier about the
importance of even points. There's no
Aspirant's climb in this game. It's
eight to win. So Alan's EQ has delayed
the turn timer he needs or the amount of
turns he needs to win the game. He can
only score a maximum of two in a turn.
Um unless he's on some crazy like Yasu
shenanigans which I highly doubt. Um so
that means that yeah, if you score two,
that's three, then another two, that's
five, another two, that's seven.
Okay, thank you for showing us the Yasuo
win rate. Again, I don't expect that
one.
But essentially it's going to be four
turns that Alan has to play minimum to
win this game. For Prismatism,
two turns minimum to win this game. That
is a vastly different clock.
>> Yeah, and we're going ahead and we're
scoring another point with this Annie
and Longsword. We're going to stack deck
real quick to see if we can
get a little sham sham.
>> Yeah.
>> Okay, sham sham was gotten.
>> Sham sham?
>> Sham sham was gotten. We did put two
cards on the bottom and we're going to
play another stack deck.
>> more.
>> We got to We got to see if we can get a
little sham sham.
>> What sham sham else?
>> More sham sham.
All right, we did again find that sham
sham. I feel like it's getting worn out
here.
>> Yeah, I wasn't going to do it again, but
that was mostly cuz I don't think I'm
quite nailing the inflection.
Um yeah, to
>> You got to hit it just right sometimes,
you know.
>> Um but
>> to it.
>> Yeah, exactly. Uh
Okay, so we got what we wanted, maybe,
and the Ferrous Warlord is going to come
out on the side of Prismatism is off.
>> I imagine Alan did it at that moment
because you're probably not going to get
another action window. Prismatism
doesn't need to score two this turn. You
only need one cuz then you can score two
on your next turn. So, you probably
weren't going to get another action
window, you might as well throw out both
stack decks in that action window. But
again, that's what if we count up the
number of total runes Alan Z Q has had
available at the end of Prismatism turns
throughout this game, it's probably like
10.
>> Yeah.
>> Cuz I think that was four and there were
two different turns with three. So,
Prismatism is just playing such a coy
game right now. He's just not letting
Alan do the Ezreal things where he's
like playing on your turn.
And Alan is just kind of like not having
efficient rune expenditures
turn over turn over turn and I think
that's really what we're feeling is
putting him in this hole.
>> Dang, so that sounds like it's hurting a
lot as this thousand tailed watcher
comes out here
>> to defend a point. I Allen's realizing
the situation they're in right now. It's
like kind of do or die. Minus three
might on the Annie puts it at two.
>> And we're going to move in that Ezreal
immediately to see if we can
clear up this board.
>> It's three attacking two, so
Prismaticism would have to use something
like another longsword, maybe a gust.
Nope, it's going
>> All right, he's going to clear it. So,
we're
we're doing stuff.
>> We're doing stuff.
>> stuff happen.
>> But I think at that point Annie had
accomplished her job. A three might unit
that doesn't do anything on board, yeah,
whatever. You know, you got the Ferris
Forerunner and probably things like
Rexai, Kaisa in hand. So, think Annie
and Prismaticism are feeling just fine
right now. You even have rebukes to deal
with this. Allen Z Q does have five
runes
to try and play defense with. And again,
we know that there's things like Arcane
Shift which paired with a thousand
tailed watchers kind of crazy cuz you
can pull back the thousand tailed
watcher, replay it
and then snipe three damage and then
thousand tailed will drop the might of
everything by three. That damage sticks.
So, then you can actually get them in
range to just kill stuff.
>> Mhm.
>> I see here and
all right.
>> So, currently seven runes for
Prismaticism to play with.
Raegan, how many times has he touched
his hair so far in this game alone? Have
you noticed?
>> through those luscious locks all day and
you know, I understand you're stressed,
but dang.
We're really we're really
>> process. It's part of the process, you
know.
>> helps him think.
>> Allen Z Q, it was also part of his
process many years ago and that's part
of the the current situation.
>> Did you used to do that as well?
>> Yes, I actually did. I did the the whole
Bieber flip thing.
>> Oh, wow.
>> just constantly. I kind of it kind of
became a tick.
>> Did it Did it hurt your neck? That looks
like it would hurt your
>> Well, it did but now I've been doing a
lot of neck work out. Thank you for
asking me about that actually. Um you
know, we were talking
>> And we got to get back to the game here.
Uh let's see. Prismatismism
is still thinking here.
Uh before we get on that tangent.
Uh
>> Well, now you're the one bringing us
back up.
>> Oh, my bad.
>> Have you checked my Twitter recently?
You'll have an idea.
>> y'all. We're thinking. We I I really got
to drag out that we're thinking here cuz
we cannot go down that road.
>> minutes. Like they are taking their time
on here but
>> have overtime here because we're in the
semifinals. They get to really bring out
the knowledge, the the the the the time
that they need to figure out these
plays.
>> looking at Allen right now just like
pondering the pondering of
Prismatismism.
>> Yep.
>> Who uh
Uh again, you know, this is a player
that likes to take his time, likes to
play a wide game of Rift Bound.
Um he actually has probably the least
number of units for this amount of
points that I've ever seen.
Usually he's still got like eight units
in base but he has been committing them
to the field cuz he realized that I I I
imagine at least he realized. I don't
speak for him of course but he had the
clock in his favor and Allen just wasn't
able to really get out there and
pressure points early on. Prismatismism,
even though he is, you know, three
points ahead, still was playing really
patient in the early game.
Transition to mid game went a little
harder on just putting out things like
the Rex Sai, had the flash to defend
them all, was always going out getting
the points when he can pull back the
units. Now has the potential winning
angle. Has he finally found it? He has
picked up a rune and he has exhausted
it.
>> Boom, we're cleaving, and it looks like
we're cleaving the Fer- Fer- I forgot
the name, Ferrari Runner.
>> And
we are going to swing in with nine
might. The smoke screen comes out from
Allen. Automatic response. We knew what
we wanted to do here.
>> Very, very big, as now it's cumulatively
negative one
on the Ferris Wheel Runner from the plus
three on the cleave and the minus four
from the smoke screen, plus one on the
Ravenbloom student means that it is now
10 defending against five attacking.
>> All right. Well, I think we have a
response for that. We're going to then
send in the
Do you read Mandarin?
>> I do. No, I don't. It's a picture. I
told you. It looks like Mandarin.
>> So,
we're going to send in the Ring Guard
here into the fight right here. See if
we can get anything else out from Allen.
>> It's going to be 10 might cuz Ring
Guard's three might with the soul, too.
Reaction, you can play it to a
battlefield you're attacking. It's
basically ambush before ambush as a
keyword was printed.
>> I can't wait for Ring Guard to be a
legend, man. It's going to be so much
fun.
>> I
That's the rule dump in here. I'm going
to find a way to
break this game. I I promise you.
But as of right now, it's about thinking
the game again, Allen. Actually, I don't
know who has priority right now or
it's focus for Prismaticism, but has he
passed priority or is it still in the
action window for Prismaticism?
>> I think it's for Prismaticism right now,
if I remember correctly, cuz we put the
Ring Guard down. We just have to decide
do we want to let this just like go?
>> Yeah. I mean, like a crashier is
advantageous for Prismaticism. You get
two mech tokens.
For Allen, I think the
advantage of that, too, is like you're
not really expecting anything
accelerated. Rex size the cheapest
accelerate in the any deck, and that's
four. It's It's three to play it, but
then an additional one in a
recycle to accelerate. There's only
three runes up on Prismatism's side
right now. So,
I don't think that that's likely. Maybe
it'd be like Ride the Wind. Cuz you
could like equip Longsword then Ride the
Wind over onto the the Ezreal. That
would probably be like the only angle
left for Prismatism to win the game. And
it's been a while since I've actually
gotten a peek at his hand.
>> Yeah.
>> Again, I think he's intentionally
playing around my goldfish memory.
I think it's through until Steve forgets
what I had.
>> The more you try to remember, the more
he doesn't want you to see. I low-key
want to see
>> Oh, okay. I guess it was Alan's turn.
>> It was Alan's
opportunity to respond and we've got the
Arcane Shift coming out and then the
Hard Bargain in response. And then
another Cleave to make it this much
harder for Alan
to make this resolve in his favor.
So, instead of that minus one on the
Rengar, instead we're going to have a
plus five.
>> Wow.
>> Or the minus one on the
runner.
Plus five on the Rengar.
>> Yeah, cuz you got the plus two from the
assault. Now another Cleave coming in
here. So, that's eight plus four and
that's the handshake. Alan's EQ concedes
it. Prismatism for the first time ever
is making it to a regional finals.
>> Oh my gosh, he did it. Annie is going on
another run here in the finals. We're
going to have Annie versus Draven.
>> It's been a long time since we've seen
Annie have the opportunity to take the
finals, to take the win. It's chaos and
fury match up in the finals. Two very
different legends,
two very similar color palettes, and two
very explosive potential match-ups here.
Prismatcisim, he took his time, but he
found the right angle to go in there. It
was just make the Rengar bigger. Just
cleave on him, and that's going to be
enough.
>> Yes, and the passing of the priority
there, like he knew, like okay, I still
have these cards in hand. I can probably
still hard bargain if he does come back
with something. Oh my gosh, I'm so
excited!
>> That was it. Hey, all the hair pulling,
all the thinking, it was worth it. It
got him the win, okay? That's what
matters. Prismatcisim, he had tops three
times. Never made it to a finals. Top
four was the furthest he'd made it. So,
this is a big moment for this player,
making it the furthest you've ever done
in a regional after so many consistent
performances,
and now could win the whole thing. But,
let's hear from the player himself ahead
of the finals appearance.
>> Could win the whole thing himself,
indeed. That's right, I have our second
finalist now locked in here. Kyle,
Prismatcisim,
how does it feel to be now into the
finals? You've gotten so many top cuts,
and here you are finally the last game,
the last match that you have to win to
take home that crown. How are you
feeling?
>> A bit tired. And it's it's been a grind,
like the match against Colin, match
against Alan. They've been very tough
matches, right down to the wire every
time.
Uh, I mean, the Draven match-up I think
is pretty good for me.
>> I think we can all kind of agree to
that. You obviously have been practicing
for the Draven match-up, you and of
course your friend who you just had to
eliminate from the tournament, Alan Z Q.
Great friend, great player, if not maybe
the two best Rift Bound players in the
world right now playing against each
other in top four. You must have
channeled some of that energy from him.
As you know, I saw you channeling some
of that granola bar in the middle of
that match. So, are you energized?
You're You've done your push-ups. You've
gotten some food. You've gotten some
water in you. I don't I genuinely have
to ask you, do you think you can maybe
even be more prepared for this upcoming
match?
>> I could probably be a little bit. I'll
have to see what his deck list is.
Haven't Haven't had anyone to scout it
when he was playing his other matches.
That'd be useful, but And I've got the
the buff beating the Wally regional
winner and Alan regional winner. So,
I've got a lot of momentum going for me.
>> Yes, you do. Not even just that, you're
so sharp so sharp from all these
tournaments. Just in Leo last weekend,
of course, with that top four still
piloting the Annie, getting that best
of. And of course, we saw that second
one that you've already locked in on the
table, of course, sitting across from
the best of Ezreal.
I'll be honest, Prismatism, I don't know
what else to really ask you because I
just can't wait to get to this finals
match. So, the only thing I really want
you to talk about is the kind of work
and preparation, once again, that's you
and your playtest team has really done
getting to this point. It I'm just big
on the storylines that come with these
players like you that work so hard
training for a moment like this, and it
pays off. It's exactly what you've
worked for, and here you have the chance
to prove it that you could be one of the
best Riftbound players, not just here in
Atlanta, but in the whole world.
>> I mean, just it all pays off. You got to
be tough on yourself, though. You can't
tolerate any mistakes. You got to be
able to look back at every game, try to
find something to improve.
It's tough.
>> Tough it's going to be because we've got
Coco Lopez on the other side for this
finals match. Don't go anywhere because
we've got an incredible finals here at
the regional qualifier in Atlanta, but
we're going to send it back.
>> We're going to finals.
>> to finals, and I got to say
that was some really funny stark
difference in energy between Coco and
Prismatism.
>> Yes.
>> Coco was like, "Yeah, that was awesome.
I'm feeling good. I'm feeling ready. You
know, shout out the team." Prismatism's
a
the those were long games. I'm even
going back to the quarterfinals. Like
game two, we broke it down at the
prompter. And like he almost lost game
two. He almost got two-o'ed in the
quarters.
>> Yeah.
>> He had to grind his way through two
really long series to make it here. I
think that these are two very different
experiences these players have had in
their uh top eight run to this finals.
>> Undoubtedly.
And I mean, even with him, we saw that
the games were also like very close.
Like they turned
>> Except for game three in in this one.
But yeah, all the others, yeah.
>> yes, previously uh the games were really
close. He had to think through these
strategies, think through these uh
match-ups to really uh claw his way to
the finals. First time here. And
honestly, I think he can do it. He's
shown that he has the mental fortitude.
But not only that, he's kind of shown
that he has the
the brain capacity to think through all
of these avenues, all of these like uh
decision trees to get that win.
>> I'm telling you, uh topping top eight at
a single regional is an impressive feat.
Topping three?
>> Three is crazy.
>> Beating Alanzq who's topped four on your
way to the finals, also crazy. Beating
two other regional winners, crazy. Like
Prismatism's got the narrative buff, I
think right now.
>> Absolutely.
>> do a lot of push-ups. Uh I'm hearing I'm
hearing also that uh we have one of our
analysts standing by with a breakdown of
some of the key moments in that last
game. So, let's hear from them.
Maybe.
>> Maybe. What if yes?
>> Thank you very much. You have not one,
but two
>> I'm cool.
>> I'm an analyst. You're an analyst.
>> I don't know about me, but uh
>> I don't know about that.
>> We've had some incredible games uh
pretty much all weekend long. And uh
this seems to be a theme with
Prismaticism games. Uh they're really
fun to watch. They often go to three.
They can be a little lengthy and they
usually involve some extremely thin
margins to get over the finish line,
which is kind of the thing with this
Annie deck, right? Like you have a lot
of play, but again, things aren't
freezing. You don't get to do a lot of,
you know, overbearingly powerful things.
You just have to get there by enough.
>> Absolutely. And the other thing that
we're noticing is that you need those
thin margins when you're against
top-tier competition like Collin the
previous round, Allen this round. These
are two teammates. They know each
other's lines and so I believe when
we're taking a look at this clip, we're
going to see one of the ones that is
worth highlighting. You're going to see
Prismaticism lead off with a cleave
before going into the battlefield. I
think a lot of players might consider
playing this as the first priority of
the showdown, but by playing it first,
one of the things that Prismaticism is
potentially playing around is something
like a hard bargain after you've
committed the unit to the battlefield.
So this was a very patient heads-up play
for Prismaticism to make.
>> already know that like you're you're
losing the might battle, so you're going
to have to buff the Forerunner, which is
the unit spoiler that's going to get
cleaved. We can play the clip and show
you kind of how this plays out and we're
going to let this roll for quite a
while. There's a lot to break down. It's
a pretty complex line, but again, we
start things off giving Assault Three to
the Forerunner, charging on in and now
it's at nine might. So that's beating
the actually that's looking to trade
with the uh the Y up nine that's on
there and Allen doesn't like the idea of
a trade, so a smoke screen is going to
basically make that Forerunner a five.
So now it's five to nine. So far so good
for Allen's upkeep.
>> Yeah, so far so good. However, there's
this cool card that Prismaticism has
introduced to these Annie lists. Uh it
is none other than a Rengar, the
aggressive kitty and it's going to be
coming down in just a moment for the
mere cost of three energy and one fury
rune and that's going to be another plus
five attacking on the site.
>> five is ridiculous. Like as far as
combatrix go, like I mean three energy
is quite a lot to play, but this is also
a unit you have to keep later once the
combatrix is done. So plus five is going
to make it yet another unfair fight. And
remember, this room student also ticking
up this entire time potentially for
every spell that Allen can play. So, got
to be a little bit careful here. And uh
I don't know exactly how calculated the
players have gone through. I imagine
given how much thinking Chris has been
doing uh during this game, they probably
thought through all these lines. But
Allen, of course, is thinking about all
this, too. And really, the goal here is
just to break this cuz Ezreal down here
looking kind of lonely. And at six
points, Prismaticism can potentially win
this game as long as he kind of win this
battlefield cuz it might not seem like
it yet, but Chris has also left some
things behind, right?
>> Yes.
>> to win in this scenario.
>> Absolutely. Knowing that you need the
double conquer, you want to get Allen to
overcommit the resources and still punch
through on the Zaun Wards because as
Pastry pointed out, the Ezreal here only
has three might. A merchant plus the
longsword that was not equipped to the
Forerunner in favor of the cleave means
that that can be attached and can for
sure conquer that if you can get Allen
to expend the resources. Allen does
still have three wounds up at this
point, and it might not seem like
there's a lot of things to play around,
but the presence of this Ezreal does
mean there are more options when you
factor in the alternative costs of
repeat.
>> And we can fast forward it a little bit
as well cuz Allen is thinking over here
before kind of committing his final
spell. And uh from memory, it is an
Arcane Shift. And I'm going to go with
fast forward the clip again. Let's get
Allen to, you know, get through the
thinking time. We have the uh the
ability to to move it on through just a
little bit more here as Allen does
eventually Arcane Shift. And
unfortunately, that does not go to plan.
Arcane Shift deal three and the Hard
Bargain. I think
>> kind of in the card of the weekend.
Really stop
>> things. And as you already mentioned,
there's everything left here at the end
of it all. Prismaticism, again, with
just about every resource they had
available was able to clutch this game
and go through to the final.
>> Absolutely. So, the Hard Bargain coming
through earlier in this game,
Prismaticism had a flash that was denied
by a Hard Bargain on Allen's side. So, a
little bit of sweet justice to have his
go off. Not only does that deny the
shift, which could have done a number of
things, could have done damage to a unit
there, but also could have potentially
replayed the Watcher to give the
minuses. The other thing that happens
there is with the one energy left up
because I believe they were tied because
of the spells played and Raven Bloom
ticking up the second cleave got over
the top. So it was a conquer there. Then
the win is on the board. You see the
handshake and prismacism locks his spot
in the finals.
>> Well, it's one more match up left for
prismacism up against cockaloris. This
is going to be one hell of a final. So
let's go back and prep for that.
>> Ugh, I love it, man.
>> Yeah. I love to see it.
>> big play, big game three. Just kind of
shutting out Alan Z Q right there. So
yeah, that's going to be the match up
Annie versus Draven in the finals, Coco
versus prismacismism.
And uh that means that there's one other
thing that we got to do for some table
setting, Reagan.
>> I think we need to take a peek see at
the best ofs from this weekend.
>> Who's walking away with the metal?
>> Oh my gosh, we've got the civir swag
yolo 420. Yeah, that is a deserving best
of name.
>> Rockal ho.
>> Oh okay, rockal.
>> yeah, what was the ATL?
>> ATL. We got rockal
ho.
>> Yeah, it it kind of works.
Demon for with a Lucian 10 two and one
and Dark Crater as Jax Grandmaster at
Arms nine three and one. Wow, they all
have the exact same if you look at the
far right, the exact same profile and
ears.
>> I love
the ears and haircut. The ears and the
haircut. But uh
I I'm absolutely happy with this uh
lineup here. Honestly, just from the
usernames. But congratulations to these
players. They played their tails off
today to secure these best of cards.
>> Walking away with the metal and we
actually had opportunity to chat with
all of them about their experience. So
let's hear from them ahead of our grand
finals.
>> I'm joined here by the prestigious Ali.
You just took home now the best of
Sivir, and you've been playing this
legend now for a little bit, and you're
finally taking home this prize that
you've been working so hard for. How
does it feel?
>> It feels it feels amazing after
playing Aurora with Misfortune and Sivir
for set one and two, take home the
big big prizes feels amazing.
It paid off, so super exciting and
happy.
>> It definitely did pay off. We've been
watching your games all weekend, at
least I've been keeping an eye on you
cuz, you know, like to you like to
follow the players, you know, that are
really good at this game. But, my next
question I want to ask, just one last
thing.
>> Sure.
>> Do you plan on still sticking with the
Aurora game plan with Unleashed on the
horizon, or do we maybe pivot to
something new?
>> I'm not pivoting. Uh I've been Aurora
since almost day one, and it it's just
better in in set three in Unleashed, so
there's no way, no. I'm so excited for
Baron, for Vilemaw, for
Elder Dragon, and then even
also the
Rift Herald, it's also great. I'm not
sure which version I'm playing yet, but
I'm super pumped for Aurora for set
three.
>> Awesome. Well, thank you so much for
your time. Congratulations once again,
and we hope to see you at the next one
as well.
>> Thank you.
>> I'm joined here with actually one of my
favorite players because I also love
playing Azir, the best of Azir for the
third time now, Rocklow. How's it feel
to take home a third trophy?
>> It feels great. I feel like it even
feels better than the first one
because like
reinsurance is like
it's like the best, like and I proved
myself because
last week, I think I got like second or
third best of, and I couldn't be like
the number one um
so coming over to Atlanta and showing
who the best is was really really
important for me.
>> No, I I I again, it's such an amazing
prize, and again, like you said, you've
proved yourself to not only win it one
time, but two times, and now a third
time. So, I've got to ask, with this
being the last Spirit Forge season one,
of course, you can still win the best of
Azir at the next regionals, but are you
going to maybe play something new, or
are we going to keep running it back on
Azir?
>> So, one thing is I'm the emperor on
Azir, and no one will stop me.
>> What a great answer. Thanks so much,
Rocco. Congratulations.
>> Thank you.
>> I'm joined here with the best of Lucian
winner, Damon. How does it feel to take
home such a coveted prize after a
rigorous competition? Literally, Samdy
Sherman, the Las Vegas winner, was
playing the same legend as you.
>> Yeah, honestly, it feels great. Uh I
want to say thank you to Sam. He
actually built the list and gave it to
me, and so he helped me out. Really
helped me out a lot with uh you know,
the ropes of learning Lucian. I picked
it up a few days ago. Knew I didn't want
to play Draven, wanted to play something
else, and it's been a pleasure, and it's
been a ton of fun.
>> Well, so not only that, and you had a
good time, this kind of sums up the end
of the Spirit Forge season. Are you
going to continue to maybe aim for
another Lucian in the future, or maybe a
new legend on the horizon?
>> I'm a jungler, heart to heart, so I
already know what I'm playing for
Unleashed. I'm going to be a metal card
hunting Kha'Zix, one of my favorite
champions, one of my main, so I'll be
there in Vancouver.
>> I love it. I can't wait to see your
performance on Kha'Zix, and I can't wait
to see that deck list as well.
Congratulations once again, Damon.
Um hope to see you the next one.
I'm here, and I'm joined with the best
of Jax, the Jimbo in Limbo. Best name,
by the way, that I've seen today. I got
to ask you, how do you feel because Jax
kind of on a lot of people's radars
because he did top eight in Vegas at the
regional qualifiers. So, how's it feel
to have this trophy?
>> It feels pretty good. Uh I definitely
people were doubting because of the
Irelia changes. Yeah. Irelia got hit. Uh
you know, the Flicker got hit. You can't
brutalize or re-equip. So, everyone was
like, "Oh, man,
it sucks. You can't You can't You can't
do this anymore." But, I was like, "Oh,
man, I was already off that." So, I was
feeling confident going into it. Uh
playing into a lot of like local games.
Like, I was doing well in a lot of
matchups. So, yeah, I was I was just
really glad that I was able to perform.
And I think even like uh the games that
I lost, like, I feel like I had a a
fighting chance. So, uh yeah, I was I
was just rooting for the underdog, you
know?
>> I mean, that's exactly it. You came into
day two seven in one, and you only ended
the day with four losses with a champion
that a lot of people are, I think,
undervaluing. Great performance. Same
colors as Master Yi. So, like, what can
we do? But, I got to ask you, are you
going to stick with the Grand Master, or
are we going to try something new in
Unleashed?
>> Uh I don't know. Honestly, I've been
I've been so laser-focused on set two
for this tourney that I haven't really
thought about any uh set three
champions. So, yeah, I I'm just going to
see what what comes out. I don't think
there was too much that they
uh that they
uh announced that is really Jack
support. So, I'm not married to it, you
know? But, you know, hey, if the card If
it's right, you know? Cuz Jack is super
fun.
>> Yes.
>> I love playing Jacks. And yeah, just the
whole like weapon switching mechanic is
so much fun to like and no one ever sees
it coming. So, yeah, I playing Also,
just playing like off-meta
>> Yeah.
>> is like is so rewarding. Cuz set one, I
played only Kai'Sa. And the worst part
about that was just playing into all the
mirrors. Everyone's playing Kai'Sa. I'm
like,
"Uh man, I I I want to try something
different." And then set two came out
like the Irelia matchup sucks. Uh so, I
played So, I was like, "Okay, I got I I
swapped over to Jacks." And, you know,
honestly, I think I I beat every Irelia
here. So,
>> That I mean, you can't ask for much
more. Like you said, it really just
shows the skill expression that you can
put on a champion. And then not just
that, still have to show up and compete
against one of the most popular decks in
the room. Jimbo and Limbo, congrats on
your trophy, and we hope to see you at
the next one. TBD on the legend, though.
>> Better remember.
>> Hello and a welcome to the finals of
regional qualifier Atlanta. My name is
Julian Petrescu I'm joined by Derek
Chama Oswell. That's the first time I'm
doing that name. Natty, how did I do?
>> Great actually. You didn't mispronounce
a thing. You got my full government
name.
>> Probably not true.
>> And I appreciate it.
>> Let's go.
>> Uh I am very excited as well and we're
going to get our yelling out of the way
now because as the venue gets
smaller and smaller, at some point we're
going to have to be a little bit
quieter. We're going to keep the
excitement up. We're going to keep the
energy up, but we're going to have to
watch what we're saying at times because
we have a finals coming our way just
around the corner between two amazing
players.
>> Yeah, it's a two first time finalists
here. So have a look at our bracket to
see how we got here in our round of
eight. Starting in the quarterfinals,
Cocoa Lopez defeated Stardust in the
Draven mirror took out Harikaze on
Aurelia two to one and both those
matchups land in our finals. Whereas on
the bottom side, Prismaticism took out
Colin who is our best of set and top
four competitor at RQ Las Vegas then
took out Teeman Allen ZQ in a very close
two to one and now it lands in the
finals. It is the same domains but
different legends and we're going to see
is which actually which of these legends
is going to win for the second time at a
regional qualifier. Of course Draven won
the last one here in North America in
the hands of Sam Sherman and won the
first one in North America for Annie in
the hands of Dual who is Prismaticism
took out on Annie when he was on Draven.
>> That's right and not only are we going
to have our first ever
double legend but we're going to have a
first time winner because as you had
pointed out neither of the players has
made a finals in the past though they
are decorated card game players.
Prismaticism in particular has continued
to get better with every run. I I it was
a day two performance in Houston
followed by a top eight, followed by a
top eight, followed by a top four, and
now finally cracking into the final. So,
getting slowly better every time.
>> I mean, it Look, the math checks out.
Divides by two every single time they
seemingly play a tournament. Would maybe
like to do it one more time and not have
to go to yet another regional qualifier
to top eight to get that first win. And
we've seen Pres Pres kind of around the
hall in between rounds. Again, games
have been very long. Series are
definitely going to uh an hour and a
half in cases when they're going the
distance of players in these untimed
rounds. Really thinking through their
plays with such high stakes. And
Cosmeticism, a very accomplished player.
I think uh widely regarded as one of the
best reform players in the world, but is
very hungry to pick up this W.
>> Absolutely. And we would be remiss if we
didn't mention the other player in this
finals, which is of course Coco Lopez.
Coco came in as the number one seed,
right? Has been very impressive so far
throughout the top eight bracket. Said
specifically during interviews earlier,
this was not an event where they just
wanted to be the best of Draven, for
example. They wanted to win the event,
and they were very excited that they got
the number one seed simply because they
knew that they were going to be the
player going first in each of these
matchups.
>> Yeah, being first definitely matters a
lot here. And as you can see, this is
the run. And fun fact, was paired
against his finals opponent in round 13,
but they did not play. They drew into
top eight, which makes a lot of sense.
Want to make sure you get in. No need to
play it out and have silly things
happen. But a curious run here. Uh
Musty, Yiarelia, Draven. Lots of Dravens
actually really taking out a number of
this champion. Ezreal actually uh drew
Alanzq. That's where the draw came from,
in Alanzq's undefeated day one record.
And really just playing actually kind of
the top meta game. Again, putting in the
early rounds, you can run into some a
wider variety of decks, but Darius is
really the only one there sticking out
as something that's a bit unusual as far
as the expected meta game goes. And
funnily enough, has not played any yet.
>> Right, not officially anyway because of
the draw to get into the top eight. But
again, worth noting Coco has not dropped
a set yet. We did have one draw against
Allen who is a fantastic player. It was
also Allen's only non-win on day one as
you had pointed out. Made it to the top
four before falling to Prismatism, but I
think that this is going to be a very
skill-intensive
match-up here.
>> I got to ask you.
>> Yep.
>> Who are you going to pick to win it?
>> Well, I just heard that the overall win
rates for these legends Draven 52% here
in Atlanta. Pretty good. Actually, not
as high as I might think given the
representation of the deck, but I guess
with high numbers perhaps comes maybe a
flatter overall win rate. That does add
up a little bit here. Annie's 48.
So, these are arguably, even though
they're not the most represented decks,
these might be the two best decks in the
format because those win rates are
awfully high given how wide this field
is. So, with all that considered
Draven certainly the best deck and has
won in the all certainly, yeah, I think
it's fair to say the best deck. Although
some might say Aurelion even though
they're certainly the most represented
decks.
And last time we were in North America
for Regional Qualifiers, Draven did win
and it looked really good. And it was
also mid-range Draven by the way. This
is back when Miracle Draven was also
around. That's obviously not an
archetype that really exists anymore
after the bans. And the mid-range looks
like the clear best deck in the format
despite how powerful Miracle could be.
So, all this to say that I think
Prismatism's going to win.
Just because both the player and the
deck, I think if Ferris Forerunner is
the card we've been yapping on about all
weekend long,
Doa and Alanzq already spoiled it for us
in their round after the interview. He's
playing the best Ferris Forerunner deck.
>> Yeah, it certainly seems that way
because we've seen time and time again
where the play pattern has been, you
know, two drop and then likely either a
pair of two drops or something else on
four and then into Ferris Forerunner on
a battlefield.
>> Yeah, with that we're going to go down
to the feature match to add a full one
final time this weekend. It is time for
a grand finals of Regional Qualifiers
Atlantic. These players have well and
truly already qualified for this
regional. They've already won their best
deals for their respective legends.
There's just one last thing to do, and
that's hand out those prizes there.
Battle Room King Playmate, beautiful
Battle Room King card, and of course,
the thing that everybody really wants
for themselves, a nice shiny trophy.
>> You know, I will admit that there are
two things that make me really excited
when I'm in any sort of competition. It
is a trophy or a novelty oversized
check.
I am a sucker for those. If I ever win
either of them and I can't fit it in my
flight home, I would have mail it home.
I just love novelty oversized checks and
shiny trophies. But, uh these players,
there's something that I want to point
out going into this. It will be
something to watch because during the
winner interview, I think Prismatism
touched on something that is often
overlooked in events like this.
He's tired. Yep, it's been a long
weekend after 15 rounds of Riftbound.
And now they still have to play for the
highest stakes of both of their
Riftbound careers.
>> Yep, we had eight rounds of Swiss
yesterday that finished at 10:00 p.m.
We're starting game one, and what time
is it? It's 10:00 p.m. local time, Tom.
We are in for a long one, but also a
good one here. The finals are kicking
off with Challenger TCD's Coco Lopez off
with a Gem Gemma.
>> And we're going to have Zon Warrens on
one side, Seed of Power on the other.
Again, Coco being the first seed had the
option, chose to go first.
>> Good choice.
>> It is a great choice. Meanwhile, the
other side, Prismatism here, opens with
a stacked deck.
Possibly trying to find a hopeful
because that's traditionally the most
powerful opener you can have when you're
going second is to trigger that Legion
off of a stacked deck.
>> Yep, always nice to find yourself a a
two-drop to play in this spot when you
are going second, and stacked deck does
help you do that. And of course, even
better if it's a super-powered one, and
it is just Traveling Merchant, still
pretty good. And it does reawaken
re-ready those runes. Don't worry, did
manage to actually pay cost for the
merchant uh and his legend ability.
Unfortunately, it doesn't work twice
despite the two best of Annie sitting in
in  near the legend zone for Pris
Mat, but Jim Jam are going to roll on
over to this to the zone warrens get
some of that filtering going and get the
first point on the board as uh Kook I
assume he's going up for a teammate cuz
perhaps forgot something that he needs.
I don't think it's something uh
game urgent we can say, but perhaps a
trinket of sorts
to watch over this as Kaisa survivor
going to be the follow up play here.
>> Yeah, I suspect it's probably a notepad
or something for keeping track of the
score because you see that die there
instead. He did call for it when he went
to the battlefield. I like the conquer
of zone warrens first as opposed to the
seed of power because it means you're
going to have to expend additional
resources if you want to send the
merchant there and get a double trigger.
>> You said it's a long day.
Did we forget to trigger zone warrens
again?
Is that the second time I caught that on
camera? Am I the zone warrens person?
I'm the zone warrens person.
>> I am the zone police force. I didn't
even know they had that in zone.
>> It's true. It's just we have Lola's
underground.
>> But you apparently are it.
>> All right, well accelerated Kaisa
survivor looking a little bit better in
this situation. Going to move over also
conquer the warrens get a point get a
discard get a draw and get a draw from
Kaisa survivor as well for conquering as
traveling merchant also going to do a
bit more filtering and another card or
in fact basically the same turn on
either side just stitching a few
different effects together here.
>> Yeah, this is actually beautiful for
prismaticism because of ordering you can
have that draw on the Kaisa first then
the warrens trigger so you have more
options. On the other side you have of
course the merchant and the seed of
power uh
similar openers for both players started
with a two drop into a Kaisa.
Prismaticism gets a little bit of an
advantage because of the extra rune of
going second so it was able to
accelerate that Kaisa, but Kook now
sends his own over to the seed of power.
>> And I really like this. I was going to
say flash is one of those things that is
just such a nice spell. It is really the
marquee spell of this deck. Makes sense
it was in the Annie proving grounds
deck. And uh Prismaticism is piloting
Annie. Not just because you can protect
the merchant, but you can just take both
units back. And you definitely want to
protect this Kai'Sa.
>> Yeah, and not only do you protect your
units, but the merchant is going to
trigger again. So, we saw that discard
of the hard bargains to draw yet another
card. And the sheer number of cards that
Prismaticism has already seen this early
in the game is wild. Because of both
Zaun warrants, seed of power, and the
merchant, and the Kai'Sa.
>> five cards already in the trash. Shame
uh he's not playing Ross as like the
last time he was here in a North
American regional qualifier cuz uh it
would be discounted in Ahri at this rate
as the uh the fight for Kai'Sa the fight
for Kai'Sa survival continues.
Prism protects their first one, and Coco
Lopez lining things up. As you
mentioned, the champion of Al Swiss, the
first seed in this top eight. It is
actually first versus second, I just
noticed. Two very dominant players
throughout the uh regular rounds, and
now meeting in the finals. Not something
that happens all that often, to be
honest, in card game tournaments. But uh
perhaps a fitting end to this regional
qualifier.
>> Yeah, this is again almost like it was
written from a script. You have the
number one versus the number two. They
met at the end of Swiss, but chose to
intentionally draw to secure the top
eight. So, it's their first official
face-off. Neither one has won. They both
have very similar, yet very different
stories. Prismaticism decorated, but has
not won the big one. Coco, this is his
first shot at winning anything because
of uh first appearance in the top eight.
And so, both want to kind of either
start their legacy off, or cement theirs
as the best player in the world.
>> on a team that is cooking at Rift Runes
events, for what it's worth. Collin also
on Challenger TCG. Uh made their second
top cut on set this weekend after uh top
four in Las Vegas. So, uh certainly a
team that seems to know what they're
doing when it comes to Riven, but
traveling merchant going to roll on in
it's two points a piece, but perhaps not
for too much longer as Ferris forerunner
was also the reinforced at the seat of
power. We saw this time and time again
on Prized side and when you were going
first and get to six runes before the
for your opponent, you get to be the one
to put the first forerunner down which
also also feels pretty good.
>> Yeah, I was going to mention that
again
Dewali said earlier in the weekend
Ferris forerunner is potentially the
best unit in the game and they thought
that prismatism had the best forerunner
deck overall, but here we're seeing Coco
Lopez deploy one first because of again
having that first shot at six runes. I
like the deploy as a reinforced two
where the Kaiza is because it's going to
make it that much more difficult to get
enough might on that site to deal with
either. However, there is an answer to
that in the form of rebuke which just so
happens to be the only card played more
often than for a Ferris forerunner on
the weekend.
>> There we go. Rebuke Wong sword and swing
on in is going to be the the the reason
Prized's Kaiza wins the combat over on
the seat of power. Actually should draw
a card as well thanks to the traveling
merchant also getting points and I was
going to say the way that we've seen
prismatism play this match, but we've
seen him play Draven on stream at least
once before this event. It seems to be
get ahead and stay ahead, right? As soon
as Annie grabs the tempo lead and grabs
the
the race in points, it does seem to be
that Prized is able to find a way to
keep it cuz Annie's just a little bit
faster than Draven who might be arguably
a little bit more powerful.
>> And the final play for that turn for
prismatism was developing that Noxus
hopeful in the base and then readying
the two runes once again because of the
Annie legend ability. So right now
prismatism has a strong tempo lead, has
more board presence, has more points.
However, Coco Lopez does have more
runes. There's been a lot of recycling
on prismatism side. That might open an
opportunity for Coco to develop more per
turn and kind of take a development turn
as we've talked about and then use that
to try to catch up. This Rex Sai is a
great way to do that because it has
accelerate and we see that accelerate
cost paid for followed by a cleave.
>> Yeah, it doesn't even need to
take a turn off to develop. Can actually
just go right now thanks to the
accelerate that that Rex Sai Breaker has
a card that we've heard quite a number
of hours ago at this point sold out at
all the dealers here in the venue. So a
very popular card indeed and going to
roll on over try and fight but there's
the flash once again always two runes
available here for Prismaticism. Is
there a hard bargain on the other side
though? That's the question cuz that is
one of the ways you can stop this very
powerful engine and there it is
countering that flash and finally
killing off the Kaisa.
>> Yeah, that is a beautiful answer on the
side of Coco Lopez for the flash. The
first one was successful. This second
one not so much. Not only would that
have saved the Kaisa but likely also
targeting the merchant which would have
resulted in yet another trigger on that
spot as well and as you have pointed out
Prismaticism's trash is full. No, this
is not a miracle deck. There's no Rossas
but because of the unit and battlefield
combination of this game one
Prismaticism has just been rifling
through this deck.
>> So if one hidden card here one of the
one of the things that I guess is good
is that Prismaticism is still ahead in
points and is still on on pace to win by
two if they can score yet another time
and that means getting through this
hidden card and this Rex Sai
in the top battlefield and let's see the
power which if you do get by the way
will actually mean assuming the
traveling merchant stays put where it is
on the zone one you get to draw a card
as well. So a lot of value to be gained
from a few different axes here at this
point in the game but you can see kind
of the first deep think really beginning
because Prismaticism would love to move
that Hopeful with the Longsword and try
and conquer and right now six six might
to only the three that Rex Sai has on
defense would be pretty good but of
course you must contend with what is
that hidden card? Is it a Tidecaller?
That would be not quite a trade
actually, but it could be a switcheroo
and that certainly would be a good thing
for Cocoa Lopez.
>> Absolutely.
The switcheroo has been fantastic and
players have uh had to play around it
all weekend long. We've seen it
absolutely just blow out certain turns.
We've seen it result in victories. Uh
you have to respect it.
So, I think we are still going to see
Prismatism say, "Listen, I suspect
that's a switcheroo, BUT I HAVE NO
ANSWER."
>> OH! AND THE ANSWER IS A kitty named
Rengar.
>> Rengar doing so much work for Prismatism
in this top eight. I was about to regale
you with the tale of the fact that
switcheroo actually won Sandy Shuriman
the last regional qualifier in North
America, but Rengar might be the talk of
the town now. Five might on offense
thanks to Assault 2. Merchant going to
move back, draw another card. See the
power draws a card. The card filter is
massive. Ferris Forerunner is hitting
the bin. That is a show of intent from
Prismatism.
>> Yeah, that's saying one, I'm trying to
win in the short term, but also I don't
expect this game to go to a position
where I have six runes available.
Prismatism, a lot of recycling early on,
trading those runes for those point
gains. Again, Cocoa Lopez has a lot more
runes available, but less board
presence. Uh it's a similar position to
what Cocoa was in just a moment ago and
Prismatism, uh like you said, is saying,
"Hey, I don't intend for this to be
relevant anymore."
>> Yep, Annie can certainly play throughout
tempo Draven in sports like this and
that's exactly what Prismatism has done.
That Annie legend ability means you can
develop and still leave things available
to interact and try and keep the pace up
on your opponent. So, Stacked Deck is
going to go digging for answers here for
our Draven player who's currently
trailing three points and as it stands,
between the conquer of the Traveling
Merchant that could happen on the other
turn and down the bottom side for his
own warrants and the hold currently
being threatened by Rengar and Draven's
overzealous fan, Prismatism is set to
win next turn. So, what can Draven do
about it?
>> Yeah, Coco has to have an answer for at
a minimum the stuff on the seat of
power. Likely would like to be able to
either have an answer as well for a move
into the zone Warren's or maybe
something to target the backline, but
the reality is the stacked deck opener
says I'm likely searching for an answer.
I was just about to highlight falling
star is probably the desired target.
>> That one is very very good. Currently
also not uh
can't get got by hardball. Either still
has four wins available and in fact
can't even be repeated. And most
importantly, I don't believe this can be
flashed. So, uh falling star is going to
take out two leave the over zealous fan
on the battlefield Ty Turner over
zealous fan deploy to is going to give
prismaticism point number seven. A flash
would win here.
If I were if I
>> Well, so would a Kaisa the Ty Turner
>> And so would Ty Turner.
>> Uh well do it as well. I was going to
say the red Rex I would have done it.
So, there were a lot of outs there for
prismaticism to close that out, but uh I
think Coco should be commended for
recognizing the falling star needed to
be the play in that situation. Play the
stack deck, get the information, and
just hope that prismaticism bricks. Uh
again, you got to play the air outs even
if you think they have it go through the
motions especially in the finals.
>> the thing when Annie grabs tempo this
these are the kind of games you can
have. I'll remind you we have watched a
lot of rift bound so far in the top
eight and overall this weekend. And uh
we've had a lot of three game sets. In
fact, I think the only one that didn't
go was one of the quarterfinals. Uh I
believe uh Aurelia
may have won her match up 2-0. But uh
we've had a lot of prismaticism sets go
to 90 minutes. That game one finished in
just above 10.
>> Well, both of these players I'm sure
have a lot of reps on this particular
match up. Coco very clearly came into
this event with the intent to win. Was
playing Draven felt it was the best deck
in the format. Did likely expect to at
least see some form of Annie. Uh again,
it has performed pretty well here in
North America. You expect players like
prismaticism to show up on on the other
end of the spectrum. You know that
Prismaticism has put in the reps against
Draven. So, be both of these players, I
think, are okay with moving through this
a little bit faster in terms of pacing,
whereas the previous Prismaticism sets
you had a banger against Collin, which
is probably not as familiar of a
match-up because it sat, and then you
also had against your literal teammates.
So, you know every move. And so, you got
to slow it down.
>> very grindy match-up against Alanzq's
Ezreal, of course. Prismaticism deep
breath to start game number two.
Reminder, Koko Lopez was on the play
that game as well. That is one of the
benefits of being the first seed. So,
serve broken, in a manner of speaking,
Prismaticism going to mulligan two. Koko
seems to like the hand right now.
>> And this time around for the
battlefields, Zaun Warwicks back again,
this time deployed from Prismaticism.
Koko Lopez opts for Targon's Peak. So,
only one of these battlefields will draw
cards. We probably won't see the rifling
we saw in game one, but still very
relevant effects we have seen in other
matches Prismaticism utilize Targon's
Peak to pair with the any legend ability
and just ready four runes.
>> Yeah, O Trundle is so good in any cuz
again, lots of things have bugging can
be Okay, never mind. We'll talk about
that later cuz Kai'Sa Survival is a very
good follow-up here, and I like what
Koko Lopez is doing here. Saying again,
a game of twos is really what we're
playing in this back-and-forth kind of
tempo-y match-up where we want to grab
points appropriately.
Brushing off the conqueror right now
doesn't really accomplish much. I guess
Targon's Peak is maybe an attractive
place to go to be able to ready two
runes, but just putting this Kai'Sa
developing and saying, "Go ahead. I'll
take the two points next turn. I don't
need to take one right now."
>> Yeah, I like the patience from Koko.
I think this also might have just been a
check for is Prismaticism really on a
slow start or are they trying to bait me
with something like a Rengar with the
three runes up? And of course, now we
see See Rengar just naturally developed,
Prismaticism recognizing I want to be in
a position to uh potentially counter
attack after Coco goes into the
battlefields this turn.
>> Yeah, Ringard significantly better on
offense versus defense, although can be
utilized uh in both situations. And
Kaisa would really love to go just about
anywhere where she can get a conquer.
So, on Warren's feels like a pretty good
one, gets a draw, then gets a discard
and a draw after that. Thanks for
conquering Zuan Warren, so a lot of
value gleaned from this Kaisa and not
going to miss it this time.
Zuan Warren's now being considered. What
does Coco Lopez want to discard?
Filtering through couple more cards,
seeing deeper into their deck, and Blood
Rush is going to hit the trash.
Kind of a fun one. Didn't see that in
every Draven deck.
>> Yeah, you don't see it in every Draven
deck, but I do like that as the discard
here. That's the sort of thing that you
might want to get late game when you
need that extra oomph to push over top
of a battlefield. This early on here
when you're just trying to establish
point tempo, it's not going to be nearly
as relevant.
>> I'm so curious, by the way, if uh
if these like little little powerful
units keep happening, I wonder like at
what point do Annie stop being like,
"You know what? Maybe a Hextech
Ransacker should come back into this
deck." Cuz that would be a way to maybe
break the point tempo in this point, but
instead it's Overzealous Fan occupying
two different battlefields and two
points to zero in favor of Draven. So,
Coco Lopez feeling a real good about how
this game is going, going first once
again. But to six wounds, we know what
usually happens when that is uh when
that threshold is hit. But how do we
break through these battlefields? It's
six might to two on the top and bottom,
respectively, but again, the big problem
really being these Overzealous Fans, who
always want to push you away from their
idol.
>> Yeah, that's right. It is the League of
Draven, after all, and Draven has fans
everywhere, but uh does look like
it's just going to be a sacrifice of the
one as the Ringard goes into Targon's
Peak.
Coco
pushes the Ringard back, Ty Turner goes
back in prismaticism. Of course,
Reinforces hit the magic six.
>> I almost didn't say anything.
>> With the Fervent Forerunner.
>> And uh actually going down to the peak,
I like I like going down there only cuz
it's the softer of the two Battlefields,
but because again, can't reconquer for
Kukulcan on his own runes, so he can't
get that effect again. But rating four
runes thanks to Annie's Legend ability,
and we talked about how good two runes
are. Flash, hard bargain,
uh all these other different uh things
you can use. With four, the entire
reaction suite is basically open now for
Prismaticism.
>> Exactly. You can do two of the two
energy options. Uh you also have cards
like Rengar available if you want to
play it defensively, which again, does
not happen often, but we have seen it
occur this weekend, and it was very
impactful when it mattered. So, uh once
you get up to four, kind of the world is
your oyster if you're Prismaticism.
>> And I think at this point, unless
Kukulcan has a really efficient way to
kind of break through this, and it might
be tough here. It looks like Titan are
going to get traded off as Gem-Gem is
running in. Prismaticism says, "Yeah,
you got it."
Gem-Gem are going to go down. I think
we're going to now going to have a game
where it's not going to be quite so easy
to get two points a turn for either
player. It's going to be one at a time
as they set up, and Beast Below, huge
tech I assume out of the board. That is
going to bring a unit back, but more
importantly, effectively rebuke the
Ferrous Forerunner while putting eight
might on the board.
>> Yeah, this is a card that we have seen
this weekend. A few of the players have
decided to run. Sometimes one in the
main, sometimes them in the board as
well, because as you pointed out, it's
like playing a rebuke, but you also get
eight might on top of it. This is very
impactful because it put the Forerunner
back into Prismaticism's hand. Uh again,
very strong if you're expecting to see a
field full of Forerunners, but eight
might is also incredibly difficult to
take down.
>> And it looks like uh in reactions with
Beast Below's uh bounce on the chain,
Rengar was played in reactions back to
that Battlefield. So, uh there was a
Ferrous Forerunner there. It's no longer
there, but there's now a Rengar
occupying that, which is actually pretty
nice as far as stealing a point away
here.
>> Yeah, just trying to maintain that hold
point because every point is going to
matter if Prismaticism plays from behind
due to that Beast Below. That Kaisa
there is also going to make sure that
Cocoa Lopez is not short on cards
anytime soon. There's also potentially
the additional filtering because
Prismaticism can't do much to stop a
move into the Zone Warrens unless they
want to commit a card from hand.
>> It's kind of nice to play a little more
in base, especially when you're ahead as
driven in the spot because it's a much
better way to dodge Rex Sais and Rengars
who really want to be attacking into you
with that assault. So when you deny them
that opportunity by just leaving the
battlefields open, well yeah, they might
get some points, but you're already
ahead in that race, so maybe you don't
mind so much. Although it is going to be
evened up in short order potentially as
point number two now on the board for
Prismaticism and it's going to be point
number three as the other Rengar goes up
top.
>> So this is going to provide the filter,
the tying point.
And we're going to see the Forerunner
come back.
>> It was the plan before, it's still the
plan now. At some point you're going to
need to likely throw enough might into
that Beast Below to get rid of it.
Something like a Forerunner plus a
Cleave could get the job done, but
either way you need to have enough might
on the board to even start thinking
about it.
>> Your hands are stacked and I did just
spy something that we've seen all
weekend long and Sephora, and it is in
fact Rebukes. So the last two Chaos Runs
are going to be recycled, but Flash is
going to happen. Hard Bargain going to
shut that down again. How many times
have we seen that little interaction as
Kaisa wanting to conquer in. It's only
three might. The math is being done, but
Cocoa Lopez is making absolutely sure
before running into the Rengar.
>> Yeah, and there's been a lot of talk
lately about Rebuke. Obviously most
popular card all weekend long. However,
Hard Bargain has really shown up in
clutch moments so many times over the
course of this tournament. And I think
that it is going to be the kind of card
where folks start game planning
specifically for it the same way that
you do against Calm. In Calm matchups
you're saying, I know that they likely
have a Defy, what do I do? Or it it's a
not so fast. With chaos lately,
I feel like most players know that
Hearth Bargain is potentially there, but
it's not always respected in the same
breath as the other two.
>> Yeah, they don't think about it maybe as
automatically as uh those cards that you
mentioned. And the thing about adding is
that it's great to to ready those two
runes and be able to have a very
powerful uh two energy spell like Flash
of Steel to play. Unfortunately, when
you don't have four, you get Hearth
Bargained a lot in spots like that. So,
it's just kind of a risk you have to
take for wanting to develop more because
if you just leave your your your energy
open, your runes up, you're just
probably not developing. And that's also
uh a risk you can't really afford to get
into. So, Rengar getting rolled in,
Fan's going to push that back, protect
the Kai'Sa. And now Ride the Wind is
going to roll on in. That's going to be
five might to four, and it's two runes
available thanks to the Targon's Peak
here. So, what does Cokolopes have?
Action window there. Spinning Axe,
pretty good bit of equipment. Plus three
now for the Kai'Sa, winning this combat
seven to five.
>> And Prismatism now has
>> Ooh.
>> the rebuke of his own, the first one, of
course, Hearth Bargained, but this time
will get the job done.
This is going to result in a successful
conquer.
We'll be able to ready all of the runes
at the end of the turn because of both
the Eye of the Dragon and now the Peak
Conquer.
I think this I was going to say, I think
this Rengar is probably going to go home
simply because uh there is the hopeful
in the base.
And that just naturally goes over it
because Rengar naturally Assault is uh
on offense.
>> Yeah, the Spinning Axe goes away as
well. It's temporary if it's unattached
at uh your the its control's beginning
phase. So, that rebuke doing a little
bit of extra, getting a bit of extra
value out of the deal. Uh again, costly
having to recycle two Chaos Runes or
Prismatism, uh losing the resource race,
but trying to keep up on points and
still falling behind in that magic
reserve. This big old beast below at the
zone warrants is somewhat problematic,
and Cokolopes gets to the critical
juncture of six points, puts down two
units, and says, "What do you have? I am
winning."
Make him have it.
>> Yeah, I was just about to highlight that
was the first to that magic number six.
Properly recognizes it, develops as much
might as possible in the base. Passes
and
>> And there's no way out.
>> Yeah, prismaticism just takes a look at
the total might and says there's nothing
that I can do that's going to stop that
and they're going to go to game three.
>> And I kind of love the I love the way
here at this point not just cuz you get
maximum number of games of Riven but I
feel like we've seen both decks do their
thing. Annie in game one go to head and
stayed ahead the entire game. It was not
close per the point total by the end of
that one. But Draven kind of showing one
of the reasons it's such a powerful deck
especially in this kind of match up.
Annie's units are a little smaller.
She's very tricky. She's constantly kind
of tempoing you by readying runes. But
Draven's units card quality wise they're
just so much bigger, so much better once
they have time to develop. And you saw
the might at the end of that board. Like
prismaticism was never going to have a
board that big.
>> Well,
might have if a forerunner could have
stuck to the table.
>> That's true.
>> But the successful not only rebuke but
beast below was a real difference maker
in that game, too. As we go into this
game three,
I can't help but point out that both
players won when they were on
going second on the the two runes.
>> That's true.
>> Both three runes, excuse me.
>> Both have broken seven and now it's
Annie's turn to go first. That means our
first to develop an Over zealous fan.
Usually good news for a deck that wants
to be a little bit faster than Draven
overall in this match up and just in
general in this meta game. Players have
talked often about how much they do love
going first. It is an arena's greatest
game as well. So we are speeding things
up. Oh, never mind. That's a regular
It's a regular game everybody. Don't
worry about it.
Little old
>> regular game with extra steps.
>> Yeah, just a little bit of seasoning on
it.
>> Exactly. We're playing to nine but
everyone's got one. It's basically like
playing to eight. Don't worry about it.
Don't freak out though when we get into
the end of the game and someone gets to
eight points. It will not end.
Uh also these players have
>> almost optimal openers. We have the fan
on the side of prismaticism. When you're
going second, stack deck into Noxus
Hopeful is as good as you can hope for.
That's going to result in the Kai'Sa and
then pass on Prismaticism side because
again, we've seen that these players are
not eager to just run into a battlefield
and die. They want to do things in twos
and they're staying true to their form.
>> I will say Targon's Peak looked pretty
good for Coca Lopez in that game. It
does all make sense. They did bring that
battlefield to bear. Not going to have
that option and that's going to be only
Annie that can really do the tempoing of
developing and readying some runes,
which again is the kind of the maxim the
entire deck is built around is Stack
Deck. Going to get deployed here on
Prismaticism side. Rexai Breachlord
deployed on the other and Coca Lopez, I
think doing what you want to be doing in
this drive match-up. If you believe that
your units are generally bigger and
better, just being a bit more patient,
develop but developing them where there
isn't a lot of pressure in the game
right now, feels to me like the right
thing to do.
>> Well, also both times it was a cheap
Noxus Hopeful. So, anytime that you can
pay two and get a four-might on the
board, you kind of want to do it because
you're just generally going ahead at
that point and I like this from
Prismaticism. Wants to play the flash
now so that you don't have to worry
about a Hard Bargain potentially blowing
you out. I was going to say earlier the
Stack Deck from Prismaticism obviously
signals we weren't going to see the
Conquer plus four runner combo that
we've seen in the past and if that's
going to be the case, you want to get
your points but then keep your units
safe.
>> I like that that's been so prevalent
throughout this weekend that you've
called that a combo.
Conquer reinforcement battlefield good
press forward. That's a combo, folks.
>> Hey, when it comes to
when it comes to these Fae Spells 400
decks, that's as close to a combo as
you're going to get.
>> That's very pretty true. There is
Hopeful of Prismaticism's own gets
deployed and kind of the the fun in
between three runes gets left up here,
which means that could be any of the two
energy spells or a Renga coming through.
And you don't have to play Renga to a
battlefield. If you get an action
winning, you can just play it to your
base as an extra unit. And again, on
offense, Rengar is five might. That is a
lot of extra power.
>> So, that's what I was referring to last
game. There was a situation where Coco
could have went to a battlefield, and
I'd mentioned playing Rengar. I did not
mean in defense of the battlefield, but
just to your base. Sometimes utilizing
those extra runes from Rennie on your or
Annie, excuse me, on your opponent's
turn for something like a Rengar is like
ramping up.
>> Hiding a card?
Kaisa being played, not accelerated
again. Wanted to keep it a little safer
in the back line. And uh last time the
hidden card was Switcheroo. Could also
be a Tidecaller, but I have a guess that
the hidden card is once again
Switcheroo.
Maybe. That's my guess. I'm not saying
it's right. I'm just saying that's what
I'm guessing, Chump.
Three points a piece, though.
>> With a something like a Tidecaller, you
could maybe send that Noxus Hopeful over
to the other Noxus Hopeful and swap them
just for for Jack.
>> send the Rek'Sai in, too.
And then uh
it would be a four, same as a Noxus
Hopeful.
>> Well, not in defense.
>> Oh, it doesn't work? It doesn't count as
attacking when you swap them? No.
I guess there's only one attacker.
You're right. Feels bad, man.
A soul doesn't trigger.
Even though you're heading in,
ultimately, you're heading out. Feels
bad. Poor Rek'Sai is being chilling in
the base.
As Prismatistism, three points a piece,
but has the opportunity to obtain more
points. And as I mentioned, we are
playing to nine this game. So, it is
still win in twos, but the numbers are
going to be odd instead of even. I know,
I know. It throws everyone off in the
final game of the day.
But it's all right. We'll make it
through together. So, looking for maybe
to try and get points four and five,
would love to, but what does it cost you
to get that there? Two runes open on the
other side.
Number of cards to work with in the
hand. And the first deep think of this
final game
from Prismatistism.
>> Th- This is an interesting position to
be in just because the two runes could
single signal, excuse me, a number of
things from Coco Lopez. The same way
that it means Uh, potential plays from
Annie. Rebuke is still a playable card.
Switcheroo can still be played from
hand. There's all sorts of options. On
top of that, you keep pointing out there
is the hidden card on the one side. I
was just about to say, so you might see
something like a hopeful going in just
to trade if you think it's a switcheroo
because it's now just not effective.
>> Yeah, I kind of like that. He is looking
to trade it off and basically take out
the unit and the hidden card and uh do a
bit of damage, maybe move back in with
Kai'Sa. And it is Oh, no, it's Tide
Turner.
The one time you don't want it to be
Tide Turner. It is in fact Tide Turner.
Could swap over to the other
battlefield. Could get Rexai in, I
guess, but don't think either of those
things are particularly interesting. I
think it's just an extra unit to try and
hold down the fort.
>> And so now the question is, does
Prismaticism have an answer in the form
of something like a Cleave? Perhaps
that's why they were okay with sending
this in. Or is this going to be a
situation where
uh perhaps there's a a Ride the Wind to
send it in another direction to save it?
>> Yeah, Spinning Axe as well. Uh kind of
the big one in Draven when they leave
open uh two runes. Did see it be pretty
effective in the last game. I guess the
thought here might be swapping in the
hopeful just so Kai'Sa survivor doesn't
get I guess she she goes top then, so
that doesn't actually matter. You can't
get two full might units on both these
battlefields. So Kai'Sa is presumably
going to have a softish target to
assault eventually. It looks like this
Kai'Sa might be moving on in.
>> So
>> I guess I guess I guess that's the way
to do the thing I said.
>> what do you think that you're having to
potentially play around on the side of
Prismaticism? Now, Prismaticism also
could I was going to say just let this
go, take out the Kai'Sa, and then opt to
go back in with something else. So
patient play, making sure you get rid of
the premier target. I I like this so far
because of the Tide Turner. I think
Prismaticism wanted to see a switcheroo
and just get that value, kind of call
the bluff, but uh sometimes you have to
make an omelet from your broken eggs.
>> Certainly do. And uh one of the things
he's kind of forgot to do that too many
times in this match up cuz Draven did
win a combat. Koko Lopez drawing a card
out of that exchange as well for winning
a combat. So, while you can test the
waters every now and then and you do
want to kind of poke and prod to see
what the cards might be, you don't want
to do it too much cuz giving any deck
too many free cards is a bad time. I can
tell you that much.
Unless it's me. Give me all the cards.
I'll appreciate that at least. It's
prismaticism.
>> Thinking.
Kind of the same situation, right? I
guess now it's two format units instead.
Wants to really get this Kai'Sa
somewhere to conquer to draw another
card.
>> Yeah, and the other problem is Koko
still has those two runes available. So,
if you were hoping to get something from
hand instead, you did not.
>> I think the other thing is that even if
you do commit Kai'Sa and something else,
right? Cuz it has to be something else
to to win the combat, get the conquer,
and put Kai'Sa get make sure Kai'Sa gets
the point. What do you have left, right?
Is that a little too exposed in the
situation? Only gets you one point. You
can't get the double conquer, so it is
going to be long sword committed here.
That's going to be six might to four,
but again, the two runes are open and it
is going to be rebuke. That is savage.
Is there a hard bargain in answer?
Doesn't look like it from what I can see
and Kai'Sa is going to go back to hand
here.
>> And that is
maybe worst case scenario for
prismaticism. It was the tide turner
instead of the switcher-roo. It was a
rebuke that was on hand with the two
runes that were up.
Could still equip the long sword and
send in the fan, but there's no reason
to, right? You're still only at four.
You're not going to win anything without
yet again expending another card.
>> Yep, and again, Draven also drew another
card. That rebuke
winning a combat there with the hopeful
still at the battlefield. Now, one of
the lines open is accelerating Kai'Sa
and basically doing it again. That would
require you recycling two runes, two
fury runes in order to re-equip that
long sword, but if that was the play you
wanted to make to begin with, it may
still be worthwhile to do so cuz now you
know the coast is clear. There are no
ruins left up.
>> I think counting out
options available. Uh slid forward to
one side if you're still considering
going on offense and you have the four,
maybe the consideration is uh something
like a Rek'Sai with the accelerate.
>> Yeah, I think just in general have to be
worried about the crackback here.
Rek'Sai breacher in base. Tie turner
still back in base safe to contribute to
might. It's going to be one or cycle. It
is Rek'Sai breacher. That also has
accelerate as you mentioned. Long sword
going to get equipped and in we go.
Three, four, five, six might total
thanks to Rek'Sai's assault one and five
on defense, which is pretty good.
Rek'Sai breacher not normally all that
good at defending and overzealous fans
going to reinforce and so is the second
one trying to build a little fort down
here at the Aspirant's Climb.
Prismatism says, I know
>> that Draven has fans, but so does the
queen. Rek'Sai is going to sit on this
Aspirant's Climb with uh an entourage in
tow to hopefully fend off against the
opposing Rek'Sai uh tie turner that you
were talking about in the base. Uh now
Coco
goes up to four points
at the start of the turn because of the
hold and has six runes available and a
fistful of cards thanks to all of those
one combats.
>> Yeah, no Cauldron either kind of the
other downside of this line for
Prismatism. Uh Kai'Sa obviously a great
unit to conquer with. She does draw you
a card and get you extra value as you
move through, but Rek'Sai a bit more of
a robust unit here especially alongside
these other overzealous fans. And of
course, the accelerate on Kai'Sa would
have been too expensive to make this
exact play. So, pretty good defense set
up here, but there's still answers
available. That looks suspiciously like
uh six energy.
>> What costs six energy?
>> Ferris Forerunner cost six energy. Up to
the top we go.
Hanging out in the arena with Knoxious
hopeful.
>> You know
>> How many times do you think we've said
Ferris Forerunner this weekend by the
way?
Titan ring?
>> At least four.
>> That's okay.
It doesn't seem like it this time. No
fan activation, just trades off with one
of them. Decides that uh that Titan is
uh
just fine.
>> Well, it's one of those situations where
if you activate the fan, your opponent
keeps their two-might unit and you lose
yours. If you just let it trade, you
both lose your two-might unit. There's
almost never any incentive to activate
it there unless
uh you're really worried about some sort
of buff or counter play, but with all of
the runes already expended for the
Forerunner, you're just going to take
the outcome.
>> going to ask you, do you think it was
worth waiting on uh using the runes for
the Forerunner there just for the bluff
at least?
>> Cuz it's I love a good bluff.
>> You do love a good bluff. Titan could
have run it earlier, but
likely some of the consideration there
I'm maybe not getting, but that's okay.
We'll awaken, go to five points of
prismaticism. Is it a point where Annie
does like to be up just barely in the
points race. You only need to win by one
sometimes, Charm, and prismaticism does
have the lead.
>> And notably
on an odd number, which again all
weekend long we've talked about how the
important numbers are typically even,
but this is an Aspirant's climb game.
So, this five is as good as a normal
four. So, you want to be on the odds
going forward if possible so that you
can go from five to seven, seven to
nine, and then close out the game.
And we see the Ferris Forerunner
developed by prismaticism in the base.
>> It's a five.
>> A pullback of the units. Coco will score
from the hold and has an open
battlefield on the other side could be
taking the lead.
>> I kind of like this from prismaticism. I
think a common play pattern we saw
against Draven Uh earlier meta games
where Draven was even more prevalent, is
that uh you don't really want to give
Draven opportunities for combat if you
don't have to. And that's an interesting
decision to me because
it's even right now on points, but
you're kind of giving the open lane, if
you will, for your opponent to get the
get the lead on points. With a
Forerunner already entrenched in that
top battlefield, does feel like
potentially a risky thing to offer up.
And indeed, Rex Arbiter is going to roll
on in. And Prismatism is going to say,
"Yep, I'm not going to play Rengar in
this spot. It doesn't even win this
battle one-on-one, even if you have
nothing else." So, you can go to six
points, but Prismatism clearly valuing
the might in the base to try and make a
much bigger play to win on the following
turn.
>> Well, there's two things to consider
here when you're doing that risk
calculation. The first is this is only
taking Coco to six points and
>> It's a climb game.
>> This is one of those things where it's a
climb game, so it's less important. The
other thing to consider as well is that
Prismatism is down to three cards in
hand. We know Draven has a bunch because
of those one combats. We saw a
uh game lost by Prismatism against
Alanzq in the previous set because he
ran out of cards. Alan kind of
attritioned him out. And I think that
he's just trying to
uh not risk that. You want to stay in
the game with your options, keep things
available. And so, I think that when you
do that risk calculation, giving up a
point that's not what would normally be
the even points in an Aspirant's climb,
technically you want to be the odd
points. I think this is worth it.
>> I do think at a high level you're right.
The on a long time horizon, that favors
this Draven deck for sure. That is the
deck that is happy to grind you out, to
really try attritioning you. And just
again, use that card quality in a longer
game. And Aspirant's climb does make
games a touch longer. In this instance,
it is again the same with Arena's
greatest being the other battlefield.
You just have to remind yourself
sometimes, because sometimes the
commentators forget the thing they said
five times already
is still true. Cuz battlefields uh don't
really go anywhere, at least not until
the next set. Thanks, Ivern. As Beast
Below, So backbreaker from the last
game, is going to happen once more.
Bouncing the Rexo, bouncing the
forerunner, doesn't even have to be at
the battlefield like Rubik. It just gets
sent straight back to hand.
>> And as you said before that was a back
breaker the last time it hit the table.
Looks to be the same this time because
not only is it the biggest unit from
prismaticism put back into the hand but
eight more might onto the battlefield
for Coco Lopez. That is a whopping 14
sitting on the arena's greatest at the
moment.
>> So so curious what the approach is here.
Still only a point behind but it feels a
little bit worse than that. If it was a
step If it was a step ahead earlier,
it's a step and and then a step behind.
Now it feels like a step and a half and
that just that little inch might be the
thing that tips this game in the balance
for Coco Lopez and Draven may well win
yet another regional qualifier here in
Atlanta but we still have a number of
turns left to play in prismaticism. This
is a tough one to try and think through
because it's not just what do I do this
turn? What am I trying to deploy? What
am I trying to develop? What is
happening on the sub good turns? What do
I do against the 14 might up top with
the first forerunner? What do I do with
my unit that got bounced yet again by
this beast below?
>> Yeah, you said it might be going from a
step to a step and a half behind. I
would argue it's going to a beast sized
step behind because uh again that seems
to be the all star so far in this match
up. Uh even if prismaticism manages to
close the gap that that just created, it
is proving to be monumental
so far.
>> Little sip of water.
All right, have a stretch, reset.
Start thinking. How do we approach this
game?
>> Are we going to get our first ever mid
game set of push ups?
>> Could be.
If there was ever a time to pull out the
dark technology, it would be in the
final game
of the regional qualifier, the one that
determines the champion
of this entire 1600 player plus
tournament.
>> And after all of that thought, the
decision is a rebuke onto the Ferris
Forerunner says, "I have Beast
>> Ooh! At home.
>> That is so good. Switcheroo. We talked
about how 8 might is so unapproachable,
but uh Switcheroo literally turns the
tables. Overzel's playing going to get
the point. Rex is going to get another.
And now Prismaticism. Is that seven
points? That is. We're threatening to
win. We have reached the end game first.
>> And on top of that is going to end this
turn by playing the Annie, getting a
spell of choice back. And the
choices likely going to be Flash. Still
making that decision.
>> And then, yeah, could could could be
Rebirth. Could Switcheroo.
>> play Rebirth. It's part of the problem.
So, I don't think you want to pick it
even though you could. No extra chaos
power to pay that with your runes. And
uh so, going to get the thing that Annie
almost always gets, it feels like in
this deck. The marquee spell, the
signature spell that's sort of a real
signature spell for Annie. It is Flash.
>> Now, that last sequence was incredibly
important because the Switcheroo going
on the Beast Below means it can't be
replayed. The Rebirth onto the
Forerunner and then using the Switcheroo
on the other side is critical. Now, Coco
does have the Hopeful, but has to figure
out a way to navigate the current board
state.
>> And that's the thing. Forerunner, it's a
wonderful unit. It's maybe the best unit
in the game. It's certainly one of the
best units in this tournament.
But right now, it's too slow.
It doesn't have Accelerate. It doesn't
come in ready. It's all this value, but
only if anything happens. And there
might not be enough points left in this
game for it to do anything.
>> And that's why Coco is digging with this
stacked deck trying to find the answers.
Again, such a beautiful setup from
Prismaticism. Like I said, it's the
build your Beast Below at home in that
interaction. And Coco is now looking to
build his own monster to crack back.
This is
uh the
final moments likely in game three of
the finals of our regional qualifier
here in Atlanta. Prismaticism, as you
pointed out, at seven. This is a climb
game, so has to get two more points to
win, but is still within striking
distance.
>> thing is, Coco needs three more points
to win, which means this turn is not a
turn that Draven can win. So, not only
do you have to stop this from happening,
you can't expend you can't overextend
yourself so much that you basically
checkmate yourself on the following turn
anyway.
>> And known information. Because of the
Annie played, you know that the flash is
there.
As you pointed out, you have to stop the
win from occurring, but you can't
overcommit resources, and you know that
Prismatism has the capability to save
these units, but you still can't just
avoid combat with them. You have to push
them off the battlefields. So, it's
going to feel bad no matter what
happens. And with the axe coming down,
Prismatism opts to just flash the Rexai.
You can still leave the fan because that
can push if necessary. You still have
the Annie in base, so you have a backup
unit to go to both sites if necessary.
>> Yeah, flashing reactions, I love that.
Actually, with the spinning axe coming
down, he says, "You know, I'm going to
save my Rexai right now. Going to push
back your Rexai." So, now the
battlefield up top is open, and the
bottom is open as well. There's a hidden
card for Prismatism.
Going to awaken everything. Going to
have five runes available. I mean, if he
can find the line, if he has the means,
the win is on the table potentially.
>> Yeah, the big story, I think, right now
is that Coco has no runes ready. So,
yes, there's a hidden card, but if
Prismatism
could have found something like a
rebuke, it might have been game.
However,
we might see a situation where that lack
of chaos runes comes into play. As you
pointed out, wouldn't be able to have
played it last turn, channeled two red
runes this turn. That might complicate
things for Prismatism.
>> Seven might on the bottom battlefield.
The top one is open. It's there for the
taking. The Arena's Greatest can be
waltzed on in at any moment.
You can't divide your might and still
win the combat. And again, that hidden
card.
Switcheroo, tie turner.
I mean, Edge of Night. There's a few
things in this cards. It is open
decklist, so again, Prismatism will know
what the options are.
I don't think it's more it's it's not
many more than two hidden cards, I
believe. I think it's two or three. It
might only be two, but
>> Are you telling me that there's no Wind
Singer in this list?
>> There might be a Wind Singer, I don't
know. I haven't looked at the decklist.
>> No, there is not. I uh spoiler alert.
>> Okay. You did look. That's good. At
least one of us did.
So, I mean, look, we can do a little bit
of math right now. Rex Sai on offense
with the longsword, six might.
Uh when she goes in to attack, Annie,
three, not bad. Honestly, for a kind of
a utility-style champion.
>> I think the decision is going to really
just come down to what does Prismatism
have as potential options because again,
before we saw him try to call the bluff
on what he thought was a Switcheroo and
said, "Hey,
uh if it's a Tide Turner, I'm just kind
of hosed. If there was something like a
Cleave available, they could have
outplayed that, but
>> Little rewind.
>> Yeah, little rewind on the
>> There was uh an accelerated Kai'Sa in a
push there for a moment.
>> Yeah. So, that would be six, four,
that'll be 10. 10 on seven versus Tide
Turner would be good. Switcheroo, I
think is going to ruin the day no matter
Although, actually, that's not true cuz
it's seven. Switcheroo is a little
awkies here cuz what do you want to
switch with?
>> Yeah, that is a good
>> You have no You have no other units. It
is Tide Turner. I don't think that's
enough. Oh, Rex Sai is the one coming
in, but that is four, five, six, seven.
That's 10 total. That's going to be
enough for a trade. There's nothing else
for Prismatism here, so everything is
going to just fall off here and Annie
Does she even care about walking into a
battlefield for a point? It doesn't
really make that much of a difference.
Although, you can threaten to win by
holding, I suppose. Force you to come
in.
>> was going to say I think that the
decision that you have to make now in
this situation is
if you leave both open and your opponent
has any sort of accelerate
and you don't have some sort of
reaction speed answer with your runes
up, you're kind of just giving it up.
You want to make them work for it a
little bit harder. So, So ultimately,
Prismatism agrees, says, "I need to put
some might here so that it's not just
free if you have something like a Rex
Sai or like a Kai'Sa."
>> Both players running low on resources.
Tai Turner can't walk in to the bottom
battlefield and get point number eight,
but we are climbing this game. Both
players all weekend long grinding it
out. We're walking up the stairs step by
step.
>> So, Tai Turner could walk in and get
eight. However, Prismaticism's already
at eight. So, if you do not deal with
the Annie, this is the other reason that
you had to put it there because if Coco
Lopez cannot break this, you will win
through holding. This is a make-or-break
moment.
>> Trying to extend the game a few more
turns.
And again, thinking through, we know
about the flash still. Do we remember
that it's still there? Probably wrote it
down, which is a good thing to do. You
can take notes in Riftbound. Over here
instead, actually going to challenge in
that. Feels like it sends alarm bells
over. There's Rebuke.
And there's Deck Stacked. Deck is
actually going to be the play.
It's true, you actually have to wait.
It's not a reaction, it's only an
action. So, Deck Stacked does happen
here. Going to get a look at a few
cards, but that Annie is rebuked, back
to hand, picks up a card.
>> Five ruins and so after this awaken,
it's really tough to find a spot where
he he gets something done here.
>> I was just about to say. So, the the
real question now is whether or not the
Rex Sai was the other play.
But I believe
that might have just been a a pass.
>> I think so. It kind of looked like one.
Going to eight points now is Coco Lopez.
Both players literally one point away
from being the Regional Qualifier
Atlanta champion.
>> One point away. Game three of the
finals.
>> Good night's sleep much better than
this.
>> here.
>> Hasn't passed yet, by the way.
>> Hasn't hasn't passed yet.
>> Two energy. Reinforce? Fan?
Knocks his hopeful.
>> Reinforce. Hopeful. Okay. Threat to
hold. Only need one point at this point.
Double conquer seems really tough in
this spot. If you're prismatism, drawing
a card, what do we have?
>> Prismatism channeled two more red runes
once again. So, this is going to be
incredibly limiting on any options for
pushing off of this battlefield unless
you come in with might. That being said
>> Rex I plus cleave?
>> Rex I could be something that could get
the job done. Rengar has put in work so
far. So, if you could
>> Ooh, Rengar would be good. There's Rex I
accelerated. In we go. That's just six.
This is trading up right now. Prismatism
says that's good enough. I don't have
very many options left.
>> You You can't win if you lose. So, you
at least have to stop what's on the
board and we are hitting a point where I
can't imagine what it's like for the
players. I am breathless just watching
this.
>> is finally back. We talked about it.
Wasn't enough time earlier to replay it,
but it is going to come back down.
>> I am curious
uh if the forerunner is because you're
worried about removal here or if there
was maybe uh some other reason why
Draven from the champion zone wasn't to
play just because that is a large number
of might in an aspirants game. Uh but,
it is the forerunner here.
>> I thought about uh Showboat as well, but
going to stay in the tank.
I mean, the removal that's going to hit
the forerunner is mostly stuff that's
not going to trigger the the death knell
anyway.
But, uh I mean, a little bit more
efficient use of your your runes perhaps
using all six.
And uh this is going to be a tough one.
I I will note I mean, I guess there was
accelerate unit. So, it's it's not
it's not safe to leave the forerunner
here. At least not have a way to maybe
answer it in showdown. But, you also
have to advance your game plan. Like,
you need to put some units on the board.
You need to threaten to try and conquer.
>> This This is an interesting situation
for both players because
you need some board presence.
You need a double conquer or a hold and
you're at least a few actions away from
that
in both scenarios.
>> Certainly are. Chrism is in deep in
thought.
Trying to figure out what do I have
left.
Smiles exchanged by both players. They
know it's close, but who's going to take
it? That is the real question.
Two ruins. Nope. Taking them back again.
Very very tough to find a way to
navigate through this game.
>> Yeah, that's a lot of might on that
Ferris Forerunner and it was big enough
that if Chrism is in some develops
something here,
it has to likely still be able to
contest with that Forerunner, right?
Because if Coco is able to walk into one
side and then just sit, you have to go
over top. And that's not even counting
what happens if Coco does still have the
accelerate unit as an option. And if you
don't do something to stop it now, you
could walk the Forerunner into one spot,
accelerate into the other. Chrism is in
some I think is asking to see the bin,
likely wants to see how many of the
accelerate units have already been
played, looking for kites, is looking
for Rex size, things of that nature.
>> Good habit to get into.
Especially late in the game. Especially
late and deep in a series.
In this final, looking through what do
you have left? Chrism is in some as
you'll notice
leaves his trash very nicely splayed to
check the options at a glance. Also
makes my job easier, which I appreciate.
>> Between the two days of this regional
qualifier, we are officially at the end
of hour number 25 of Rift.
>> Traveling merchant is the decision here.
Two energy for a unit. But again, it's
going to be I think it is actually
effectively impossible for Chrism is in
some to win this turn. It is mostly
trying not to lose and still set up a
win following that.
>> I think it's absolutely just trying to
not lose the next turn, hoping that
there's not an accelerate unit that you
can't stop.
>> So does Coco Lopez have something here?
4 5 6 7 runes. Forerunner goes over.
There's ride the wind. We're trying to
go over with the traveling merchant and
sneak away a point here.
>> Oh, if this sticks and Lopez does not
either have an answer for it or an
accelerate unit to get in there then
Prismaticism will win on the hold come
the next turn.
>> That's true. Sneaking one in but still
seven rooms open. Again, the this
conquer by the Ferris Forerunner which
is still in the process of happening by
the way. Hasn't quite happened yet.
>> Right.
>> Uh, will draw a card but it can't win.
>> showdown.
>> Exactly.
>> in the situation and because it's an
action it has to be done now. You can't
wait for like a reaction window later
but this is this is the all in play I
think from Prismaticism saying, "Look, I
don't think I can go over this so I'm
going to try to steal one and just hope
that there's no answer."
>> We're queuing up Battlefields.
This is the fun one but here we go.
First things first. Conquer happens.
Uh, they actually both throw a card cuz
they're both at the winning point but
cannot win.
>> Exactly. They're both at eight need to
go to nine so on what would be conquers
they draw a card.
>> Falling Star. That's very good.
Is that enough? RENGA IS DOWN. IS THAT
GOING TO BE ENOUGH? RENGA OCCUPYING A
BATTLEFIELD. Does Coco Lopez have
anything left after that? Prismaticism
is out of room.
>> Ryan's kitty has been so good all
weekend long and because the Falling
Star has to choose the targets Rengard
is now there.
Free.
Does Coco have the rebuke in this
instance? NO. SHOWS IT.
>> THAT'S IT.
HE DOES IT. RENGA.
>> THE INNOVATION IN this Annie deck got it
done.
Wow. I thought for sure that
Prismaticism had a huge hill to climb
with that Ferris Forerunner staring him
down. He played the lowly merchant.
Didn't even put the long sword on it.
Just said, "Hey, I'm I'm playing
possible over here."
>> a little guy.
>> capitalized by jumping on it with the
showdown and then having the Rengard as
the backup in case there was a rebuke or
falling star or whatever the case may
be. What a beautifully played game.
Prismaticism has been consistently
better every event that he has attended
but has finally got the monkey off his
back, got the big win he's been looking
for.
>> Starting to make a case for one of the
best of Rift bound players in the world.
Approaching that top spot where his
teammates tend to occupy a lot of that
conversation. He is well and truly in
the throws of that chatter now in the
early days of Rift bound. An incredible
victory stolen away.
>> I I said to you while we were on our
break, I am inspired by this Annie deck.
It makes me want to play it. I've been
watching Prismatism play it and I just
go, this looks fun. This looks good. I
like the long swords. I love the
Rengar's. They have been great all
weekend long. They come in the most
clutch you could be in the biggest
moment of the event. I'm so happy for
Prismatism.
>> You talked about it. Players learn to
play around the fire. Learn to play
around not to vest. Learn to play around
the week. Learn to play around cleave.
Learn to play around bolt. All these
stuff all these things that Rift bound
has developed and hard bargain that's
been kind of a sore spot but the players
they're figuring it out. You know what
they haven't figured out how to play
around yet? Rengar and this is the thing
that this Annie deck does that Draven
cannot do.
>> You know, you mentioned the hard bargain
thing. We've seen hard bargain be
incredible all weekend long. It's almost
like Prismatism went one step ahead of
the developing meta because you know
what you can't hard bargain? Rengar.
>> You know what's coming in unleashed?
Rengar.
>> More Rengar. I'm so looking forward to
it.
>> Yeah. That's an absolutely thrilling
final. I mean we had so many three game
sets. You could not ask for better Rift
bound. You could not ask for a tighter
margins and I think you could ask for a
more deserving champion. What an
incredible showcase by both these
players. Draven so close to winning
another regional qualifier but undone in
the same domains by the dark child.
>> I don't
I don't even know what to say. It's so
weird because again all weekend long not
to toot my own horn.
I have said that I thought Aurelia as a
legend had a good chance to win, but if
I'm picking based on the player, I think
Prismaticism has this event won.
Prismaticism, thank you. You have proven
me to be a genius. But now that it's
happened, like I am literally breathless
because it wasn't even just like, oh, he
steamrolled in. He fought for it every
step of the way in this top eight. The
games against Collin, tight. The games
against Alan, tight. Their game three,
down to the wire.
>> No margins left for error, and it just
goes to show that
>> it is capable
Players can be capable of overcoming
almost any obstacle if you just play to
your outs.
>> That game looked impossible to win. Like
actually impossible. Rune like Rune's
advantage completely shredded all the
Runes to cycle them. Had to use
Switcheroo and Rebuke in the final turn
just to stay in the game and set up a
possible win. Don't know how he found
that line to begin with.
>> Yeah.
>> And then with five Runes and a Traveling
Merchant and nothing but, you know, a
hope and a prayer, there was a line.
>> It It's almost
>> I didn't think Riku was coming out of
the hat.
>> I can't wait till we get to the
interview portion cuz I want to know if
Switcheroo only came in for game three
after the Beast Below blew a mountain
game two as well. Because that was the
moment where he started to come back. I
thought the Beast Below was going to be
the back-breaking moment, but he did the
Bilge Your Beast Below at home with the
Switcheroo plus the Rebuke and then put
himself in position. We talk about it
time and time again. You just need to
get yourself into a position to strike.
>> For was the first one to the seven point
on the climb game, then got to eight to
try to get this sneaky hold win off the
ride to win.
Again, we talk about knowing your path
to victory. This is knowing your path
and then some.
>> Yes, it is. And the thing is even in
that spot, there is four Runes still
four or five actually, I think available
for Kukulkan. There were a lot of
options. There were many things you lose
to. He went through the bin kind of, you
you calculated the odds and said, you
know what? I'm not going to if I don't
do it, so I might as well try."
>> thing is is when he showed the hand at
the end, there was a hard bargain. I
think that Coco was kind of banking on,
"Okay, if there's like a rebuke or
something, I have the hard bargain."
But, like I said, you can't hard bargain
the kitty. Rengar came in clutch.
>> Certainly did. I am now thinking
how many runes were up when Ride the
Wind was played?
>> Uh I believe there was four exactly
because it was either four or three
because we know he at least played the
Rengar after the fact, right? Uh there
might have been four and so he thought,
"Okay,
uh perhaps he could pay for the repeat."
Or maybe even with the three up, it was
enough for him to say, "I don't want to
play it and have him pay."
>> the Falling Star. That's why.
>> Oh, yeah. It was the Falling Star.
>> Star. So, you can't even do it. I can't
even do
All right. Well, with that, we are going
to go down to our winner. Prismacism has
finally done it. So, let's hear from the
winner himself.
>> Everybody, I am here with the Atlanta
Regional Qualifier Champion,
Prismacismism.
Congratulations.
Yes, let's make some noise.
My word, you top eight in Bologna, top
eight in Las Vegas, top four in Lille,
but now you are top one. You fought
through over 1,500
participants here in Atlanta in the main
event. Kind of give me some vision here.
What's going through your mind? How are
you feeling?
>> You're making me start shaking and
saying those numbers like that. Like
It's always It always feels like
climbing a mountain almost where every
single game is one step higher, another
pile of bodies left behind, and then you
just go after day one already so high
up, still have a lot of rounds left. And
then I I think at previous regionals
when I got to top eight, that felt like
I got to the top, and then I I let off
the gas a bit, and it's taken some
practice and experience to be able to
push past that.
>> Absolutely. And you showed that you have
that experience, that mental fortitude,
and you did overcome. But, I kind of
want to ask you, what was it like? What
did you do or what didn't you do to get
here to the top one spot this time?
>> I mean, I did push-ups against Collin
after I lost game one. That was That was
a good choice. And then I think I got in
his head a bit cuz he did push-ups after
game two. So, that That was great. And I
managed to keep my emotions under
control. I think I got a bit sad at the
end of game three. I did make a misplay
in that game, but
I still kept my head in the game, and I
I found the one out that I had to be
able to win still.
>> Absolutely. You kept your head in the
game, and I just want to point out you
have so many people here surrounding
you, cheering you on, supporting you. Is
there anything you want to say? I kind
of want to open the floor to you. Is
there anything you want to say to the
people that are cheering you on, that
helped you get here, or even to the
people who are aspiring to be in your
shoes at a future regional qualifier?
>> Yeah, I mean, shout-out big shout-out to
Allen.
Big practice partner, teammate,
supporting me a lot through everything.
And shout-out to the rest of my
teammates on I guess we're team
strategem unofficially, but all of them.
And shout-out to the community. Everyone
has been amazing. Like, I haven't had a
single
basically ever a bad experience with an
opponent or anyone. Always happy to talk
about the game afterwards, talk about
decks. Just cheer each other on. It's
It's been amazing.
>> Absolutely. Well, I'm not going to hold
you back any longer. The time has
finally come. We're going to present to
you the Rift Bound Regional Qualifier
trophy. Go ahead and lift your head
high. Lift that trophy up.
Congratulations to Brimmstone
It It It them.
And we're going to send it back to you,
casters. Go ahead and close us out here.
>> Well, it's been an incredible weekend
here in Atlanta. The sights and sounds
of the convention hall have been buzzing
all weekend long and the Regional
Qualifier Atlanta is finally finished
with. Folks, I hope you had a fun time.
We certainly have. For myself, Chib and
Miss Chim Chim Kangas and the entire
broadcast crew, my goodness, it's fun to
do these things and I hope we get to
come back again. Spirit Forge is finally
over as we do enter a new era in a new
usher of Rift Bound with Unleash coming
right up. But at the end of it all,
there could only be one. So many
players, so many legends, so many decks
forged their path through this RQ.
Master Yi, Azir, Annie, Draven, so many
more champions, so many best of
medalists. But at the end of it all, we
had an incredibly stacked top eight.
Alan ZQ is in there. We had Draven
fighting for the slot once again, our
number one seed through the Swiss. But
Prismatices when he sat down had one
singular goal this event. The best of
Annie didn't matter. Already won it, had
two on the table when he sat down. Cocoa
Lopez, the fearful Draven opponent, was
looking for it all. But after nine games
of Rift Bound, there can only be one.
And while the nerves may strike gods,
the weight is there. It is heavy and so
is their account. But Prismatices can
finally hold his head high because that
one thing they wanted this entire time
is done. Rift Bound Atlanta, you've been
incredible and we'll see you next time.
>> Mhm.